good morning everyone and welcome to the
New Hampshire House of Representatives
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have several
bills noticed for this morning and this
afternoon as well as an executive
session in between but before we get all
to get to any of that please join me in
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
thank you very much uh the first bill to
be uh heard this morning is House Bill
1278 FN and I'll recognize the prime
Thomas thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee this is going to be an
interesting day we've got a lot of
Canabis bills uh to bring
forward so uh I am representative Wendy
Thomas I represent the town of marac uh
along with seven other
Representatives uh I'm here today to
introduce House Bill 7 uh 1278 um which
is relative to qualifying medical
conditions for purposes of therapeutic
cannabis as a legislature we keep
identifying conditions allowed under the
New Hampshire therapeutic
program since I've first worked as a rep
we've tackled insomnia opioid usage and
anxiety we keep adding new conditions as
they become known and how are they known
we read books and we talk to patients
I've actually connected online with two
authors of um cannabis books this past
this past year um and ask them questions
about about their research that they've
done they let us know how the program
works and how cannabis works I started
in the therapeutic program five years
ago because of chronic pain for me it
was a car versus a bike accident when I
was a kid since being in the program
I've also used cannabis for insomnia
eating issues gut issues PTSD
PTSD and anxiety I have found relief
from all of these symptoms some of which
of which are not covered in the
program I talked to many many people
about therapeutic cannabis they want to
get into the program they want to see if
cannabis helps their condition no one in
the Cannabis program uses cannabis to
feel high or inebriated I spoke to a
caretaker in Maine and she shared with
me a wise truth if you're getting high
on therapeutic on therapeutic cannabis
you're using it wrong however the
biggest concern I hear is will I qualify
because I don't fit into the current
patient model these are all examples of
cases that would not qualify but which
should in my humble opinion for the
therapeutic cannabis program I'm having
surgery and I understand it will be
painful for a few months cannabis can
help with that I have IBS but not
Crohn's disease cannabis can help with
that I have long Co I have a procedure
done regularly that gives me anxiety in
my my case that would be dental work I'm
getting older when I work out I'm really
sore the next
day and I've also heard many many times
over I have serious period
cramps the recent HHS report on
descheduling cannabis identifies
additional uses that cannabis has been
found helpful for these conditions
include ALS autism wasting cancer
chronic pain Crohn's disease epilepsy or
conditions causing features glaucoma HIV
AIDS multiple sclerosis Parkinson's
disease persistent severe muscle spasm
persistent severe nausea PTSD and
spasticity chronically ill patients are
not interested in being zoned out on the
couch we have had enough of that and we
want the coach to put us back in the
into the game so why are we potentially
denying New Hampshire patients relief
just because we haven't gotten around to
getting their symptoms or condition into
law and on a qualifying list I
understand that many Physicians are not
interested in anything about cannabis
however there are many Physicians who
are willing to learn about how this
plant can help their patients they are
willing to look at reports and read
literature that gives new information
about possible uses they are willing to
let their patients try something
different that has been demonstrated to
work recently the the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board voted 7
to one to support this bill I'm going to
let the honorable Jerry kerk uh expand
on that
one um and there's a repeal portion to
this bill that I'm going to let Mr Holt
uh speak to
that if this bill does not pass at the
very least you will see me here next
term advocating that long covid
situational anxiety menstrual pain and
gut dysfunction be added as symptoms to
this program let's stop trying to
practice medicine and let Physicians
treat their patients as they see fit I'm
happy to take any
questions any questions for
representative
Thomas representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question you sort of
addressed this but um given the way the
um medical cannabis law works now with
specific conditions only
I'm wondering if you've had talks with
Physicians about their preference in
terms of having a lot more subjectivity
as they would have um if your bill were
to become law um and whether they feel
more comfortable being able to um
qualify People based on categories or
whether they would have would be more
comfortable having um a great deal more
discretion as your bill would give
them the Physicians that I've spoken to
that Embrace uh therapeutic Canabis
thank you for the question uh that
Embrace therapeutic cannabis and that go
out of their way to understand it are
very open to prescribing it for
additional uh symptoms that are not on
on the the the
list um the the case that that comes up
to mind is that
um so I had had massive um I think I've
testified before I have cancer and so
I've had three massive cancer surgeries
the last surgery that I had which was a
revision to to take care of
complications I had from previous
surgeries The Physician prescribed
opioids two weeks before surgery to make
sure that I had it in hand for use
afterwards it was not an ongoing
prescription is a one-time prescription
I've talked to Physicians that have said
they would like theer opportunity to
prescribe the Cannabis program for
postsurgery pain as AO I mean we can
prescribe opioids but we can't right now
prescribe therapeutic cannabis which has
been proven by that HHS report to uh
help with with pain so um it's cases
like that there's also cases um and I
haven't spoken to a lot of Physicians
I've spoken to my primary physician who
is very open to this I've spoken to some
surgeons
who are somewhat open um but a lot of
them have said that that especially now
that HHS has proven that it is a
medicine that that is that works they
would like to be able to use it in other
instances follow up thank you so are I
should know more about this than I do
but I don't so um so are you saying that
in anticipation of a surgery which will
probably cause a great deal of pain
um that is not that is not a legitimate
use of medical cannabis now because the
person is not in pain yet correct or
short or short term correct the
qualification is chronic pain and I
think chronic pain is defined as it's
either three or six months and I believe
um The Honorable Jerry coner can can is
it three or
six all right it's it's a defined amount
of time so if for example I'm having an
artificial knee joint replay or joint
put in that's going to be painful for a
certain amount of time and then it's not
going to be painful so that situation is
situational pain it's not chronic
pain representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you so much for
bringing this bill to us um I'm not I I
assume you probably are aware that
there's a discussion in changing the
schedule federally from class one to
class three but as a class three drug it
would be most likely treated as any
other um FDA regulated drug which may
actually have implications in uh the
recreational Market which would
foreclose any opportunity for people to
seek out recreational cannabis for what
is actually a medical need do you think
that this bill would actually allow us
to protect more people if uh cannabis
starts being actually being treated um
access their access to cannabis is
actually restricted um if as a class
three drug the FDA starts to
intervene
yes sorry I know that was a big question
um you know I mean the the the
rescheduling it it's about time it's
about time we all you know those of us
that are in this field we know that
cannabis works we know that there are
less uh biological effects on the body
it is more if you're in pain it is more
healthier for your body to take cannabis
your liver and your kidneys are going to
thank you as opposed to self-medicating
with alcohol which is what a lot of
people do now because we don't have
access um I have access to cannabis but
a lot of people don't have access to
cannabis
um as far as as more people being open
to the or have access to the program if
you look at the financial note um
towards the bottom it says though
indeterminable the department estimates
the bill may result in up to a 10% %
growth increasing Revenue by
$70,000 per year which would uh function
to um to lower the application fee so
this this bill Not only would it help
Physicians treat their patients um it
would also help the patients in that it
would lower costs so I don't know if
that answered everything thank you it
did and I apologize for peeking around a
couple corners but working as a medical
device analyst for a long time I know
that sometimes the FDA does interesting
things so that's why I wanted to ask you
about that and I appreciate your answer
yeah thank
you other
McKay thank you Mr
chairman um I had the privilege or I'm
not sure what it was of being chairman
of the committee I think it ran for four
or five years so I wondered if you talk
to U Mr Holt and also the gentleman
that's sitting right behind you who's
the chairman of a of a continuing
Committee in other words the the work
has been going on for quite a while so I
wondered if you have involved yourself
with those two
gentlemen in in preparation for this
legislation you're talking about Mr Halt
and The Honorable kerk yes of course of
course I have they're
they're they're brick walls in this not
brick walls that's the wrong
analogy they're very important uh
yes rck wall I didn't mean to call you a
brick wall my apologies you meant
Foundation I meant I meant yeah what
yeah solid Imperia uh yeah always
reliable whatever that is invaluable
resource
valuable resource thank you thank you Mr
chair other
questions I actually have one
representative Thomas you had mentioned
long Co and what were the other
conditions you were talking about um if
you don't mind repeating them oh sure um
long covid situational anxiety which
um that means if you have a regular
procedure like if you have a cancer scan
or if you have dental work um a lot of
people get anxiety and doctors prescribe
Valium for that um and we could
prescribe cannabis um menstrual pain is
a huge one um ask any college female
what they use for menstrual pain and
almost all of them will say cannabis or
that they know that cannabis helps and
gut dis gut dysfunction which would
cover IBS and gut dysfunction that is
not Crohn's
disease and that's just a very short
list that is a very short list
there's so many things out there and if
second these are the books that I read
about cannabis and every time I see a
new symptom I write it
down looks pretty thorough yeah yeah I
yeah some people read novels I read
cannabis books um but it's it's so
important and the thing is it's people
use cannabis the way people use alcohol
so alcohol was invented for us to sort
of recreationally feel good right but
when my babies were teething what was I
told rub Whiskey on their gums so we've
learned we've adapted we've found a new
use for alcohol when I was young and I
was sick with uh with bronchitis or
something my mother would give me
something that she called Grandma's
recipe
it's hot tea lemon honey and Crown Royal
whiskey so we've learned to use uh
alcohol in different ways and people
have learned to use cannabis in
different ways and once again and this
is why we can never get rid of this
program it needs education it need we
need to to teach the patients how to use
cannabis and if you are using the
therapeutic program to get inebriated
you're not doing it correctly
thank you other
questions I'm see no other question
thank
you also signed up to speak is former
Kar
thank you Mr chair um yes for the record
my name is Jerry kerk and I'm the chair
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight
board the also known as TCM o and TCM o
is uh comprised primarily of providers
and is statutorily charged with
oversight medical oversight of the
therapeutic cannabis
program um when representative Thomas
has already covered a number of the
issues about things that cannabis us it
works for and there's a lot of evidence
uh strong evidence in addition to
anecdotal and our program serves about
13,000 patients uh most of them are
between ages 50 and 70 uh yes TCM did
vote 7 to1 to support this
bill now to understand the importance of
this bill or the impact of this bill
it's important to understand the rather
cumbersome produ process of
certification to be able to use cannabis
as a therapeutic cannabis patient since
it is a schedule one drug it cannot be
prescribed by a provider so therefore
the pr the provider uh has to certify
the patient as having both a medical
qualifying condition and a qualifying
symptom the statute then confers
protection upon the patient for the use
of cannabis for that particular uh
condition and symptom knowledge of the
use of therapeutic use of cannabis is is
growing a great deal it's been hampered
because of it being a schedule one drug
but in any case it's still growing and
bills are filed every year to request
new conditions be approved and one of
the primary jobs of tcob is really in a
way to act like the FDA we don't really
but we sort of like that we review bills
and see whether there's sufficient
evidence of benefit of cannabis to allow
the condition to be placed in statute
and then we REM we recommend it to the
legislature who then acts upon it
so the point is hp1 1278 offers an
alternative process for certifying and
that's important to realize it doesn't
just say a whole bunch of other
conditions are good it doesn't say that
but it offers an alternative process
allowing more provider discretion but
with clear safeguards in
place the provider still does not
directly prescribe cannabis because we
can't but they then certify that a
patient has either a condition or a
symptom for which in their clinical
opinion they feel that the benefits of
cannabis would outweigh the risks
there's been discussion in the past
about just get getting rid of this list
of qualifying conditions and symptoms
and just make patient certification at
the discretion of the provider that's
been discussed in the past but we have
to realize that not all providers have a
good knowledge of the therapeutic use of
cannabis and they don't have an FDA to
guide them as to what you know whether
it's reasonable or not so this bill is a
very good compromise and that it allows
some provider discretion for those who
are knowledgeable about therapeutic
cannabis the way I've been looking at it
is it really sets up a two tier system
for
certification P providers who really
have a very limited knowledge of the
therapeutic use of cannabis would still
use the standard approach of Consulting
a list of statutory conditions and
symptoms to certify a patient that route
would still be present in statute the
new tier would be available for the
providers who do know more about the
therapeutic
cannabis it they they they feel that
they can make a reasonable appropriate
decision as far as the risks and
benefits of cannabis just as they make
an informed decision on the use of any
other medication including the off Lael
use of FDA medications so in other words
if you don't know a whole lot you can
look at the list and say yep you've got
chronic pain I'll certify you got that
the state says that's okay you're
protected the person who spends a lot of
time and is really kept up on that
literature can say you know it's not on
that list but I really think it's a good
chance this will help you and in your
case the benefits outweigh the risks and
so I'm going to certify you so it's an
alternative
approach um a couple of minor issues but
are important though if we look uh at
the bill on lines four and five the word
that is used is or for this Standalone
qualifying condition but the word in
statute currently for regular is and
now the point is that when the program
was designed you had to have a condition
and you also had to have a symptom and
sometimes it's hard to link a condition
and a symptom together sometimes our our
prescribing is is uh basically
symptom-driven so for example they say
you have a stuffy nose we don't go to
all kinds of detailed testing to try to
figure out exactly whether you got a
cold or you got a flu or whatever just
prescribe a decongestant for the stuff
you knows it's a symptom-driven
prescribing so this bill allows in a way
a symptom-driven
prescribing so let's say you have some
anxiety we don't have to delve into all
the reasons why you do we you could be
certified um there are safeguards that
are really quite good in this bill as
well the it limits provider discretion
uh to certification of adults 21 years
of age older and that's really quite
appropriate given the risk of cannabis
in
kids Mr con if you could start wrapping
up please yep I I have two sentences I
think left uh limiting provider
discretion as well to debilitating or
terminal medical conditions or symptoms
also assures it will only be used in
impactful conditions and symptoms and
not capric capriciously so bottom line
in summary TCM urges passage of 1278 to
enable provider discretion in certifying
patients to streamline the certification
process and I'd be glad to take any
questions thank you thank you
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also Dr
kerk The Honorable Dr kerk it's nice to
see you back here in the chamber thank
you in regards to Providers one of the
things I think I heard was the level of
knowledge the provider may have dealing
with
cannabis is there a possibility then to
create a certification of those
providers who have that knowledge and if
they have it let them at that point in
time not have to deal with a list and at
that point in time if you have somebody
who doesn't have that level of knowledge
certification whatever we call it then
you go into a list of what you have what
you can and cannot do I'm just trying to
look at it and saying how do we take
some of the barriers out of this if the
provider has the appropriate knowledge
then why are we micromanaging it well
the from the beginning the program has
not required a provider to be certified
and the reason partly is it would add a
cumbersome bureaucracy we'd have to
develop some kind of um testing
procedure to determine competency um in
many respects you think about it any
provider is already if they're already
licensed and they already are
uh uh they ALS also have a DEA license
they've already demonstrated a level of
competence in terms of understanding and
thinking about medications and we
certainly do that if we prescribe an off
Lael use of an FDA approved medication
we're looking at the FDA isn't backing
us on that because the company didn't go
through the you know years of testing
and hundreds of millions of dollars but
instead you're saying look we got pretty
decent evidence that it works in this
and they make that judgment and you know
I mean in general I would hope that for
me as a spine surgeon I wasn't going
there and doing all kinds of off label
prescribing for psychiatric medicine I
shouldn't because I I didn't know that
stuff I'm not being I'm not trained in
that so as a result you would hope that
the provider would use their usual
discretion of saying um they I I I know
enough I can do this or I don't know
enough I can do this but I think that
certification just adds more
administrative
burden thank you thank you Mr chair I
concur with what you're talking about Dr
kerk however by creating a list in the
statute and what we're doing here we're
creating another level of bureaucracy so
I'm trying to find out how to minimize
that level of bureaucracy I know we're
creating another level of bureaucracy
but there one less honorous than the
other that's what I'm trying to get to
well I think one of the things about
this in this bill it doesn't require
that that we have a bureaucracy to
assess whether that provider's decision
is appropriate that is not in the bill
which I think is okay because again we
don't do that for non FDA approved drug
label use but instead you we have a
responsibility if some provider is
really going off the wall and doing some
pretty weird things just as they would
for standard uh FDA approved medications
the board their disciplinary board would
look into this that that's where any
thing would go but that' have to be
pretty egregious as it would have to be
for regular
medicines thank you representative
Missour thank you Mr chair thank you
doctor for taking my question um here it
says that TCM o voted 7 to1 to support
this bill um just
curious what was the reasoning that one
person did not um yeah see I'm looking
quickly at my
recall
um I'm sorry I do not recall why that
person voted
against sorry and I don't recall who it
was my
apologies representative Shapiro and
then representative Lon I'm I'm sorry
you had a follow up I'm sorry would it
be possible to get that
information um May I consult with I'd be
I'm just really curious to know that I
don't know I don't know if uh Mr Holt
does that's right that's okay that's
that's who I thought it was but I wasn't
sure um he confirmed for me that the
person who voted no actually did not
participate in the discussion he didn't
say anything about why he felt that way
he just voted no so I was pretty sure
that I that I just didn't want to State
something I wasn't certain of okay
representative Shapiro and then
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman to piggyback on the um previous
question
um you had pretty pretty good consensus
but not complete consensus um and if you
don't know what that person's reasons
were um certainly you've encountered or
maybe you've encountered other pres not
prescribers but um what's the proper
word um you've encountered other um
people who were able to qualify people
who are resistant to this idea of more
discretion more subjectivity um if you
have yeah what what would the what would
the argument on the other side be I
think often times it just rolls down to
saying well you know we we don't have
the FDA to really kind of give us the
backup we don't have as much of data as
we would like and we certainly agree
with that this is something that's
proactive I mean you know any provider
really ought to be looking at the data
before they start giving people
medications and if it's pretty weak they
might want to think twice about that and
that's true in cannabis as well I think
it's important to
realize running this particular board
tcob is really like hurting cats because
I've got people who are basically almost
anti-cannabis to people who are very Pro
cannabis and trying to get even close to
unanimous is a real task and it takes a
lot of work so but that gives us
strength because it means we don't just
all kind of lock Step Go the same way we
end up trying to compromise with what we
come up with on our recommend
commendations because we have to because
I if I walk in here with a four to six
recommendation it didn't mean a whole
lot to
you representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you so much for
coming back and uh all your involvement
in this um my question is um has to do
with the bill that we we passed last
year last term about the off Lael
prescribing where for the FDA approved
drugs somebody would have protection
from um an inquiry from the licensing
board um if they prescribed
FDA approved drug off label um it would
be my understanding that the medical
board has no such restrictions on
looking into any pres any any
recommendations that people have for
cannabis so that if it appears that this
is this is moving out of control the
medical board would probably be the
appropriate place and they're fully
enabled to do so is that your
understanding too well that that's my
understanding too is that any if
somebody is really going off the wall
that the medical board would be just
like they would for anything else if
people are doing inappropriate surgeries
or they're doing uh prescribing of FDA
drugs inappropriately it's the medical
board that would say wait a minute you
know that this is not the standard of
practice not even
close thank you yes yes pres McLean
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um with respect to the the
21y year age restriction um in in the uh
in the in the new edition that doesn't
exist in the existing schedule since
you're kind of creating two-tier those
familiar those providers who are
familiar versus those who are not
um would you not want to have that
available to folks younger than 21 um so
what would if you could dive a little
bit deeper into the thinking as to why
that restriction is there well we do
have a restriction for minors in the
program already and they require a
second certification so if you're seeing
a specialist who says gee you know I
think you would be benefiting uh you
benefit from the use of therapeutic
cannabis you have to get a secondary
certification
from a medical provider that currently
says from a pediatrician we have a bill
in the Senate which trying to change
that to be a provider who provides
pediatric care because so it could be a
family practice person because in the
reality a lot of people don't have
pediatricians up in the North Country um
so there is that's why we only have
about 10 kids certified in the program
because there are rather robust
safeguards and we feel that that is a
setting where you want to have uh in a
sense the approval of TCM o in the
legislature that it's okay to prescribe
in that setting but even there we have
battles uh internally in TCM o about you
know what we still allow for kids so we
didn't with this is a provider
discretion we are comfortable with the
idea that we would not provide
discretion for that age group under 21
be a little more rigid on that followup
so so even with a secondary um
recommendation
noo well that that's currently how this
is written and that's what we agreed
with I think that certainly could be an
amendment that could be placed saying
that it could be at any age but anybody
under 21 requires certification by a
provider of pediatric care that could be
placed in his Amendment but I think the
demand for that will be relatively small
um I'm not sure thank you very much yes
other
questions seeing n thank you okay thank
you
oh actually may I say just one other
quick thing about the schedule three
we've been talking about that for
decades we've been talking you know this
to wait for that doesn't make sense I
think it's okay to move with this if it
becomes moot
great also signed up to speak is
Howard thank you Mr chairman and
committee members uh I really appreciate
you having me here today so I really
support this bill because of my own
personal experiences uh when I was 16
years old I broke my back I had an L4
burst fracture and uh 2020 I had a uh
one of those rods actually broke uh so I
had to have a secondary surgery to take
all of that Hardware out and uh through
that I dealt with a lot of chronic pain
I still do and uh I am uh currently uh
on I'm a part of the uh therapeutic
cannabis program
and that was a challenge for me to get
on it was a long process dealing with
pain management doctors over at
Wentworth Douglas they did a good job of
making sure that I uh was following the
proper procedures and uh were taking
proper care before moving on and going
through uh the uh the Cannabis route
because I have refused uh any opiates I
prefer not to uh take them if I can and
it it's something where uh luckily we
have changed the requirement to uh
remove the uh secondary uh testing of
medications before you move on to uh the
Cannabis program and I think that there
are potentially a number of other people
suffering from other conditions that are
allowed in other states but we haven't
necessarily prove them here for our
qualifying conditions and going through
an allowing ing providers to make the
proper decision for their patients and
what would fit them best I think would
serve the state well that's all I have
thank you thank
you any questions for representative
you also signed up to speak is Michael
Holt from the Department of Health and
Human
Services
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh my name is Michael Holt I'm
the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program I've been involved with
the program since in its Inception in
2013 um thank thank you for the few
minutes that I two minutes that I can uh
take to to add some clarity to this bill
I wanted to point out that there is
another provision in this bill that
hasn't been discussed this is the repeal
this is line nine where it uh the bill
proposed bill would repeal RSA 126
x2v relative to limitations for a
visiting
patient so this bill would remove those
restrictions for visiting out ofate
patients uh on in 2021 the uh the state
law changed to allow out ofate patients
to access the New Hampshire dispensaries
um and currently the law says that a
visiting patient can have three visits
at per year at a New Hampshire
dispensary um and after which they need
to show medical documentation that they
have a medical condition on the New
Hampshire list so when this when this
law was proposed in
2021 um a parity issue was raised um New
Hampshire has a smaller restrictive list
of qualifying conditions than many other
states and more importantly New
Hampshire does not have what's being
proposed here which is a a catchall an
any condition catchall that provides
discretion to Providers broadly for
certification of any condition so the
concern was raised in the Senate that it
would not be fair to New Hampshire
citizens if we allowed an out ofate
patient who was certified in their state
for a condition not on the New Hampshire
list say anxiety to access the New
Hampshire
atc's when New Hampshire citizens
couldn't access the program with the
same condition so they put in this this
parody uh uh Clause that says you get
three visits before you have to show
that you have a New Hampshire condition
so this bill as proposed would add such
a catch-all any condition
um creating parody with other states
it's very common for other states to
allow certification for any condition
based on provider discretion New
Hampshire does not so if the bill as
proposed moves forward to allow any
condition it removes this parody issue
so I just wanted to give you uh give the
committee the knowledge about what that
repeal provision was about I'm happy to
answer questions about that or anything
else with regard to the bill I would say
one thing the department can
operationalize this uh new uh two-tiered
certification system without issue by
amending U the written
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question
um Dr kerk mentioned the two-tier system
and you just mentioned it again so what
is the
purpose of having a two-tier system and
what potential potential downside is
there to having a two-tier system if the
um if if the medical providers are going
to have this great discretion why have
the conditions remain in the statute
that are
there why not repeal all the the
specific conditions and just have um
provider discretion well that is not the
bill in front of us right um I'd be
happy to talk about a different model um
the legislature has uh in the past uh
reviewed a bill that would have repealed
all the conditions and given providers
complete discretion with no guidance
whatsoever um and that and that was
killed a number of years ago um and so
based on that legislative history a uh a
model that keeps the current system but
adds another uh uh way of of C for
certification I Believe by the sponsors
was uh was the way forward at this time
um the current system is inadequate it
prevents people from accessing the
program even if their providers uh see
value um in trying this alternative
therapy um and so the the current system
is does restricts access um it restricts
provider discretion and so that's why we
need at least this additional process
for
certification
um I'd be happy to consider other models
but it was that model that you're
proposing was killed a number of years
ago follow up follow up um thank you for
your answer and I I I'm probably was I
was asking for an opinion on which is
preferable but you're probably not the
to I'm in favor of whatever uh models
allow access to as many patients who
want to try this alternative therapy and
have the support of their physician or
their the medical provider uh to access
the program thank you representative
McCay thank you Mr
chairman Mr Holt has been involved with
with this for years in fact he was
probably the only person in the
department that uh did this work for a
very long time so he should be commended
for that the the one question I have is
that
this process will produce
$70,000 a year and that
$70,000 goes outside of the department
the department has um it it
says
um where is
it apply to the program there will be a
application received by the department
the department estimates the
bill under it sounds as if it lowers the
cost for the people providing the
marijuana instead of increasing some
staff uh uh function uh so if the 70,000
is staying in the department then I'm
curious as to how that is being spent
and uh whether that's giving you some
support uh uh out of that
7,000 well first of all thank you for
the uh the generous words um I have been
working on the program for uh for about
10 years um and um so thank you for that
with regard to the fiscal note um the uh
LBA recently changed their uh change
their processes whereby when we do
fiscal notes for proposed legis ation uh
we can no longer say indeterminable
without having a range so part of this
this information is specifically in
response to LBA rules for us to um
provide an estimate when we really do
not know what kind of fiscal impact this
so so so that's that's that's one thing
we I believe that this will result in
many more patients uh being certified
for the program but I also believe that
this proposal will
reorient um uh patients currently on the
program the next year for certification
a doctor will use this second tier to
certify um uh anxiety for instance many
people are being certified under PTSD
when they have anxiety and perhaps don't
have a a diagnosis of PTSD so I it's
it's hard to say how much this is going
to improve the revenue um that being
said this program is 100% self-funded
through patient fees and through ATC
licensing fees and so whatever Revenue
that we get the the state gets from
patients if that is less than our costs
we will build the atcs for the
difference so that's what this is this
is trying to describe um I will say with
regard to Patient fees uh two years ago
the just uh the law changed to allow
providers to issue certifications up to
three years um we did not raise our rate
we did not raise our fees our fees have
been $50 uh uh for um a card since day
one and now under the new law with a
three-year certification the fees are
still $50 $50 for one year $50 for three
years so we're at we're at place of
stability with the the the the program
finances um and so I don't uh I would
not
characterize this bill and this language
as suggesting that money will go outside
the system it's more of a description
about how the system works where when we
don't receive enough revenue from
patients we're allowed to build the atcs
for the
difference thank you very much because
it it concerned me that there's been
such a lack of support for this program
that the money would be going elsewhere
and if it's not I'm very pleased to hear
that it's a dedicated fund all the money
stays in the system we've been uh
working for years to stabilize the
program uh we have sufficient support in
the department now um under the division
of Public Health Services um and um to
to the extent that we were you know we
were we were able to essentially reduce
patient fees by two-thirds based on that
um uh that recent legislation that
allowed threeyear certifications thank
you thank you other question
you uh the last person signed up to
testify this morning on U House Bill
cannabis thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee for the record my name is Matt
Simon I currently work for granite Leaf
cannabis uh no problem uh we're one of
the three alternative treatment center
companies in New Hampshire uh nonprofit
focused solely on serving New Hampshire
dispensaries in
Chichester and miramac um and we support
this bill uh my comments will stem more
for my involvement uh 10 to 13 years ago
is the legislature was debating and
ultimately passing this law in
2013 a lot of the rhetoric surrounding
the bill was based on the idea that that
if a doctor believes a patient can
benefit from Cannabis then who is the
state of New Hampshire to stand between
the doctor and the patient and the law
that we ended up passing uh did not give
doctors the discretion to determine if
if cannabis might be right for a given
patient we instead use the system that
we created which I'm I'm fine with and I
would Echo everything that uh former
representative kerk said and and the
sponsor said about creating the
two-tiered system we're not breaking the
thing that's been working for 10 years
what we would be doing by passing this
is simply allowing doctors to be doctors
do their jobs if they have a patient who
doesn't have something on the list and
they believe it's a unique case it does
create a higher threshold they have to
attest to their opinion in writing and
say that they believe that the benefits
would outweigh the risks for the patient
so I support the bill as is I think it's
great I want to comment brief YY on the
rescheduling issues since there were a
number of questions about that I've been
reading everything that I can find on
the prospect of rescheduling of course
we don't know whether it will happen or
not it it rests with the DEA currently
but let's say that it is approved as
many of us hope everything that I've
read suggests that rescheduling is not
going to have any impact on state level
therapeutic or quote unquote
recreational cannabis regul ation that
moving it to schedule 3 would have a
number of benefits it would make
research somewhat easier it would likely
lead to the development of new drugs
that would be put through the FDA
approval process uh but the FDA is not
in the business of approving plants and
the idea of putting whole plant cannabis
through the FDA approval process my
understanding is that's very unlikely to
ever happen uh so changes will likely
occur but it it's not expected to change
anything with regard to state level
programs and as one example I could
point out uh Congress passed the farm
bill in 2018 legalizing
hemp hemp has been federally legal for 5
years and there still are no federal
regulations for CBD or any other hemp
derived cannabinoid we've been waiting 5
years and nothing has happened yet so I
would agree with the ments that we can't
wait for the federal government we have
to try to pass the best laws we can to
benefit the citizens of New Hampshire
and I would be happy to answer any
questions thank you any questions
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for those
comments um when I raised that issue I
viewed that this is actually drisking um
New Hampshire patients um if we do
approve this um would you agree that if
there are other restrictions because
this is being done through doctors and
that's the way that Pharmaceuticals are
dealt with that that would drisk the
access to these
patients and if you can't have a firm
answer that's all right yeah no thank
you for the question I I don't believe
there's any risk to patients to begin
with so uh you can't drisk zero but
thank
you other
you also signed up to speak is Heather
Hampshire could you push the button for
the microphone I have to push it yes do
I have to hold it no no once the right
once the red light goes on you all thank
you for that uh instruction um yeah I'm
Heather Stockwell I work at rights and
democracy I'm the healthcare organizer
I've been doing this work for uh
approximately six years now and I talk
to people about their health care every
day um I'm also a patient and the reason
I'm speaking here today over other
people that work at rights and democracy
um is that I have the most knowledge
about this I too read a lot of Articles
and books about cannabis um and I have
for longer than six years
um I like millions of Americans uh did
before this program use uh what is
considered Rec recreational
um I would use the term adult use I now
uh I'm gonna I'm going to pause there
for a second
um I'm not a medical card holder yet in
the state of New Hampshire and that's
why I'm speaking today because I have
faced barriers in getting that card and
part of that is really because of the
provider side of things because they are
so not knowledgeable in fact I go into
appointments having more knowledge than
my own provider on this
topic I have
many many
qualifying conditions I I should be able
to get a card some of them are chronic
pain conditions but I
also um have
anxiety uh as well as insomnia these are
both things that I could be treated for
and I really want to talk about the
anxiety part because the first line of
action really for anxiety from providers
is to give you what is known as a benzo
a benzo dipene I believe it's pronounced
there's a lot of evidence that this is a
very addictive and quite strong drug and
I have chosen not to go that route
unless I really feel that I'm incapable
of doing something but I can be capable
of doing things with the anxiety if I
had a cannabis card if it was easier for
me to
get I really appreciate the fact that
this would lower the cost and that the
committee has worked to lower those
costs making $50 a year now it's $50 for
three years that is another barrier to
patients the cost of medical cannabis is
not cheap
and so getting a card and having to
having that barrier of another $50 a
doctor's appointment maybe several
doctor's appointments starts to rack up
especially when you might also be
managing other other health issues you
might have to have
surgery right there are there are a lot
of costs associated with some of these
medical conditions and keeping those
costs down for patients is certainly uh
a big a big
concern um could you start wrapping up
please yes sure I I think that's really
that that's really the last point that I
wanted to make I I personally um in the
past before we had this law um I I used
cannabis to quit smoking I see that
there are so many positive uses for this
and if you're looking at things in terms
of like harm
reduction cannabis is
in my opinion less harmful than so many
of the other substances that we allow
doctors to prescribe and it's really
time for us to see through some of the
nonsense that we have created consider
the FDA uh Ru you know scheduling and
things like that so I really appreciate
uh the time uh that you've taken to hear
hear me out here and hear a patient uh
side of things and I'd be happy to take
any uh questions if anyone has it any
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
much no one else has signed up to
testify on hb1 1278 FN so I'm going to
close the public hearing on that bill
and open the public hearing on HB
1240 uh and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Heath
Howard also I'd like to point out that
uh all of the Bills should be on the
side table but if members of the
committee need those or any others uh
they can see uh Karen Davis and moom
2011 and she'll be happy to to frish
those representative howood welcome back
thank you thank you Mr chairman and uh
committee members so the purpose for hb1
1240 uh is because for me I I somebody
very close to me uh has dealt with
anorexia uh and anorexia is one of the
deadliest mental or is the deadliest
mental health disorder uh killing
anywhere up to 5% of of anybody who's
diagnosed with it and we need to be
ensuring that anybody who has anorexia
is eating it doesn't matter how they get
food it's that they get it and the
States of Maine California New Mexico
North Dakota Illinois Maryland Nevada
Pennsylvania and Oklahoma all have
similar legislation on
record and as we've already kind of
discussed uh in the recent uh FDA uh
report that was released uh we have had
seen uh that in their uh findings they
had used a study from the University of
Florida where in Florida uh there is uh
only one exception for uh treating uh
anorexia with cannabis and that's for
patients uh dealing with cancer uh and I
I apologize but there are limited
studies on uh the effectiveness of uh
cannabis on treating anorexia but they
did find that there was moderate success
in treating uh anorexia with cannabis uh
in this and it was part of the reason
why they decided to recommend uh it to
three so not only can uh cannabis help
provide an appetite for patients dealing
with anorexia but anorexia is a mental
health disorder and there are a lot of
uh there's a lot of anxiety that goes
along with it and of course we already
recognize that cannabis can help people
dealing with this uh so it kind of helps
people on two fronts so if we can help
uh provide cannabis to some of these
people and uh help them actually obtain
hold food then we can actually help save
lives thank you I'm uh open for any
questions questions for representative
Howard representative
Palmer thank you Mr
J
I'm too short thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking the question I'm just
curious about whether Bill 1278 would
cover this yes uh so it would I mean I I
would prefer uh uh HB 1278 uh over this
bill but uh as we know sometimes uh
bills can often uh end up being uh shot
down and ited uh so it's it's always
good to kind of cover our
bases representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for bringing this to us um we heard
before in the previous Bill's hearing
that there's the issue of having both
the underlying um diagnosis and the
symptom would we need to add anything to
those symptoms so that these patients
can actually get the relief that they
need or is that already covered in the
symptoms that are
listed um I that would be best answered
by somebody else okay thank you I just
want to make sure if we do it we do it
right yes of course thank you other
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question and
um I'll just say that it's fine if you
can't or um don't want to answer this um
but but I wonder if you had considered
limiting the covered Eating Disorders to
anorexia since
um since some of the other disorders
include
binging um and I wonder if um using
medicinal cannabis in that case would
have a paradoxical and maybe negative
effect yeah uh so I I mean I would be
open to an amendment uh as as we know
the other uh Eating Disorders listed in
this bill uh would actually benefit from
medicinal cannabis uh but I mean as I
had mentioned with eating disorders it
is a very mental uh it's a very mentally
focused uh problem and it's a mental
health Disorder so if we if somebody
does uh have binge eating disorder they
may benefit from it and I think that
would be best left the
provider thank you other
you also signed up to speak is
Thomas thank you Mr chair um you guys
are going to be sick of seeing me by the
end of today um but that's that's I'm
here for a good reason um I'm
representative Wendy Thomas again from
the town of marac and I am in support of
this bill I want to give you I'm going
to take this off I want to give you um a
personal example of how uh cannabis has
helped an eating disorder in November of
2020 I uh came down with covid um and I
developed long covid and so for a year
and a half I had no smell I could not
smell food I couldn't taste food I had
no appetite and no
thirst um this was called long covid
induced anorexia it was not a mental
condition but I could not eat food uh
there was no desire to eat food and food
actually made me feel ill um many of you
that have served with me before um many
of you didn't even recognize me I lost
80 pounds um and that was because of
malnutrition I could not literally could
not get the food into my body it
wouldn't stay in my body I couldn't
absorb
it three years out I still have
diminished smell taste appetite and
thirst but I can override it now and I
can force myself to
eat I went to many dispensaries I went
to some in Maine I went to some in New
Hampshire and I asked the dis the people
who worked in the dispensary what
strains help with appetite because those
are the people that know the people that
work there the people that use this um
you know the big sort of joke about
cannabis is you you smoke a joint and
then you sit on the couch and eat
Doritos for the rest of the day I looked
forward to having Munchies as their coll
called um never got Munchies I'm
probably the only person in the world
that didn't get munchies from from
Cannabis however the Diesels and the
kushes which are specific strains of
cannabis that lean towards the
indicas they calmed my gut spasms down
enough that I could eat food it would
stay in my body enough that I could I
could absorb the nutrition so here is a
clear eating disorder that was that was
helped with cannabis since since almost
a year ago I've gained 15 pounds back
and I again I'm probably the only person
in the world the only woman in the world
who is thrilled about gaining 15
pounds um so
so uh I I believe it was uh
representative Leon Eating Disorders are
not currently covered um which is why we
would need this bill however if you
passed the previous bill you would never
need to hear another one of these bills
again for a specific condition um and as
far as the question for binging that's
where education comes in if you've got a
patient who's binging and they want
cannabis for an eating disorder that's
probably not an appropriate patient or
condition to to prescribe the the order
for however along with binging usually
comes some kind of anxiety or some kind
of medical condition so it might be but
this is where education for the
providers is going to be very very
important and must be ongoing if you
could please start wrapping up I'm all
done thank you I'm open for questions
questions oh representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um even if
1278 were to pass following up on some
of the testimony on the previous bill
because there are providers that are
maybe not current on all the Lit
Literature
having this passed into law would still
be benefit because it would explicitly
state that this is there am I correct I
I believe you are correct because if we
passed this it would go on to the form
and there the the Physicians that are
not familiar with cannabis are going to
rely on the conditions that are outlined
on that form so it will give them an
idea but if you are familiar with
cannabis you're going to look at the
form and you're going to say okay what I
want is not listed on this form I'm
going to do it this way thank you you're
welcome thank you for the question other
you also signed up to speak is uh former
KARK this time try for the three minutes
okay yes actually this one timed out at
two minutes though I'm going to
respond
um so again uh I don't have to
reintroduce myself except say for the
record Jerry kerk chair of the
theraputic cannabis medical oversight
board um so indeed excuse me hb1 1240
does seek to add a broad spectrum of
Eating Disorders as a qualifying
condition for the therapeutic use of
cannabis tcov voted 6 to1 to not support
support this bill as there's not enough
evidence to take a position at this time
the board feels that there may be some
Merit and some people may benefit but
the literature does not really support
its
use here's the key thing it's important
to understand that Eating Disorders are
not simply a lack of appetite they're
complex psychiatric disorders often
requiring multi modal long-term
psychiatric therapy and as was alluded
to earlier anorexia nervosa can be a
disorder and one of the things about
sort of the psychiatric part for example
part of the disordered behavior of
anorexia nervosa is a sense of
empowerment that comes with resisting
hunger and the temptation to eat and so
treating anorexia nervosa is far more
complex than just stimulating appetite
cannabis doeses have appetite
stimulating effects and that's primarily
from the TC and we do utilize that and
to treat patients with diseases or
treatments such as chemotherapy which
can cause a loss of appetite that's
already in statute but they're not
psychiatric disorders those are a
suppression of appetite due to other
things and what I was looking up quickly
here before coming up and we when look
at that and piece that we spoke about
earlier it's important toe to understand
that the
um the there's a catchall which is uh
existing here and that is at the end of
the conditions is one or more injuries
or conditions that has resulted in one
or more qualifying symptoms under
paragraph two in other words if the
person has an undefined condition that
the provider certifies leads to one of
the symptoms in list two and this is
what's currently in statute they can
qualify and enlist to um is caia and
chemotherapy induced anorexia and
wasting syndrome so for example the
comments about loss of of appetite
secondary to long covid you could
qualify by saying you have long covid
and as a result you have an appetite
suppression you could qualify into that
now this again is one of the areas
though where provider knowledge is
really a problem some providers will
understand that a lot of people will
have no clue um so there are some small
limited small studies on use of
therapeutic cannabis and anorexia
nervosa and one of those was quoted
earlier but that was one of them there
are a handful of studies but the results
have been mixed there are also some have
shown a small amount of gain like a
kilogram of weight over the course of a
month that's not trivial but it's uh
that's that's all and there are also
some potential Harms in using cannabis
and eating disorders including
compensatory disorders of bur purging
and
binging also it's important to
understand that in the group that have
anorexia nervosa there are relatively
High co-occurrence rates of substance
use
disorders there was a result that would
suggest that the use of cannabis for an
eaan disorder may put patients at an
increased risk of cannabis use disorder
please start wrapping up if you could
yes I I I maxed down to two oh actually
a comment earlier um comment about the
Standalone aspect the the the question
was asked about symptoms and conditions
that will not apply because this is put
in as a standalone condition and
therefore it does not fall into that
rubric of needing condition and symptom
so basically until better data is
available TCM o does not support the use
of cannabis to treat Eating Disorders so
we would urge pass going with itl on
this bill rather than passing it thank
you any questions any any questions for
representative K representative King
Seth King thank you Mr chair and thank
you doctor for taking questions um you
supported um HB
1278 and we've also heard from other
testifiers on this bill that if 1278 is
passed this bill becomes sort of moot
because these conditions will be covered
in 1278 how do you square the fact that
you're for 1278 but not for this bill
even though this bill is sort of
encompassed by 1278 thank you well this
would put it in not as a provider
discretion thing but simply as a
statutory approved Standalone condition
so therefore the person who does not
have much knowledge and says I'm not
really sure but I'm looking at this and
it says that it's okay to do it for
anorexia nervosa they would be able to
do it if this
passes if this does not pass but 1278
passes they could not do that but the
person who says I know a lot about this
I actually treat Eating Disorders I'm a
psychiatrist I that's a key thing they
would know a lot about this and I think
in your case it might be worth a trial
then they could certify so that adds
that again higher level of Provider
discretion in the person I mean we got
providers really need to have a certain
element of responsibility that they know
what they know and they know what they
don't know again would I as a spine doc
prescrib this no for this disorder no
but if I were a psychiatrist and I
already treated that patient I have an
established relationship and I think it
might be worth a try they could do that
under 1278 but they could not do it uh
as it is
questions see none thank you okay thank
Hannon good morning good morning uh
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Joe Hannon and I'm
in support of this bill uh I didn't
speak on the previous bill but since
it's come up uh during testimony for
this I'd like to say that I I do believe
that things should be left at the
discretion of uh people that are
Physicians and prescribers uh the
previous uh doctor was a spine surgeon I
was a foot and ankle surgeon uh neither
of us would be generally would prescribe
something for anorexia nervosa or other
Related Disorders however uh I do
believe that uh even though when I was
in the legislature I voted on a lot of
these things uh I didn't feel even as um
an elected representative that it was my
I wouldn't say duty but I I didn't feel
just because I was elected I knew better
and just because I'm a doctor doesn't
mean that I necessarily know better for
everybody or other doctors in patients I
do think it should be left up to the
individual Physicians and prescribers
and the uh the potential patients there
are uh definitely uh studies out there
that show that there's some evidence um
for lots of different conditions
recently the FDA we heard about their
rescheduling recommendation uh to be a
schedule three um they they've indicated
there's a there's uh credible scientific
data to support uh to substantiate the
use of marijuana the treatment of pain
Anor anorexia related to certain medical
conditions and nausea invol vomiting uh
such as chemo-induced um vomiting with
varying degrees of support and
consistency of findings so they did find
evidence and in their review also none
of the they also said none of the
evidence from the systematic reviews
included in their analysis identified
any safety concerns that would preclude
the use of marijuana in the indications
for which there exists some credible
scientific support for its therapeutic
benefit so um as talk about uh these are
not people that are trying necessarily
have an agenda these are FDA scientists
who were told what do you think and this
is what they came up with with review of
uh some of the literature uh you know
we've heard this quote uh the founder of
mod day tox of Toxicology phys Swiss
physician named paracelsus heard this
quote yesterday so I thought I'd bring
it back up again today um the dose makes
the poison everyone wants to know well
how much do you give uh what what is an
effective therapeutic dose uh if a child
has attention deficit disorder they get
riddle in say 10 milligrams three times
a day that may be the appropriate dose
and that'll calm that child down even
though it's a stimulant drug if you give
it to someone an adult they might get
the J get jittery or get anxious so it
depends on the patient depends on the
individual and depends on the condition
if you give that same child instead of
10 you give them 100 milligrams you're
going to notice a difference in their
behavior and it's not going to be calm
it would probably make anybody a little
more uh agitated to say the least and
anxious so everything is um potentially
a poison everything water cannabis
uh you name the the substance it could
probably kill you in the right dose the
fact is uh we can't legislate what
someone should take for attention
deficit for diabetes if the legislature
came uh in session and said we're going
to determine how much insulin you need
to be a diabetic and this is the chart
that's been approved and if you deviate
from that you know we'd kill a lot of
people um so I think it's really
important to leave this to the people
that uh that have gone to school have
gotten a DEA license and these people
write prescriptions for much stronger
and more dangerous uh therapies than
this uh and I do believe I agree with my
colleague that uh you know not it's
important the prescriber knows what they
know and knows what they don't know and
I've never uh when I was prescribing I
never looked at uh the law to say oh
that's how I should do this uh not once
never looked it up and I'm bit of a wonk
when it comes to policy so uh thank you
Dr yeah thank you uh are you taking
questions if you have any any questions
for Dr
Hannah seeing none thank you very much
thank you very
much okay no one else has signed up to
testify on House Bill 1240 so I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill 12 I'm sorry 1240 okay yeah please
Forward I'll let you state your name I'm
yeah my handwriting is much worse but
I'm more familiar with my own
handwriting so thank you for letting me
speak uh I'm representative hope Damon
Sullivan District 8 I serve on Ed
committee which is where I was and
chairman lad reprimands us for
permission I mean for punctuation all
the time I'm here to support this bill I
spent my career as a dietitian probably
50% of my patients were people with
eating
disorders over the course of 40s
something years in that work I developed
relationships with many patients from
seeing them for an extended period of
time as you do with folks with eating
disorders and it became apparent in
many uh
cases that some folks considerably
benefited from being able to use
marijuana um it was not something that I
as a practitioner ever initiated
discussion about um most of the time
that I was in practice medical marijuana
wasn't legal in New Hampshire um but
when it would come up in therapy and
discussions and a patient would
describe how much more able they were to
manage their eating disorder
behaviors it's pretty hard to ignore
that benefit I think these patients
deserve to legally obtain what is
helpful to them use in a wise and
thoughtful way and I fully support this
bill as I was thinking about testifying
on this there were two
particular patients that came to
mind one was an anorexic man he was
probably about 40 if memory serves me
correctly a very
smart very engaged
person I won't speak to his profession
to be sure I respect
confidentiality um but his Capac
capacity intellectually
was um very
high and he was dying he was totally
adequately he refused Residential
Treatment um his parents tried to get
guardianship of him they did not
succeed it was really the stuff that
keeps you awake at night his treatment
team how were we going to help
him and another member of the team
suggested that he try
marijuana and that man is alive today I
wish he was here to testify and if you
met him on the street you would have no
reason to surmise the ordeal that he
went through to get
well it really was an extraordinary
turnaround I'm not suggesting that
marijuana would do that for all people
by with eating disorders by any means
but it was really a life-saving measure
for
him the other case that came to mind
particularly much less dramatic but also
very valuable college student young
woman um binge eating disorder that
became bulimia so she was making herself
sick many times a
day beyond the medical issues of that it
was completely distracting from her
well-being and her ability to be a
capable college
student and similarly obviously lots of
college students um smoke marijuana or
uh utilize it in some other way uh
certainly um suffice to say that that in
fact was also a solution for her so I
thank you for hearing my remarks and I
Bill thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for sneaking away from
education to testify on this I
appreciate it uh my question would be we
had another bill about allowing um
doctors to have more latitude and people
21 and older um do you see this as
necessary to go into the statute
separately so that teenagers and others
who are under that age have the ability
to access this um because I know a lot
of teenagers do reach do have serious
life life-threatening issues around
anorexia thank you for the excellent
question and the answer is yes
um specifically because as you noted
there is such a high incidence of Eating
Disorders in teens and we know that with
eating disorders the sooner that you
effectively treat it the less likelihood
that it becomes a lifetime
condition and if we are not as effective
at early
treatment the long range is um much
harder to manage and the Vitality rate
anorexia is the psychiatric diagnosis
with the highest fatality rate of any
want thank you Mr chair and thank you if
I could have just two questions because
that just so with respect to the prior
legislation which I don't know if you
were here for and the 21 year age
restriction I was not yeah so but based
on your experience as a
dietitian um you would possibly
recommend going back to amend that to
allow people that are younger um with
maybe a second opinion to do that so
that you could intervene at an earlier
period with the caveat that I have not
read that legislation so I want to be
careful that I don't speak without being
informed what you're saying sounds to me
like it makes sense that a person who is
15 or 16 with a restrictive eating
disorder or binge eating disorder could
very much
benefit and I uh appreciate your
suggestion of you'd have two providers
weighing in on that that makes
sense and and then then and my second
question is not related to that but um
the TCM o did not come out in support of
this because they talked about the
literature is not comprehensive enough
or or um it's it's not it it really
doesn't put a stake in the sand per to
say um is there anything you know from
your experience as a dietitian and and
your exposure to maybe literature that
they may not have seen that may kind of
counter that um because you're talking
specifically about anorexia and bulimia
which there is a certain amount of
what's the word I'm not a doctor mental
aspects to it um so are you aware of
anything that might kind of counter uh
those prior comments or or add to
that I have been retired for a year
retired in December 22
um so I haven't kept up in this past
year something about being a rep on
education and housing committee
um so I don't know if there was newer um
research prior to that I would say it
was limited and very small case
populations it's much more anecdotal and
I would say talked about a lot in the
eating disorder Treatment
Community uh I don't know who else
you've heard
testify of other professionals and
eating disorders but I can certainly
reach out to some folks and ask them to
provide some input to the committee um
you know post hearing
um Eating Disorders are not a topic that
attract a substantial amount of research
money and so it has been a very long
slow process as in my opinion not only
related to marijuana just in general how
certainly thank you very much for your
day
thank you Mr chairman and uh committee
members for having me back yet again all
right so as we've already oh I'll hold
up as we've uh already discussed uh with
regards to uh medicinal cannabis uh it
does a good job of helping people with
anxiety and we know that because of how
we already prescribe it for people
suffering from PTSD uh which is defined
as an anxiety disorder caused by
or and we we do prescribe other
medications to handle anxiety like Xanax
uh which is a
benzodiazepine uh and we know that benzo
zeppin have been involved in
12,500 deaths in 2021 alone and that's
from the National Institutes of
Health the states of Delaware Nevada New
Jersey New Mexico North Dakota Oklahoma
Penn and Pennsylvania all have uh
anxiety as a qualifying condition and or
similar
legislation and as I have already
mentioned uh with some of the previous
bills uh I I do genuinely think that
cannabis as a treatment for anxiety is
something that would be beneficial to a
number of people it's not going to be
the solution for everyone just like
certain uh benzo zines will not
necessarily be the solution for others
but there is a Le there's significantly
less risk of Overdose as we know because
nobody's overdosed on marijuana uh and
alone I should say and it can be
beneficial for that regard alone we know
that there are different ways that and
triggers that people have for anxiety
and it's important that we try to
approach uh their issues from a patient
level and let providers decide uh what
is best for them and providing this as a
qualifying condition will give uh
providers that opportunity to assess
you thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my qu question this is actually
an observation we in the state of New
Hampshire we don't prescribe cannabis we
certify PE
the individual as a condition and then
based on that the Cannabis commission
okays or HHS okays it I apologize for uh
using the wrong terminology person to
answer this but I'd like to know if
there are any data on cannabis um in
people in adolescence um because the
first bill that we have um the first
bill that we have would already address
it for those who are 21 and older and
I'd like to know if there's any data in
this younger age group for anxiety and
cannabis uh unfortunately I'm not the
person to really answer that but as as
I've already stated uh hb12 uh 78 would
have uh addressed the uh language of
you
sorry but apparently she knew she
apparently I'm talking a lot enough
representative Thomas please come
forward oh she was just saying my
microphone was off oh oh okay all right
your microphone is on so you're all set
thank you very much uh representative
Wendy Thomas from the town of marac um I
used to work at a dispensary uh a
cannabis dispensary in New Hampshire and
the two MA major major uh symptoms that
were helped by cannabis were uh insomnia
and anxiety you cannot heal if you
cannot sleep and you cannot heal if you
can't C down now not all anxiety is
created equal I am not an anxious person
however I should qualify that I was not
an anxious person a cancer diagnosis
changed that after 2 years of dealing
with long covid and and all of the
issues with that I was diagnosed with
cancer the cancer concerns kicked off
anxiety that revolved around my family
my kids Financial concerns continued
pain relapse and who will love my dog
like me if I
die uh this is called this is
situational anxxiety it is not because
of an event although the one could say
that a cancer diagnosis is an event but
it's considered normal anxiety when I
would talk to a physician about it they
would say of course you're you you're
anxious about cancer that's normal and
So based on that I would not be
qualified for the the therapeutic
cannabis program um because of my quote
normal anxiety over
cancer um cannabis which I do use for
this anxiety allows me to back off the
cliff it allows me to stop thinking all
of these horrible catastrophic thoughts
and it allows the anxiety to be quiet
enough to allow me to sleep and as I
said before once you can start sleeping
you can start
healing so cannabis allows me to keep my
anxiety at B at Bay and in therapeutic
doses I've heard from so many patients
that that have found that uh therapeutic
canabus also allows them to keep their
anxiety at Bay I'll take any questions
thank you
any questions for representative
much also signed up to speak is former
kerk
so once again Jerry kerk chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board um so yes uh 1349 does seek to add
generalized anxiety disorder to the list
of conditions and TCA may be voted 7 to
one to support this bill as it is
written anxiety disorder is a
complicated disorder and often treated
with an integrated program of multiple
modalities including counseling and
cognitive behavioral therapy exercise
medications but we know that medications
do have some really significant side
effects and those were commented on
earlier um even the use of FDA approved
medications for anxiety generally are
for uh short-term interventions and not
good long-term interventions anecdotally
cannabis has a lot of evidence about
relieving anxiety it was commented
earlier that a lot of patients do that
in our patient survey anxiety was listed
by many of our patients as the symptom
for which they really use their
therapeutic cannabis now there have been
some studies and the Studies have shown
that particularly the CBD alone can help
with social anxiety that's like public
speaking um but the and that can occur
that can help without changes in
cognition or sedation which is good lowd
do THC or a combination of low THC and
CBD can reduce anxiety without producing
significant side effects so that's
pretty good but we have to keep in mind
that THC and higher doses can signif
iFly worsen or actually denovo cause
anxiety and increase the risk of
cannabis use disorder so cannabis does
need to be used cautiously preferably
avoiding high
THC CCM feels that cannabis is
acceptable to use to treat anxiety
especially as part of an integrated
program the standard approach that the
ATC follows will they would they already
follow this if they're taking care of
somebody with anxiety and they follow
this generally but they would
particularly do it here they would keep
the THC concentration low they would
start at an overall low dose and slowly
titrate the dosage to get to the desired
effect without The Unwanted side effect
of intoxication or
Euphoria now another good reason to pass
this bill is that currently as commented
earlier many people treat their anxiety
using cannabis which is purchased on the
unregulated recreational Cannabis Market
the use of unregulated and unlabeled
cannabis introduces the rich risk of a
patient getting high THC cannabis which
as I just commented can actually cause
more
anxiety so therefore it'll be far safer
for these people to be certified to use
therapeutic cannabis in order to be able
to access tested labeled
contaminant-free cannabis under the
guidance of an ATC basically it's a harm
reduction maneuver as well so we do urge
passage of 1349 I'll take any questions
thank you any questions representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question I I just wondered if
you could um address the question that
was asked earlier because I know the
therapeutic cannabis board has a
statement on cannabis use under the age
of
25 could you comment on that relative to
this population yeah basically here's
the issue U cannabis has two times in
life that it is really problematic and
that is in the uterus and during
adolescence and the reason is we are
having an enormous amount of change in
our neurologic system and cannabis
interferes with the pring of synaptic
connections within the brain and
developing new ones as a result um use
of cannabis during pregnancy or in
adolescence can cause significant risks
risks such as psychiatric disorders and
psychosis and schizophrenia um learning
disorders can interfere with the ability
of people to concentrate and learn and
that can be long lasting not just during
the time of use because you're changing
the neurologic system so as a result we
I mean we already we battled for months
about whether or not to still allow uh
kids to use uh cannabis for epilepsy and
we only have three on the program so you
know we really take this seriously and
we we are very cautious about it because
these risks are significant in kids and
we think that there may be an occasional
child where it could be beneficial like
for example uncontrolled seizure
disorder still May benefit uh because
that's a pretty problematic issue for
the parent and the child both but in
kids that is that answered well enough
you know as much about this as I
do other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you
Hannon long time no see thank you Mr
chairman uh Joe Hannon again and I'm in
favor of uh House Bill
um there are there are many reasons why
I think this needs to be approved um for
one uh this has been done in a few other
states specifically the most recent
state was Pennsylvania in 2019 added
this to the list it created a lot of
controversy in the media because you
know the media takes things that happen
in politics and Science and makes
headlines but uh the people that looked
at this there was at the Drex University
they have a um medical cannabis Research
Center and in April of last year they
they it wasn't a published report but
they did their little review of the
recent literature on um and things about
uh anxiety and cannabis use um little
background they they they found it about
31% of the population has anxiety
disorders uh but less than half of them
ever seek any treatment uh one of the
most common treatments that people do
get is is cannabis usually at adult
recreational or elicit uh sources um to
treat the reasons why they looked at why
people want to use cannabis instead of
other um Pharm Pharmaceuticals or not no
treatment at all which is what most
people wind up doing uh the stigma with
anxiety disorders uh the bureaucracy in
the red tape of going through the
insurance process prior approval getting
treatment all kinds of things the costs
uh even with prescription drugs that are
covered by insurance it's often uh not
very uh inexpensive to say the least uh
the side effects of a lot of medications
for anxiety and other psychiatric
disorders uh not everyone appreciates
some of the side effects um you know I'm
not going to list them all but uh they
can be U more than annoying to say the
least for some patients um as as you
heard previously uh they looked at uh
what dose does and we talked about this
before what doses are important lower
doses have been shown in a lot of the
research that they looked at to be to be
effective and helpful for people with
anxiety disorders uh as uh and CBD the
non psychoactive part of uh the can
cannaboid is is effective in all doses
however we did hear that high doses can
lead to anxiety and other problems that
doesn't mean that cannabis can't be used
for anxiety you need the right dose and
I think it's important these patients go
through the medical system and it's very
that's why I think it's imperative that
this needs to go in even if we don't do
past the everything bill or let the
doctors decide kind of versions this is
important it'll increase uh the numbers
of patients to qualify and it'll take
them out of the shadows and actually get
them into some form of treatment now no
drug by itself is a treatment for um
everything or you know um any kind of
anxiety so you don't always do one thing
for diabetics we don't just say here's
your insulin that's all you get we talk
about diet we talk about nutrition
exercise for diabetes uh the same thing
with uh psychiatric disorders especially
anxiety there are other things U other
talk therapy that may be helpful also in
conjunction with Pharmaceuticals but
when we give someone prac we don't say
here's your Prozac good luck I mean some
people do but you need to have other
modalities but this is a great start um
last thing I'll leave with is um you
know when I was uh doing surgeries I
would always prescribe one sleeping pill
just one for the told the patient take
this tonight and I almost never got
called for complaints the patient slept
through the first night and that's the
worst night if you ever had any
procedure minor procedure usually the
first night is the worst you don't sleep
you're anxious all pain and anxiety is
worse at night I give them one pill and
my anxiety greatly increased I greatly
decreased I was able to sleep and I was
able to enjoy my Saturdays because I
usually do these on uh Thursdays or
Fridays so I think it's very important
not just for the patients uh anxiety and
and well-being but also the Physicians
and the prescribers okay thank you any
questions reprentative Lon um thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Doctor The Honorable doctor for coming
in doing this um my question would be
are there people that self-medicate with
alcohol for anxiety and how does the
harm of that compare to somebody going
through the therapeutic program and
having lowd dose THC through an ATC
great question uh I'm I'm someone who's
been in recovery uh alcohol was my my
favorite I guess you could say uh it's
been it's been quite a while since 91
um and I never took lowd dose alcohol
that didn't exist I mean it probably did
I just didn't see it in the stores um
but uh you know as far as um alcohol
being used to treat uh a disorder I
think in someone who's had a lot of
experience in the recovery community and
working with substance use for for many
years I I think it's safe to say that
the drugs aren't always the problem it's
uh the drugs are a symptom they're
something that people self-prescribe to
treat with their with their feeling um
and I think it's very important that uh
just because something can be harmful
doesn't mean that it also can't be
helpful um you know alcohol actually had
medical prescriptions during alcohol
prohibition I was show the former head
of enforcement for the uh commission
years ago showed me a picture of one of
his prescription pads or picture of his
prescription for alcohol for the State
of New Hampshire for medical purposes uh
I think Winston Churchill got one when
he hurt his back in the United States
during a Car Act he was hit by a driver
in New York City and he had to get a
prescription for his uh medical
condition so he was able to drink while
in the United States during prohibition
um I don't know if that was the ideal
treatment at the time alcohol but it was
you know better than going through the
uh the DTs uh but I think it's very
important to allow the the the people
that know what they're doing to at least
say this is an option and that it's okay
I think like I first said the stigma
associated with a lot of mental
conditions and and psychiatric
conditions and and addiction and other
um substance use problems
is one of the biggest reasons why people
don't seek treatment and try to
self-medicate this kind of takes it out
of the Shadows um this says hey it is
something that can be used but we want
you to talk to someone at a medical
dispensary and try and get some
knowledge and some uh education if
someone came in I've never been a bud
tender I don't work in a in a cannabis
shop but if someone came in and said
what should I do uh from my limited
knowledge I would say from the studies
that this place I would say you want low
dose and they always say start small and
you know start low and work your way up
uh I've visited some dispensaries and
had tours and I've never heard anyone
say you know oh yeah we tell people take
the take the big one big gummy bear take
the big joint that's not what they they
talk about even in the recreational
adult use places they they tell you you
know if you're new start slow and it's
the same thing with medicine if someone
has a a medical condition you know we
don't usually give them the highest dose
available for something we try to give
this everything in medicine is you want
the lowest you want the safest
acceptable dose that produces the most
benefits with the least amount of um
harmful side effects and I think this is
one of those things that we know from
The Limited studies and I say limited
because the federal prohibition Federal
prohibition has uh kept us from studying
this to a really serious degree but
there are there are enough studies out
there to show that it does work in low
doses for for many people not saying
this works for everyone I'm not saying
this if you have anxiety you should go
out and start you know using cannabis
but I think you should talk to your
provider talk to your your PCP your PR
Primary Care doc your mental health
provider and at least start the
conversation and if that conversation
goes further at least this would allow
them the opportunity to treat themselves
legally and as far as Society is
concerned
legitimately you know we don't want to
push this underground because that's why
people get more addiction problems I
drank like a fish and it I was underage
so the law didn't stop me um and it
didn't stop most people it still doesn't
stop people now that we see as no no one
in here thinks that prohibition has
stopped people from smoking or using
cannabis or even during uh prohibition
some people smoke drank a little less
during prohibition but they drank more
and they drank more dangerous products I
think it's important to bring them into
a safe um safe environment and get
something that is uh regulated and
approved and I'll stop talking because I
know I can keep going thank you other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you very much you're
welcome no one else has signed up to
testify on 1349 FN so I am going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
1349 FN at this time we are going to um
take a brief recess maybe 15 minutes oh
yeah representative Shapero is that what
you were asking yep we're going to take
a about a 15 minute recess and then go
into executive session for several
noticed bills um U beginning with u 1520
11:35 because I have the Republican
members uh and substitute members come
forward
please
yes
yeah
Tre
be
right
St
boy
like this person would have been
read
I
a
of
right
to
right I mean it's I think
I'll be honest I read the whole thing I
just
Wendy
number
not
why
no I can I can do it a little bit
differently you can just scan the QR
code
flurry too
close yeah that happens
sometimes you on the the Wi-Fi no I'm
not on the oh that's true I'm not to I
don't
you're
town
okay yeah well no it's that is the
but
know
probably
want
yeah
last
the
you
need
okay I'd like to call us back like to
reconvene the meeting we are now in
executive session on uh several bills
under house rules um if the chairman and
the ranking member of the committee are
in agreement uh bills that were heard
today can also be considered an
executive session uh so the committee
will be considering at this time House
Bill 1278 representative McLean do you
have a motion thank you Mr chair I move
ought to pass okay representative
McClean moves ought to pass on 1278 do I
have a second second okay representative
Canon seconds representative McLean do
you want to speak to your motion well I
I think I think we heard some uh oh
thank you Mr chair I think we heard some
uh pretty compelling testimony today I
had some of the same questions that
representative Shapiro said you know why
do we need to kind of maintain the old
system why not just kind of broom it but
I think the testimony um really kind of
underscored the value of of maintaining
uh the current system that we have to
give some kind of clarity for those who
are less familiar while bringing in uh
uh the second tier for those that have
knowledge to allow for more discretion
and hopefully expand access for those
people who need it so um I thought it
was a well-crafted bill and there seemed
to be a lot of consensus and support
behind it so um I'd like to go with
octop pass thank you representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman I I'm
going to also vote in support of this I
think um you know judging from what
we've heard over the years when the
therapeutic cannabis program program was
first conceived of and first became a
law it had to be done in the most
conservative way possible to get
people's support and to try it out and
to see whether it was going to be
a useful statute a useful program and I
think over time it seems to have proved
its use and um people seem to be less
um not everyone but I think in general
people seem to be less concerned conc
erned with it creating a disaster and so
we've seen um this is my third term and
each year we've seen other bills with
new qualifying conditions and I think
um patients are more familiar medical
people are more familiar and it's time
to give um medical personnel more
discretion in um the way this program
plays out so I think this is a really
good bill and I think um we should
support it thank you representative
Nagel thank you um I I'm supporting it
also we had a very entertaining and
important discussion this in the
Cannabis commission um I just wanted to
share one very brief story of somebody I
think of every day she was a woman dying
of cancer who moved to New Hampshire had
therapeutic cannabis where she was
coming from and she didn't quite meet
the criteria here and so she couldn't
get it here and um the woman was doing
well where she came came from and was
suffering needlessly here and I think
bills like this are really important to
help people like that and help people
like me do what I think is right to help
them um at the end of life and whatever
thanks thank you representative
McKay as chairman of the
marijuana uh advisory committee for five
years I uh strongly support
this okay thank you thank you anyone
else any other
comments who representative merant who
seconded the uh representative Canon
thank
you you want to speak to your
second okay I'm seeing no other comments
so we'll go I'll ask the clerk to call
the all motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 1278
FN
representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative sers yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative
bogert
representative
priest
yes representative M
yes representative fedus
yes representative mon Phillips
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative
Merchant yes representative Manos or
Manos yes
representative Palmer
yes representative tez yes and represent
McDonald yes 20 to zero those are the
kind we like calendar yes if there's no
objection we'll put that on the consent
calendar and representative McLean you
can please write a um report for me and
get it
in um next up is a house bill 1520 FNA
I'll recognize representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman I would
move that this bill be uh an expedient
to
legislate is there a second to that
motion I'll second that okay
representative kushman do you want to
speak to your motion sure so there's
several reasons um there were some
logistical issues with the bill some
concerns uh about fraud and the ability
to sell a
vehicle um issues with you know who owns
the title and how maintenance is going
to be dealt with um while I do very much
sympathize um with the struggles of of
obtaining and Ma maintaining a vehicle I
don't believe that it is um the state's
place to step in and be the main
Foundation of a charitable organization
I think that should be done um through
private donations
primarily um um and I just see a lot of
issues with actually uh putting this
bill uh into place and enacting it thank
you okay representative kushman you want
to speak to you a
second oh I'm sorry repres oh
representative play on I'm sorry yes um
thank you Mr chairman many l um I I have
to say that the work that the good news
garage and other people like that do is
absolutely amazing and is something that
absolutely should be reported um the
reason why I don't think that this is
something that should be done through
the government is you have some
questions around the issue of the title
I recognize that in the past there
hasn't been much of an issue with people
selling cars but quite frankly the
economic condition we're in is um
quickly approaching something we haven't
seen in a long time and people will be
under pressures that they haven't been
under economically um that could
increase the chance that somebody may
not act may not keep the car as long
because at that point they may be
choosing between making their rent
payment paying for something for food
for their kids and you're looking at
different needs and different um
conflicts you know the fact that the
economy is worsening means that it's
more important that people do Ste step
up to help people obtain reliable
transportation but if we were to make it
so that the state held title in order to
keep these cars from being sold too
quickly then if there's an accident as
the title holder the state would then be
liable um you have all of these
different issues and all of these
complexities that that really only exist
when you're doing this at the state
level um and I want to encourage as many
people as possible to donate to people
like good news garage and others who are
getting these cars roadworthy in their
town I know we have a use car dealership
in Dairy that does a lot of this and
they make sure that they find cars that
are affordable and they help match them
to people who need them it's not through
a charity but just through something
they do in their normal routine work of
getting these roadworthy cars that can
get get people over the Gap I think that
we should encourage that through
voluntary help um and unfortunately I I
think I see way too many problems
bringing the state in that would create
new complexities so unfortunately I feel
that this needs to be itl but I do want
to thank the sponsor for all of his
really hard work on this because I know
I know that his intentions are pure and
good it's just a matter of of the of the
challenges of executing on the plan in
the
state other comments representative
Shapero
yes thank you um I will certainly vote
against itl and I'll try to address some
of the issues that have been brought up
um I think we all um have been through
many many discussions about whether to
what degree Federal benefits um create
dependence and to what degree Federal
benefits create resilience and you know
in the case of Medicaid um Wellness so
that people can go on with their lives
and but I think we're all in agreement
that we want people to be
self-sufficient and
um
self-reliant and um and not to be on on
on federal benefits not to be on tanif
in this case because I don't think
that's um any picnic for anybody
um people who are on tanif are still
impoverished and so we all want people
to move on with their lives and to be
more successful and um as I mentioned in
in my original testimony um there's a
working group within um DHHS called the
benefits Cliff effect workg group that's
been focusing on what are the systemic
issues that keep people from going off
of these benefits and the one challenge
that they came up with and there are
numerous challenges I don't know if
anybody looked at that on the um DHHS
website there are many challenges they
came up with and they paired each
challenge
with a um pilot project to see if they
could make progress in helping people
get off benefits and the one thing that
they didn't come up with a with a um
that they didn't pair with a um pilot
project was Transportation challenges
and we know that people um cars are very
expensive they become increasingly
expensive and without an automobile it
is very hard to get not only a job but a
good job um and um and then to be able
to maintain that job so that was my
original intent in bringing this up when
we did have our um hearing there were
um you know would would this be really a
sustainable program and with the worst
case example being that um someone gets
so one thing is that we heard from the
people here from Good News garage who
ran this program in conjunction with the
state um it was just anecdotal there
wasn't data but um that that had not
been an issue um after the after the
original hearing I had um several
discussions with Karen Hebert who was
the director of the division of economic
stability so you know within the within
DHHS
um tanif comes under economic stability
in other words um the intention of of um
of this program is to really create
economic stability for people it's not
to have them be un tanif and so given
that she explained to me um how they
would develop criteria for PE for who
gets these cars to try to ensure that
they actually led
to sustained self-sufficiency and
self-reliance and she talked about um
several things um but I but the
importance of identifying who are the
good candidates to get these cars
because they they're really invested in
in the success of um their clients and
success does not just mean getting off T
if it means um really moving towards a
middle class life where they can support
their kids because these are all
families with kids so they talked about
some of the um she was certainly not
telling me specifically what the
criteria but some of the broad Strokes
of what the criteria would involve um
would be obviously people without
cars um but also people who were Work
Ready who had participated within the um
um New Hampshire Employment Program
career counseling program um and taking
courses in Workforce Development
education
um employment
Readiness
um and financial literacy um I think
financial literacy was key because that
only not only leads to getting a job and
a better job but it also includes being
able to manage your money so that you
can maintain a car because we all know
you don't just get a car and that's it
you have to have money for maintenance
you have to have money for hopefully you
have money for insurance and for
inspections and the
like and she said that they would also
be targeting people who are not only
ready to work and all these people are
already in a work program um so it's
there's a work requirement but they
would be targeting people who are not
just looking for the next job but
targeting people who've made advances in
terms of developing a career so through
the um career counseling program there
have been opportunities for people to
like get certified in various things so
that they're not only on towards the
next job but they're arm towards a
career and so these are some of the
factors that would be taken into
consideration in deciding who is
eligible for getting one of these
Automobiles and um
these are the factors that um she felt
would
ensure or you can't ensure but decrease
the likelihood that people are not going
to um
sustain this effort um towards
independence um through getting a car so
um you know obviously I think it's a
great idea so I'm going to vote against
itl thank you represent pres dep
pmer thank you Mr chair I also
co-sponsored this bill and I
co-sponsored it for one main reason
which is that I donated a car to Good
News Garage in Vermont and um the
anecdote part of this is like almost a
year later I got a letter from the the
people who'd gotten the car saying how
grateful they were and how much it had
it had helped their lives and that they
were going on exactly the result you'd
want and as far as the concern that it
might be abused this is a pilot program
so it's a perfect time just to do a
pilot program see see if it works see if
they problems if if if the problems
aren't fixable then end the program and
if they're fixable fix them so I'm also
going to vote against the itl thank you
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair I'm going to take a different tack
on this um we have many people in our
society unfortunately or fortunately how
you look at it
that are really dependent upon the state
whether it be a tanif program whether it
would be snap programs and so forth for
various reasons many times not any fault
of their
own I went back and looked at the
documentation that was provided to us
from the Department of Health Human
Services and what it showed in there
that this was a bridge to get people off
the state and on their own so this in a
lot of ways is helping the state do
exactly what we're trying to to do is
turning me into taxpaying citizens so
therefore if you look in the Department
of Health Human Services back in
2017 every single
person the cash payments go into tanif
was $1,500
less less folks so the state has a
vested interest
economically to support s this program
because if we can find a way to get
people from TANF from snap off those
programs and fend for themselves we
helping ourselves and helping the state
treasury secondly when you deal with the
car ownership which I don't disagree
with it's a
concern but that's why this is a pilot
if we do see evidence through the pilot
that that behavior is in fact
occurring then you can deal with it by
not having the pilot go forward so I'll
stress to you folks here this is in the
state's best economic benefit to support
this program to help people get off
social programs that cost us money to
become self-sufficient and become a
taxpaying citizen of the State versus a
consumer thank you thank
you other
comments yes representative Seth K thank
you Mr chair um I've got a few reasons
outlined while I'll be voting uh in
favor of
itl um number one uh gratitude versus
entitlement um representative Palmer
here gave an example of how he had
donated a car and somebody was extremely
grateful for that and I find that when
there's voluntary charity involved
people are genuinely grateful and there
is real gratitude but when they get
something from the government they feel
a sense of entitlement like well I pay
my taxes so therefore I'm just getting
something that I'm just getting a little
bit of my tax money back and I'm very
much against the entitlement mentality I
don't want to increase that and I think
that yes there are going to be a lot of
people that would take advantage of this
and they would have the entitlement
mentality like their ow a car instead of
the Gratitude of thank you somebody for
voluntarily donating a car um number two
this is just a little bit of socialism
that I don't agree with number three um
it it was mentioned in um um public
hearing that few are known to turn
around and sell their cars but um how
many are unknown because they don't keep
track of all these cars they don't keep
track of very many I mean unless you
know personally the people you're giving
these cars to how are you going to know
if they turn around so there could be a
lot of cars that are turned around and
sold they don't know of um next how many
are simply abandoned due to lack of
upkeep how many people turn around and
they've got great intentions they want
to keep that car and then three months
later boom there's a $3,000 maintenance
bill that they don't they can't afford
and then they just it just ends up
sitting and rotting in their driveway or
they give it away or who knows what
happens um next is the costs are
actually much higher to fuel insure and
maintain a vehicle than just getting a
cheap vehicle um you know I recently
bought a few years ago I bought a a
truck for
$6,000 last year I put $5,000 in just to
keep it on the road uh so and that's
just for this year every year I'm
spending more money on the truck than I
do in actual the truck um so if somebody
is incapable of getting quite quite
frankly the cheaper part of maintaining
keeping a vehicle the cheapest part is
getting the vehicle unless you buy a
brand new one but if you get a used
vehicle that only has a couple years of
life left on anyways the cheapest part
is getting the vehicle the most
expensive part is the upkeep um if
they're not capable of maintaining it
then um there's you're just wasting
money um so I'd like to give you one
example also a personal example many
years ago uh we had a female dog that uh
had some puppies we weren't a a puppy
mill but you know happen stce we had
some puppies and um we always made sure
that we we sold our puppies for like a
hundred bucks because we didn't want to
give them to anybody who couldn't pay at
least a hundred bucks for a puppy you
know it's like you're going to spend so
much money on this animal throughout the
course of its life if you can't even
afford $100 for a puppy we're not we're
not giving you a puppy and there were
even times where people would come by
and maybe they did have a 100 bucks but
you could just tell this person is not
capable of treating that puppy well and
we would we would reject some people
from having a dog because you could just
tell these people aren't they're not
they can't even take care of themselves
they're not going to take care of a
puppy now let me ask you when it comes
to Transportation what if we didn't have
cars what if they were horses would you
feel comfortable giving a majestic beast
like a horse to somebody who's incapable
of taking care of that horse that would
be animal cruelty so when it comes to
automobiles okay you're you're giving an
automobile to somebody who has shown
that they can't they don't have the
credit I mean why can't they go out and
get a car on credit so you're saying
they have no credit they don't have any
family or friends that could give them a
vehicle they don't have a church they
don't have any Community that's willing
to give them a few thousand doar for a
for for a vehicle but but we the
taxpayers are going to give that to them
and then what are they going to do with
that vehicle if they don't even have the
capability of getting a few thousand
bucks to get the vehicle they definitely
don't have the ability to maintain the
vehicle so so this whole this whole
program I'm just against 100% thank you
thank you other comments representative
Shapiro yes it's um it's a choice that I
make that to believe
that people who are lowincome people who
can't afford to have a car people who'
have maybe had some trauma in their life
that's LED them to this situation that
they're motivated by the same things
that I'm motivated by and
um and that they would be you know given
the right situation they would behave in
a way that's similar to me and um so I
choose to not think of these people as
those kinds of people and myself and us
as other kinds of people which is why I
would do anything I could to help people
get a step up
um and become self-sufficient um as I've
been lucky to be in my life life um and
the other thing I would say is that
um I would just say to representative
King that perhaps if he had gotten his
truck from Good News garage he would
have had better luck with the truck
because they check them out before they
U give them to
people thank you other comments
representative blon um thank you um just
really quickly I guess the one thing
that I want to say is that there are
people that are very capable and there's
people who are incapable there's people
who are honest there are people who are
dishonest and that cuts across all
income levels just because somebody has
a lot of money doesn't mean that they'd
be somebody who would be a good faith
actor in a program like this and just
because somebody is lower income doesn't
mean that they're automatically a good
faith actor um I just want to assume
that everybody in every category of
people is just as just as flawed and
just as good as any one of us um and so
it's not a judgment on any of the
individuals based on their income level
it's more a note about human nature and
about the flaws that we all share so and
I I think that I think that as a
voluntary thing there's more benefits so
that's that's the reason for my
seconding in my motion but I just wanted
to clarify that so that we don't get uh
on each other's toes a little bit too
fedus oh there you go um
I'm feeling confident about the safety
net that's around this that these are
not just somebody getting a car they're
in the Department's temporary assistance
program they're participating in the
Employment Program they have a valid
license they have an individualized work
plan so I think there are some
safeguards that this program could be
successful and I and in favor of it
thank you thank you representative tez
uh thank you Mr chairman so uh for me uh
the issue in addition to what's been
stated already is um we live in a in a
state where we don't have the kind of
Transportation infrastructure that other
places have and so it's a huge barrier
for many people for many reasons and
many domains and being able to get to a
job right for self-sufficiency purposes
if this is all that would really be a
limiting factor and there's a proven
program that was successful here for 15
years and right now we're the only state
um that isn't off in it I actually
donated my C at goodnos garage a few
years ago I think it was one of the
older ones that probably just you know
they sold for parts um I I feel like we
heard a lot of really great information
about how they make sure the cars are
going to be pretty good for a while and
a lot of information about how people
are successful because of the guard
rails that exist for a you know defined
population and I really
don't I don't think that making
assumptions about the worst
possible behavior is the way to make a
decision about something that actually
is proven and will be beneficial both to
our um interest as uh public funds but
also because we want to invest in the
economic uh uh opportunity of our our
constituents so that they can be
prosperous and so they can be thriving
um members and let's remember a lot of
people end up on tan if because they had
some kind of Health thing right uh all
sorts of things are reasons for why
people end up on tanif um and the goal
is that it be
temporary um so I I'll vote against itl
thank you other questions I mean excuse
me other
comments seeing
none at this point I'll ask the clerk to
call the all motion is uh inexpedient to
legislate on HB 1520
FNA representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative sers yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nagel
yes representative
bogert
yes representative Canon
no representative mon Phillips
no representative
Shapiro
Manos
no representative
Palmer representative
Palmer
no um seem to have missed you yeah
wait David priest yeah um representative
Merchant is who I missed maybe
no representative Priest
no represent
fedus
no Representative tez
no and representative McDonald yes 10 to
10 okay uh since another motion is
forthcoming representative Shapiro I
move all to pass second motion's been
made by representative Shapiro and
seconded by representative Merchant for
our to pass do either one of you want to
speak to your motions or have we already
said what we need everything been said I
think we're we're all
set
okay um when the clerk is ready I'll ask
him M call the roll motion is ought to
FNA representative Leon
no Representative kushman
no representative Bill King no
Representative sers
no Representative mlan no
representative Seth King no
representative Missour
no representative Nagel
no Representative bogert
no representative
Canon
yes representative
priest
yes represent McKay
yes representative Mak
Phillips
yes representative
Shapiro yes representative Merchant yes
representative
Manos
yes representative Palmer yes
representative Taos yes and represent
McDonald no 10 to 10 no
rec okay that'll go uh on obviously on
the regular calendar with not a
recommendation and um representative um
kushman and representative um pero I you
could get me those reports that'd be
FN uh kushman representative kushman
uh 1593 FN relative to funding for
developmental Services Community
integration representative Nagel I make
a motion
itl okay representative C representative
Leon and I'll second that okay would uh
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Nagel reluctantly yeah um
this
was sometimes we go at night home at
night after bills here and feel somewhat
tortured I suppose this is one of those
um but I'm speaking speaking as um
somebody who's worked with people with
disabilities his entire life somebody
whose mother was disabled somebody whose
son has a developmental disability
someone who was actually recruited to
come to New Hampshire by Easter Seals
and I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
Easter Seals and somebody that
volunteered with Special Olympics so
it's an issue that's very important to
me in a lot of different ways um however
um as I listen to the testimony I was
actually surprised that I came to oppose
this bill because um superficially I
actually supported it and and the reason
why was as I was listening to people
talk you know I have one non-d
developmentally disabled child and one
who is and I know the terminology is not
accurate but um that's what I use um and
I was thinking about how important you
know out of school out of work um
experiences were for both of them and um
and made them who they are today they're
both in their 30s now but um you know
when I looked at it all the services
that they received were provided by
non-governmental sources um Boy Scouts
best buddies um things like that and I
paid for both able-body and non-
able-bodied and that's where I started
to struggle with this is what makes us
need to support report one versus the
other and then I thought we were
starting to go down a slippery slope
that really concerned me um I really
think that nonprofits do an absolutely
wonderful job providing a lot of these
Services already and I was struggling
with the concept that we would do this
in this manner um with that said as I've
already stated this is important I know
these experiences are extremely
important and relating to many of the
comments are made during the testimony
um
I totally accept and acknowledge the
role of folks with all sorts of
disabilities and non disabilities as
part of the fabric of our community um
that that's by reasoning representative
Lan did you want to speak to you a
second yes uh thank you Mr chairman um
you know this is a really hard Bill to
look at and to see um especially because
the whole uh the basically the whole
landscape is Shifting around this
community right now um I absolutely feel
for everybody impacted but I'm also
trying to figure out how any changes we
do now are going to Ripple through in
the future we've seen with other
programs how what seems like just um a
short-term change in order to get over a
challenge ends up creating yet another
Ripple that then follows through and
then has other consequences later on um
I struggled with the idea of maybe
figuring out how we could just grant out
the amount of money that previously were
spent by the area agencies um in order
to say that you know it last year
through through this budget cycle how
much would have otherwise been covered
under Medicaid in order to fund these
services that previously were allowed
and now are not but that's a really
complex thing to figure out how we would
be able to draft that and if there' even
be an appetite to say here's some money
that is simply a grant that we're going
to trust you that you are going to do
this because we don't want to put we
need to consider this under the larger
scheme of how New Hampshire addresses
the developmental disabilities Community
under the shifting landscape of what
comes down from CMS um I'd feel a lot
more comfortable quite honestly with
almost an unrestricted Grant to the area
agencies to allow that to fill that Gap
this year but I'm not sure that that's
actually something that would be
supported by everybody here um and in
the absence of that trying to figure out
how to carve through this trying to
figure out if we'd be able to get to an
idea of having these unrestricted grants
simply to Pat these holes right now
through this transition would be
palatable um my assumption was no which
is why I've seconded the itl motion but
if people want to convince me that we
want to do an amendment in order to do a
block grant just to get over this hurdle
not tying it in and not binding not
setting any precedent for future
legislation then that would be something
I'd be I'd be look into but you know
right now it's they're on shifting Sands
and we're going to need to look at the
program as a whole that's part of why we
have that that subcommittee that's
looking at this whole transition process
as well which I do need to notice and
have us meet um but we just we just want
to make sure that we can come through
with a with a holistic approach to this
because I agree um at what point at what
point does this become something that is
part of the government's responsibility
and when does it not and that's a big
discussion we need to have especially
with the developmentally disabilities
community and people whose services are
provided through local taxpayers for
when they school age but are part of the
dep department when they are not school
age um I think that we need to really
sit down and figure out how to how to
make sure that we best benefit this
community over their entire lifespan
instead of carving it out into these
different programs and I I just just I I
just don't think that the way that it's
been presented to us is the best path
forward which is why I've seconded the
itl representative sh Shapero you had
your hand up was this the amendment one
you had an amendment on or is that
something
else I didn't have my hand up yet but
I'd be glad to speak you had your hand
up initially so I wasn't sure if this
was the one
um
so so I did uh have an amendment written
to just um decrease the amount of money
but um even before we got to this
discussion I decided that that was
probably not the best way to go and what
I was hoping for today was that um
we would put off um executing this bill
for a couple of weeks because there have
been ongoing discussions with some
people um with stakeholders and people
in DHHS to solve some issues that I
think are real issues in this bill um
however I I don't
think those discussions would address
the concerns that the people who have
spoken so far so there kind of an impass
here and I'm trying to figure out what I
think here I I will say what some of
those discussions involved um they
involved the total amount of money which
I think was not um was um probably
pretty random when it was first written
into the bill um and that
um that further discussions about the
full amount of money that this would
take to put in this fund which would be
an ongoing fund um um which is what um
representative Leon seems to be in
disagreement with um so one concern that
I thought we could address if we had
more time was the amount of money also
um I don't know if everyone got it but
the original Bill didn't have a fiscal
note and then we um we got a fiscal note
um so there's also a part-time position
within DHHS that would um result as a
would be a result of this program and um
there needed to be further discussions
about that how that position would
actually be funded um and also there's
been talk about how to develop further
guard rails in this bill in terms
of what
activities are legitimate activities for
this program and how it's decided who
gets them who gets them funded and is
there a cap on the on the funding of you
know individual um a cap on for the
individual's amount of activities that
are funded so these are all like
questions that I think um if we had a
few more weeks we could improve the bill
but I'm not sure they would address the
um the issues that we've been speaking
about in here
so unless there's some appetite for um
continuing this exec session I would
vote in favor of the bill I would vote
ought to pass as is it's not my
preference but that's what I would do
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I'd be willing to serve on a
subcommittee to try and um look at this
and try and figure out if we can find a
solution that satisfies everybody or at
least get closer to a solution that
satisfies everybody um and I know I
didn't make the initial motion but um if
the chair wanted to put that together
and then maybe move this to the 14th
when we moved the other early bills
which is the hard deadline since it is
an early bill um i' I'd be willing to
withdraw my second if that was the case
representative Nagel I totally agree
with that I think this is a really
important issue um and I more than happy
to withdraw my
motion in favor of so you're withdrawing
your your motion what's that you moved
aop itl so you Mo removing your
withdrawing a motion yes and
representative Leon is withdrawing her
second so at this point we will continue
this bill to February 14th when we uh
we've already continued one bill to that
point also and we will have an executive
session that day so so we won't we'll
take no action on 1593 FN at this
time all right moving on uh HB 1612
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman I'd move I L on this bill he is
there a second second representative
Missour I think beat representative
Merchant to it okay do you want to speak
to your motion representative Lon uh yes
thank you Mr chairman um I think that
being aware of the status of our error
in radio any radio activity is highly
crucial um but I think that with the
existence of the C10 Network and the
ability that people are already doing
this I think that the more important way
to do this would be to plug into the
work that is already being done as
opposed to trying to reinvent the wheel
um I reached out to the department to
see if they needed any authorization to
participate in something like this and
um I was referred back to the testimony
from C10 that said that they're working
to figure out how they would work with
the state of New Hampshire in order to
do this um generally we're not in the
business of micromanaging departmental
decisions and um I don't see any
indications that they would necessarily
need any stat any uh legislative
approval to um working a contract with
them um as far as I believe I believe
most of the contracts if they're large
enough go through the executive counsil
because it is an executive dep executive
agency um and so for that reason I
encourage the department to work with
C10 or anybody else who is trying to get
alerts on the radio activity in that
area so that we can know when there's a
real response and know when there's just
somebody who hit the wrong button and is
somebody who hit the wrong button and
lost $80,000 when I was trading for my
company I recognize the harm in that but
I'd say the harm of everybody thinking
there was a leak at seab Brook was far
worse than my mistake on the trading
floor um but I'd like us to just um do I
move and go itl on this bill and
encourage the department to work towards
a collaboration and then come back to us
with anything they need if it's
needed representative M did you want to
speak to you a second or no okay repres
anyone else want to
speak representative uh representative
Nagel and then representative Shapiro I
just have a quick comment I mean I was
struck when um the person was giving the
testimony from C10 was giving a
beautiful eloquent testimony that was
going on and on and somebody asked her
what do you think about the bill and she
said I think it's Dead on Arrival and
that totally swayed me that was all I
needed to
hear representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman um first
of all I would love to hear the story
about pushing the wrong button um
um I just want to I I will I will vote
for itl I think that um it's not clear
to me that there's not a problem that
could be addressed through some changes
but it likewise it's not clear to me
that there is a problem and I think the
fact that the sponsor of the bill didn't
come to the wasn't able to come or
didn't come to the hearing and there was
uh a letter by the person who did um
Inspire this bill and they didn't come
to the hearing I think they just we're
left without any specificity about why
the why the added monitoring is needed
and what the added monitoring means and
the financial note was quite Hefty and
so I don't know if there's a problem but
if there is a problem it doesn't seem
like this bill is the way to um solve
any other
discussion seeing
none okay the motion is an expedient to
leg legislate on hb1 1612 FN last cler
to call the RO representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative sers yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
bogert
yes representative
Canon
priest yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus
yes representative Mak
Phillips I'm sorry did you just say
representative hacken Phillips
you represent Shapiro
yes representative
Merchant
Manos yes representative Palmer yes
representative taes
yes representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero there's no objection we'll put that
on the consent
calendar and representative Leon I know
you'll get me a
report okay last uh bill for our
consideration under executive session is
HB 1662 FN recognize a representative Le
on um thank you Mr chairman I move that
we adopt or vote out to pass on
Amendment 202
24-9 sorry 01
91h um to House Bill 1662 to FN do we
have a copy of that yes I just
distributed that when I came back into
the room I know I had misplaced mine so
um I'll give you all a moment to find
here
so a second to the motion to adopt this
amendment representative kushman she
moves to Second
yes has everybody had a chance to read
it okay does everybody have a copy of it
okay um if I may just start by
introducing what the change is so that
everybody can read it um I'll then pause
um so the the first sentence in Section
8 is inserted was already in the bill um
the addition of the line This
prohibition shall not restrict the
ability of employees of said Department
from serving as foster parents for
children for whom they had no
involvement in the removal of placement
process um was what I believe to be
consistent with the discussion in
clarification between the sponsor and
the concerns of the department so I'll
let everybody read through that again
and sort of signal to me when you're
discussion
and I want to apologize for not
Distributing this earlier I was so I was
waiting so much for the depart for the
um OS to get it drafted that I forgot to
mention that this was coming and I
apologize for this uh last minute it was
not intended as uh as trying to pull
anything off I was just trying to get
the amendment drafted and it was my
oversight to not mention it before we
broke before less of an issue than the
Mr chair yes what was the second on this
please uh representative Kush thank
amendment seeing none okay are we ready
for a vote I'll ask the clerk to call
the row the motion is ought to pass on
FN representative Lon yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative sers yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
bogert
yes representative
Canon
priest yes representative McKay yes
representative
fedus representative mon
Phillips
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Manos
yes representative Palmer
yes representative
TZ yes and representative McDonald
yes 19 to1 okay the amendment
passes
um I I don't know if do this qualify for
consent or no have pass right right
right okay okay represent kushman I
would move uh ought to pass as amended
as uh by the previous Amendment okay do
I have a second I'll second
representative Le on
seconds
discussion sure me go ahead
representative L representative kushman
um so we'll recall from the committee
this is a pretty simple bill um just to
keep any conflict of interest out of
these very important situations where
we're placing kids um
where we are um involved in removing
them from the home we just want to make
sure that there's no um competing
interests that would put the well-being
of Children and Families secondary to a
financial interest thank
you representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman um I know that this bill has a
very Hefty fin uh fiscal note but this
fiscal note appears to be entirely
related to the concern that the the the
employees of the Departments would be
removed from consideration in foster
care and then the cost of filling the
gap of those 10 employees the 1.8% of
foster families in the state being
removed from that system um this I
believe that this amendment makes that
clear and this bill is a second
committee bill that I'm pretty certain
it's a second committee bill and if not
we can request that it U be referred to
finance but we can ask for um there's
already been a request for a new fiscal
analysis without including the F the
change to the Foster families um I don't
see any fiscal language surrounding
anything other than the removal of those
employees from the Foster family pool
and as such I don't think that there's
actually a fiscal um impact I'll check
my notes to see if this is an early bill
or not but I think that's why we heard
it um so quickly and um with that I'll
yield to anybody else representative
Seth King thank you Mr chair uh I
support the a to pass motion um I agree
that we don't want the fox guarding the
hen house and one thing to consider is
that if this were private ecosystem um
this would potentially be considered a
monopoly the idea of the same company I
mean we're not dealing with a company
here but if we had a company that was in
the process of taking children from
families and the same company involved
in redistributing those children that
would probably be a monopoly that would
be broken up by us so if you don't
support that sort of
monopolistic uh private Venture then I
would say you probably shouldn't support
the idea that uh in this case the same
people um that are involved in the
breaking up of families are also
involved in the redistribution of
children that just seems it just seems
like a conflict of interest and we
wouldn't tolerate it in other aspects of
society we probably shouldn't do it here
either thank you this is an early bill
by the way and we'll be going to finance
should the House pass representative
Shapiro yes I'm adamantly opposed to
this bill and so I'll vote against
otpa
um when the sponsor presented the bill
he said he was aware of no problems um
um that where this had actually occurred
so this seems to be um of bill that is a
a solution looking for a problem
um
and
secondly when we're talking about
children being removed from their
families by DCF in particular um they're
not Avail they're not available to be
adopted because they've been put in
force to care or quotes removed from
their family but if they if they become
um eligible for adoption because the
parents rights have been terminated in
court or or voluntarily um they would be
adopted directly through DCF they
wouldn't be adopted through a
a a licensed adoption and child placing
agency so I think the the um conflict
that is alluded to with people um being
incentivized to take children and make
them a aailable for adoption um and
then switching job roles and then
adopting them out for some kind of
profit is is not really real we're
talking about something that's not
really real I think this is a slippery
slope in terms of saying what kinds of
um jobs people can hold as well as their
you know as well as their nine-to-five
job um and I think this is kind of a um
a cynical view of humanity that we
shouldn't support um that
um that people are
um going to be incentivized to
essentially steal people's children so
they can make a few bucks by adopting
them out to someone I think that's a a a
view of humanity that I don't want to
support um I also think that this is um
just more big government of like making
you know I'm always amazed that there
are a thousand bills put forward in our
legislature um and frequently people on
both sides of the aisle depending on
what the bill is say we have too many
laws well I think this is one too many
laws so I'm going to vote against
this thank you representative Leon um
thank you Mr chairman um there are many
lines of work in which there are
employment restrictions about what other
jobs and what other secondary jobs would
be a conflict with their with the
current or main employment um as the
state of New Hampshire is the employer
for people at the Department of Health
and Human Services and the department of
children and children and uh Family
Services uh because of that the only way
to change the terms one of the ways to
change the terms of employment is
through changing the laws surrounding
what is permissible for those employees
uh so the only the this isn't growing
government this is putting a check on
government and um I would be quite
thankful to hear that this is not needed
but you know we're always told what do
we need to do if it can save just one
child this is one of those areas where
it just simply would remove people's
concern that this is an issue this is
something that is limiting the state and
as such I think that it is reasonable to
move on to the next step of the process
representative Merchant and then
representative Seth King thank you thank
you Mr
chair first I want to commend the author
of the amendment for drafting the
amendment I think it's a step in the
right direction but unfortunately it's
not far enough um when I thought about
the issue of someone trying to cook the
books if you will to try to get a child
away from their parents to put them up
for
adoption what I have to realizes that
can't be done without a
court so there's a court involved here
folks that that court is the one who
decides to take parents rights away not
the DCF or anyone else so even if they
wanted to do this it could not happen
without the blessing of a court so
therefore I think baral's point of view
we have a solution looking for a problem
there is no evidence in the state of New
Hampshire that this actually exist so
why are we penalizing a group of
employees and putting restrictions on
their employment when a there's been no
evidence that we need it and B if there
was you still have to go to court the
judge still has to waigh on it you
cannot take parents rights away without
the blessing of the court so therefore I
will not support the bills amended thank
you representative Seth King and then
representative kosman thank you again Mr
chair uh to address representative
Merchants concerns um that the the court
would be the Arbiter here uh that's true
but let's not forget that the
information that the court gets is from
employees of
dcyf and if their if their judgment is
is Tainted by ulterior motives then the
court is going to get bad information
from dcyf so uh the court may help
prevent some things like that and that's
nice but the problem is is lots of times
when it comes to children it's a he said
she said thing and it's just it's just
extremely powerful the the the amount of
power the dcyf employees have um and
then also I wanted to just piggyback a
little bit on representative Lon said
there are a lot of positions when you
work for the government you're not
allowed to simultaneously work for those
you regulate you know we wouldn't want
people that work for the dod to also
work for Ron we wouldn't want the people
that work for the SEC to also work for
Goldman Sachs matter of fact there's a
lot of talk on both sides of the aisle
not just Republicans both sides of the
aisle that we're even starting to say
hey you know what not only can you not
work simultaneously you shouldn't be
allowed to work 10 years after if you
leave the SEC you don't get to work for
Goldman Sachs because there could be Pro
quid you know quote um I always mess up
the Latin Pro quid quid pro quot going
on where you know um it you you you are
the regulator but behind the scenes
you're going to regulate in favor of the
big corporations and then you're going
to turn around and work for them after
you quit I mean that does happen all the
time and both sides of the aisle are not
happy about that so um yes it is a
cynical view of humanity and I'm a cynic
okay people are people are that
corrupt so that's why I'm supporting
this Bill thank you representative
kosman thank you Mr chairman so I have
been experiencing a crash course in DCF
and family court over the last several
months I watched all of the hearings on
the special committee um on the Family
Court uh division of circuit court and
there were many meetings and much of the
testimony was about the fact that DCF
and the family
courts do not operate in a fair or
non-arbitrary manner there are many
reasons for that I won't get into all
the details but the judges have full
discretion to accept evidence or not so
if you bring affidavits from all your
friends that you're a good mom and dcyf
brings a finding of abuse the judge will
throw out your affidavits or not even
look at
them and they will take dcf's orders as
sacrosanct and rubber stamp it and it's
not all the judges and some of it's
incompetence but some of it there's
really a lot of evidence that there is a
lot lot of very deep corruption and
um I'm treading carefully
but just the assumption that everybody
is good and will do the right
thing um is
a understand there it's understandable
why we'd want to assume that but as I
grow over older I find more and more
that it can be the other way especially
when you have people in positions of
authority and you give them power power
corrupts representative Merchant then
representative blon thank you Mr
chair if the issue is the
courts and the courts being not true
neutral
arbitrators is that not where we need to
go versus doing something of this nature
and talk about where the problem is
versus trying to solve something without
getting to the problem and that's what
I'm trying to get to so therefore again
back to your
comment if in fact the courts are not
being neutral the courts are taking
one-sided in leaning one way or the
other I think the appropriate place to
go in a legislative process is dealing
here representative kosman thank you Mr
chairman um I'm assuming the question
was directed toward me um I I agree we
do need definitely there's like massive
overhaul that needs to take place in the
courts but there's also massive overhaul
that needs to take place within DCF
processes as well and this bill is the
first step the first you know place that
we've Unearthed an issue um and that we
want to get ahead of and make sure that
it it can happen thank you
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um right now the standards to
remove a child from the home aren what
they are but there is a bill um that is
active in the other body that would
include somebody something like uh
somebody dis ageing with the level of
cleanliness in your house um I'm sorry
but I have three boys the whole saying
is your house will be clean when the
kids leave the house and that sub the
potential subjectivity about the state
of somebody's housekeeping or
disagreeing with the education that's
provided to other children um that other
the bill that's pending in the other
body could make things so much more
subjective within the department that
that actually would give us more reasons
um why it's more important to as
employers set this condition of
employment um you know hopefully that'll
be addressed and if it comes our way
we'll deal with it as well but I just
wanted to raise people's um awareness
that that this may be moving into a more
subjective way so if we do end up
enabling to have more subjective choices
in which children are removed you know
in Wake of the ab absolute Horrors that
we witnessed in recent years um that we
also have this Safeguard too that we
don't potentially experience some of the
horrors within the department that have
happened in other states you know I'd
love to think the best of my fellow
Granite Staters but you know sometimes
we need to figure out where to draw that
line other discussion representative hen
Phillips thank you Mr chair um I just
wanted to take a moment to address um um
some allegations that were made in
testimony just now from our own members
and just um to remind this body that I
am a member of the New Hampshire Bar
Association I am a licensed and
practicing attorney in the state and
that um the allegations that I just
heard of without any factual evidence
that our New Hampshire court system
or perhaps our family court system by a
non-practicing non-licensed lay person
who is also a member of our general
court I find to be very
disturbing I um would just like to make
a mention of The Honorable work that our
court system staff and judges do for our
state um and that you know they are held
to very high standards of constitutional
practice and and professional practice
codes of conduct that um I believe are
held here in our state and that um I
would just like to say the substance of
this bill does not seem to address the
concerns that we've just heard um you
know it sounds like there's a procedural
evidentiary complaint that someone may
have um with the court system but I'll
remind this body that our house did in
fact just vote on that matter this month
and shot it down so um this particular
concern does not get addressed by the
language of this bill and I would just
like to say that
um you know it's it's our our duty here
in in the Health and Human Services
committee which I am substituting on
today to to try to work on these healthc
care issues and um I don't believe that
those
allegations appropriately align with the
substance of this bill and for that
reason I will be voting against
that representative
Palmer so my only additional point would
be that um normally a conflict of
interest kind of thing would be dealt
with by
the company or the agency so I would
much rather see this addressed by HHS as
a as an internal policy rather than
adding more legislation that takes more
legislation to change if it needs to be
changed representative
mlan thank you Mr chair um the only
thing I would say is that we are seeing
in this state in this country um a real
decline in the trust of our institutions
in general and in this state in
particular there is a huge amount of
distrust in in in the Family Court um
and it's not enough that that the system
be fair and the system be just it may
very well be but in addition to that
there also has to be the perception that
the system is fair and just and so I
think that um this bill goes a long way
towards accomplishing that it this is
about also reestablishing trust in the
systems and so I will be supporting the
bill representative Parmer and I
I I guess what I would say is that part
of the reason that the trust is slipping
is because of the kinds of things we do
and I think we need to be very careful
that we don't accelerate anything beyond
appropriate um skepticism of what
government is doing um because I think
we certainly can make it worse along
with the
media uh representative Shapero and then
representative Seth King then
was yes as um as I'm hesitant to say
this but as someone who's actually
worked as a protective so protective
services social worker um briefly and
earlier in my career and not in New
Hampshire and Vermont um but who's
actually had that job of um working with
family amilies um to assess abuse and
neglect and then to get families the
help that they need to keep their
kids and in the worst of circumstances
having to remove kids at times having
done that
job briefly um also having um worked
with adolescence for a great deal of my
career and therefore been in court a
great deal with kids who were um
involved in that
system um and even having participated
in one case in
um you know witness and a termination of
parental rights um case which was
incredibly
painful um as someone who's done those
things um I would be the first one to
say that these systems are imperfect and
sometimes there are really bad things
that happen um but in my experience and
it's not current experience in New
Hampshire in my experience um most of
the time people do the best that they
can and they work pretty
um I guess I would just like to um kind
of piggyback on what representative
Palmer said is that that number one we
should be very careful about not
amplifying that distrust through laws
that we bills that we bring and um
speeches that we make and bills that we
pass um but also as people know we have
had a shortage of dcyf workers in this
state which have led to some some
unfortunate situations in our Protective
Services um
ecosystem in New Hampshire and you know
at various times there have been efforts
to um hire more people and um it's
difficult to hire people to do an
incredibly difficult job and I
think bills like this will be seen as
um kind of
disrespecting people in those jobs
assuming the worst about people in those
jobs and make it more difficult
um to get people to want to do that kind
of work um and so for all those reasons
I um once again I will say that I I will
vote against this and I think this is a
um this will be really unfortunate if we
pass this bill representative Seth King
thank you again Mr chair I just want to
piggy back on what representative mlan
said I really liked what he had to say
um it's not just about the trust it's
also about um uh being being seen as
trustful and um when it comes to
different departments um there are very
few departments that I think people get
as emotional about as this one I mean
people might be upset about a certain
hunting rule with fish and game or
something but when it comes to losing
your children there's nothing that's
going to make somebody go crazy more
than that you know and if they think
that there's anything about the system
that is corrupt or rigged against them
it just makes the matter that much worse
and um to say to respond to what
representative Palmer said he said well
um you know we don't want to we don't
want to do anything that could upset
people and a lot of what we do to upset
people is in the legislature and I agree
but I really don't think there's going
to be anybody at home that is going to
be bummed out about this bill passing I
think there are people though that are
seriously unhappy with the way DCF is
run today and certain things about it um
but I don't think anybody body at home I
don't think the average person is going
to be bummed that dcyf employees cannot
simultaneously work for child adoption
services nobody's nobody's thinking that
um but there are a lot of people that
are that would not be happy about the
reverse so that's why I favor this Bill
thank you representative TZ did you have
your hand up yeah I just wanted to say
that you know I am freshman but this
makes me wonder about does this mean now
we're going to be facing all sorts of
other bills for
specific uh laws to be put in place for
specific types of situations where as
representative Palmer pointed out this
could be handled at a rule level a you
know other kind of policy level not
necessarily requiring legislation and
again fundamentally we heard no evidence
that this actually is a real um that
this there's that there's any kind of
problem and I also doubt that there's
anyone really you know spending time
time thinking about it because we've had
no evidence that this actually is a real
problem thank
you um representative Leon um thank you
Mr chairman I've noticed tensions rise a
lot during this discussion and I just
want to remind everybody about article
30 of our constitution unfortunately
another heated discussion in a previous
year in the legislature led to somebody
having legal action taken out taken
against them for defamation um um it
it's currently going through the court
process so I can't speak to it too much
so I do want to remind us of the
Constitution which states the freedom of
deliberation speech and debate in either
House of the legislature is so essential
to the rights of the people that it
cannot be the foundation of any action
complaint or prosecution in any other
Court or Place whatsoever so I just want
to remind everybody of that and uh also
realize we're all just trying to look
out for the best interest of kids and
family Ames we just may disagree on how
to do this but let's not let our
emotions on that override how we're
acting today so thank you other
discussion I'm seeing none and certainly
we think we've covered it pretty
thoroughly I'll ask the clerks of
Colwell at this time the motion is ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1662
FN before I begin I have an apology for
representative hen
Phillips sorry it's hacking Phillips
hacking like a computer hack even
further apologies um me too hacking um
sorry representative Lon yes
representative kushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative sellers
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nagel yes
representative bogert
yes representative Canon
no representative Priest
No representative McKay
representative hackin
Phillips
no representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant
no representative
Manos
no representative Palmer no
Representative tez no representative
McDonald yes 10 to 10
okay that'll no recommendation I since
forthcoming is there another motion
forthcoming rep representative Canon
itl motion has been made for itl is
there a second second representative
Merchant seconds any discussion or and I
think we've covered it but any
discussion seeing none when the clerk is
roll
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
no Representative kushman no
representative Bill King no
representative seller
no Representative
mlan
no representative Seth King no
representative Missour
no representative Nagel
no Representative bogert
no representative
Canon
yes representative priest yes
representative McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative hacken
Phillips
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes representative Manos
yes representative Palmer yes
representative TZ yes and representative
McDonald no 10 to
10 okay these will go to obviously no
recommendation to the calendar
representative Canon you're doing the
okay okay that concludes uh all of the
business for the uh executive session
this
afternoon um so I am going to adjourn
the executive session uh the hour is
currently 105 um my recommendation of
the committee unless his objection would
be people take lunch at their Leisure uh
during the course of the afternoon uh
rather than delay uh proceedings you
know considerably any any opposition to
that
idea oh okay all we have can we do five
minutes just to get the bathroom sure
yeah we we'll we'll take a a quick U
quick break uh five maybe 10 minutes
we'll take we'll take what's
that seven
sure
want
there
the
1633 which has a 4 o position uh
possession limit uh the purpose of this
bill would be change to change the
medical purchase limit uh from 2 oz to 4
oz uh that's because it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense for patients
to be able to go into a medical uh
dispensary and purchase 2 O
of cannabis when they could go to a
recreational facility and purchase
four um so there are also another of a
number of other reasons why uh we should
allow patients to purchase 4 ounces uh
because patients may be uh in need of
different dosages uh so they could use
more uh than uh and require them to go
to The Dispensary more frequently we
only have seven dispensaries across the
entire State and people with mob
problems or people who with limited
Transportation have sometimes difficulty
getting to their uh dispensary that they
use uh to be able to purchase uh their
medicinal cannabis so if you'd help me
uh support this bill and kind of fix a
potential upcoming problem that we're
going to see in our legislation that'd
be great thank
you thank you any
questions representative Leon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
bringing this forward I think that it's
great to look perspectively about what's
happening in the larger environment um
my question is actually in section two
um that's in sub paragraph uh seven
there it talks it increases the amount
of obtaining more than 2 ounces changing
it to four of cannabis in any 10day
period in violation of the rsas um my
question would be if um I guess I also
don't want to Doom this in the other
body but um if it might make sense that
if there is somebody who has a higher
need that those that are writing that
certification may want to um allow more
within that time period perhaps it's
better to defer that question to
somebody else but I just wanted to make
sure that we're not limiting people yeah
I mean that that that would make a lot
of sense uh and I I would definitely be
open to uh some changes there thank
you other
you also signed up to speak is
representative Wendy
Thomas
hi everyone um representative Wendy
Thomas town of marac um I come before
you in support of this bill there are
several reasons to support it um besides
the fact that it would match the legal
uh recreational bills that are being
proposed one is that cannabis Works
differently for each person uh and so we
use different strains use different
amounts uh I recently went up to Maine
to talk to a cannabis grower who grows
for recreation as well as uh creates um
therapeutic products and she was telling
me of a cancer patient that uses 12200
milligrams a day of cannabis and they're
functioning that's that's a ton if I
took 1,200 I would be out like a light
um they but that that's for cancer um
and it was actually for brain cancer um
I've also talk to people that have
worked in dispensaries that their
average dose their daily dose is 100
milligrams at a time and again if I took
something like that I would be out as a
patient my comfort dose is between five
and 10 milligrams at a time that's what
I take I don't I don't need a lot but
thank thankfully I don't need a lot
there's a lot of people that just
metabolize it differently and they need
a
lot um I will tell you that uh one of
the uh products that I use now is a very
concentrated um product with cannabis
and it is actually 50% THC in this
product but when I use it it's an oil
and I only use a tiny tiny amount and
it's compared to a grain of rice it's
about 10 milligrams for that dosage for
me to take that that product I'm taking
it for cancer I'm taking it for pain but
to make if I wanted to make that that
product on my own and there are ways to
make it I would need a lot of cannabis
um keeping patients to 2 ounces for me
that's fine 2 ounces I don't think I've
ever in my lifetime hit the the maximum
level of 2 ounces however I know many
many cancer patients many many patients
with terminal illnesses that need a lot
more they burn through the 2 O burn I
didn't mean to say that they use the 2
oz um that they're allowed to get and
then they augment it by buying stuff on
the street because they just don't have
enough and lastly transportation is a
big problem um as the previous speaker
um mentioned we have 10 uh dispens we
have seven dispensaries in the state of
New Hampshire that means that some
people have to travel a long way to get
to these dispensaries if we increased
the amount to match what we're talking
about recreationally these people may
not have to do that travel every 10 days
I'm open for any questions if you'd like
are there any questions for
representative
you I'm going to skip out for lunch and
turn the chair over to Vice chairman
Leon for a while so representative Lon
uh thank you uh and next we'd like to
call Matt Simon from Green Leaf cannabis
thank
you thank you madam chair again for the
record it's Matt Simon I work for
granite Leaf cannabis Sor um no problem
at all uh if that name is unfamiliar to
folks last time I was in this committee
we had a different company name we
changed our name in September so we're
still the same New Hampshire focused
nonprofit with the two dispensaries but
we are Granite Leaf cannabis and uh the
previous speakers have made most of the
points I intended to make I think the
main reason this bill came up is because
the house uh both last year and the year
before passed two totally different
adult use legalization bills but they
had one thing in common they both had a
4 ounce possession limit and if either
of them had passed into law we would
have had a 4 ooun possession limit for
adults 21 and older but a 2 ooun
possession limit for register patients
and that didn't make sense so this bill
would put the therapeutic program on the
same footing with with adults uh who
would be become legal consumers if the
other Bill were pass uh as others have
mentioned we do have only seven
dispensaries in the state so a lot of
patients do have a drive of more than an
hour and if they're purchasing cannabis
every 10 days I'm not a math Wiz but
that's like 36 and a half trips to the
dispensary in a year and for a lot of
people that's far from ideal so this
would make it so that people could make
fewer trips and stock up a little more
when they do it so please support this
bill be happy to take any questions are
there any
questions um I actually have one for you
um would you advise people that are
involved in those adult use bills to
perhaps change the language so that the
um so that the therapeutic cannabis is
in addition to whatever the limit for
other adult use would
so that you're not so that you're not
saying that I I guess my question is do
you want to mean do you want to
basically block somebody off from that
other access or would it make more sense
for the therapeutic cannabis to be on
top of the adult use
limits thank you for the question I
don't think I have an answer on that I
think that would be a policy choice for
the general court my biggest concern is
that we not create a standard uh for
adult use that is twice as high as the
standard for patients so
uh that makes sense I recognize that and
thank you for noticing the oversight in
our legislation thank
you with that I don't see any more
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you supposed to back to you um and
with that I will call Jim
Riddle thank you and so we're trying to
keep testimony to three minutes the
spudger will go off and uh if you keep
going beyond that we'll remind you so
just to let everyone know this afternoon
so thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Jim Riddle
Hillsboro I have a uh New Hampshire
medical cannabis card I also uh hold a
USDA hemp grower license um and I'm on
The Advisory Board of the New Hampshire
cannabis Association I'm here to speak
on my own behalf and I'm here to support
uh HB
1350 and to increase that possession
limit from 2 to 4 oun to be consistent
with the adult use Market that's being
proposed but I do want want to just
challenge the whole notion of a
possession limit I mean I can go to the
state liquor store and fill my car with
wine or whiskey I can throw in some
bottles of Everclear even pure grain
alcohol there's absolutely no possession
limits on uh alcohol and We Know It
Kills you you know it's bad uh for you
but yet a person can buy transport
consume have in storage as much alcohol
as they possibly uh could want so it's
like I think it's a transition but it
does seem to me like a bit of a nanny
state of looking over my shoulder to
control to make sure that I don't have
too much in my possession and um you
know there just haven't been problems
with medical card holders buying up and
then reselling I mean it's just has not
been a problem in all the years that the
program has existed so I support the
bill but I do just have a problem in
general we don't limit other medications
it's placing limits on people's Health
Care choices and that their preferred
treatments but thank you thank you are
there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for the testimony sorry I'm doing a
bad bad job handing these off uh next I
will call the honorable Jerry kerk to
microphone thank you very much Madam
chair and my testimony I distributed
everybody has it along with the bill
couple Beyond this too um once again for
the record Jerry kerk chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and um the board voted unanimously
to support HB
1350 the discussion uh some of this will
be slightly redone but I want to tell
you what we said at our meeting that
specifically it will help our patients
because Edibles that are sold at atcs
are expensive so in order to save money
many of our patients make their own
batches of Edibles they'll get the plant
they'll make an edible uh that they can
then use over many months but most the
recipes take a kind of large amount of
cannabis to make the batches so the 2 O
limit makes that difficult and that's
particularly true for oncology patients
who may be using higher Doses and you
could say well you know they just go
back to ATC and buy another couple
ounces 10 days later well that puts them
in violation of their possession limit
that's why the how often you can buy
would need to be changed in how much you
can buy every 10 days I mean do we have
to be changed in order to still make
this work one of the main things though
again is that distance if you live in a
rural area trip to an ATC can be a very
long issue and this is particularly
difficult for older patients who don't
like driving long distances particularly
maybe at night or whatever patients in
pain oncology patients and I always like
to think through analogies I live about
an hour and a half round trip from my
Pharmacy when I go refill my uh
prescription for L Center Pearl for my
hypertension I get a 3month supply I
don't have to go back every 10 days so I
think the 10day part is already a little
bit of a nuisance but allowing people to
buy 4 ounces every 10 days might mean
they only have to go once a month or
something rather than having to go uh
more frequently so it's really going to
make a big difference and we also
recognize the issue that the
recreational Cannabis bills have talked
about 4 ounces but we've also talked
about recreational can abis for a decade
or more and it hasn't passed yet so even
if that doesn't pass this still is a
good thing to do so we urge you to pass
this bill it'll save money for patients
it'll also save a lot of time
particularly those who live a long ways
from an ATC and I'll be glad to take
questions thank you are there any
questions from the committee
representative
Palmer this may be a little bit of a
silly question but um we're talking
about 2 and 4 ounce limits but then most
doses are in grams and how how many
people translate all of that well and um
how does that work I mean you go to the
you go to the dispensary and you
get 2 ounces or 4 ounces and then you
make gram doses um I mean maybe people
who do this all the time it's yeah I
think I though I I I don't I don't have
a card I don't use this stuff so I can't
answer exactly all those details but I'm
pretty sure that most people would have
a recipe would say you know use 2 oz or
whatever of something which contains
perhaps 30% THC or 10% THC or something
like that so you'd have an idea what
you're going to do because you're right
if you make a batch with 1 ounce of
cannabis and it's a 10% THC it's going
to be a lot different than if it's a 50%
THC because the strains do have
different THC CBD or cannaboid
concentrations
yeah um thank you are there um we'll we
can call you back after we have the
other people testify representative
Thomas okay yeah she would know more
than I probably about that um and then I
guess my other question is that a lot of
the stuff is dispensed in milligrams and
there's no real consistency in
Translation between that and gr and um
and ounces of plant form cannabis if you
were to have a low potency 10% THC
content cannabis versus one of the uh I
think they're trying to push 30% out in
California and some places but I'm not
sure if they've actually broken that
that level um you know how how does that
translate or are we just simply stuck in
some of the echos of the drug war I
think we're actually stuck in The Echoes
because you're right it would it would
it would be kind of weird to say hey you
can have 4 ounces of a highly
concentrated you only have two you know
it it it doesn't make a lot of sense but
this is just modifying what's currently
in statute I think it might be a little
more complicated to have a nomogram that
would say how many ounces you can have
of what percentage although that would
certainly be another way to do it but to
remember that there's such variability
in What patients need is the main issue
is that a oncology patient um as was
mentioned earlier may require a very
large dose and a person using it for
social anxiety or well it's not approved
yet sorry are using it for yeah well for
something else may use a tiny dose I
mean I have a even though I could never
prescribe this stuff because it didn't
come into being excuse me I couldn't
certify for this stuff because it didn't
come into being until after I left
practice I kept track of kept up with a
couple of patients who live in the same
town and the one gu you know he just
uses a little bit of a brownie each
night before he goes to bed and that's
all he needs and he doesn't need any any
opioids it's as simple as that um so
some people use really very small
amounts yeah it's hugely variable thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much sure thing thank
you and uh next I'll call Dr Joe Hannan
um this is the last card I have so if
anybody else had anything to testify so
representative Thomas will'll have you
you good afternoon Madam chairwoman my
name is Joe
Hannan I was limping up here my foot
fell asleep so it kind of It kind of
goes into what I was going to start with
was mobility issues um not saying that
this is an indication I'm not pushing
for sleeping legs to be qualified under
this but anyway um you know up until
this past summer I'm in my 50s now and I
didn't really give much consideration
even though I was a practicing doctor
for many years and I was in the
legislature I had a lot of experience
with people with health conditions and
mobility issues it didn't really uh hit
home to me until the summer when I had
serious back problems and I really
couldn't walk for for over well over a
month almost six weeks um and I had to
get medicine I was and since I'm in
recovery I'm hesitant to take most
things and my wife is like hey you need
a muscle relaxer just to help you sleep
or at least get some of the edge off and
I was out of town in some State and I
she I got a script called in for 5 days
of muscle relaxer just a little bit and
I had to walk from a hotel about Three
City Blocks to get there and I could
barely brush my teeth so just the fact
that I had to do that I I it it boggles
my mind to think that we're forcing
people that have a medical treatment
that they have to go very frequently to
get filled um you know uh most
medications if doctors prescribe them
they usually give if it's something that
people aren't consistently they're
usually 30-day supplies or sometimes 60
or 90 days or more uh and they can give
refills but you can't do that uh we
can't prescribe Doses and stuff and I
understand that's why they came out with
these limits initially but they really
don't make any sense whatsoever when
they're we're surrounded by the
recreational adult use Market if someone
wants more they're going to get it if
someone's going to the medical place to
get their their medication there's no
reason not to allow them to get whatever
they want we've heard Alcohol and Other
Things um you know 2 ounces he said what
is does anyone know what that is it's 56
Point some grams so yeah some people
know um and that's that's not I learned
that from medicine not from my past but
um anyway the other thing is it's we
know about mobility issues weather there
can be power outages travel distances I
travel 30 minutes to get my teeth
cleaned and you know I'm not in the
middle of nowhere I live in the sea
Coast it shouldn't be that but that's
what people travel New Hampshire for to
get basic things I mean I it's the first
I've lived many places I've been here
over well over a decade I've never been
able to not get Chinese food delivered
to my house while I live somewhere I
can't get Chinese food delivered I have
to drive 20 minutes um imagine someone
with disability or Mobility condition
and they have to go back 36 whatever
times a year um it's just uncalled for
and also if there's a power outage or
storm or something or there's a closure
of a store a lot of pharmacies right now
are having problems Staffing and and
some are restricting their hours some
are closed more frequently or if there
isn't if they have to close because they
can't even get a pharmacist to show up
now I know this is Pharmacy and not
other Pharmacy but um if a pharmacy is
closed or they can't you know for some
reason you can't get there or it's after
hours there are 24-hour phes I may have
to drive 40 minutes or you know 35
minutes to get there but if you need to
get a 24-hour pharmacy you'll be able to
eventually get there there are no
24-hour cannabis places anywhere yet
sorry didn't mean to spill that anyway
um so I think this is really important
and I'd be happy to take any questions
and please pass this Bill thank you are
they any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much and I'll call back uh
representative
you yeah I just wanted to um explain a
little bit more about Edibles the
question about Edibles um most if not
all dispensaries um have syringes of
concentrate and each syringe syringe is
about 100 milligrams so if you're if
you're like me and I want to know
exactly how much I'm taking because I'm
very sensitive to cannabis and I don't I
actually I don't want to be high I don't
like that feeling um so what I can do is
I can take that syringe make um a plate
of brownies we all heard about that in
college right and if you cut it into 20
pieces then each piece is 5 milligrams
more or less you know I mean depend on
on how well you um you stir it um
another way to to use um cannabis and
Edibles is to decarbox it which means to
heat the flour up because once you heat
the flour that's what activates the THC
that's why people smoke cannabis if you
eat raw cannabis you're not going to get
inebriated you might get you might get a
little calm from the CBD but you're not
going to get inebriated so you you decar
carboxilate the flour and then you can
use the flour in food some people
sprinkle it on top again I don't do that
because I want to know exactly how much
I'm taking um and
lastly when you are smoking the flour a
healthy Bowl um and that's you know
typically what you see in in you know on
screen in movies and stuff a healthy
bowl is about 20 milligrams of of
cannabis in it way way way too much for
me so I use something called a one
hitter that has a bowl that is about the
size of the Eraser on a pencil that's
how much I use I mean and and it does
the job so um so so people use this in
different ways and you need the product
to make
edibles yes question from sort of the
gist of my question was you you sort of
the 100 milligram syringe is that's 100
milligrams is close to 4 ounces would
that be the kind of limit of what
somebody could buy or no so the the the
the four grams is the raw 100 milligrams
so it's it's not 100 milligrams is not
grams I'm never mind yeah milligrams no
we're talking milligrams you could get a
you could get a lot of syringes you
could get right I'm I'm off by a factor
of um 100
yeah
math I was just
and I'm it was just sounding like very
little in grams but now I got it no it's
uh been a long day and getting getting
those different orders of magnitude when
you're when you're converting between
all of these it's hard to keep straight
unless you're writing it down
so well and if you're not a patient this
doesn't this may not make sense to you
because you don't have to do this but as
patients this is what we do so that we
can go and we can go to work work we can
raise our families we can go buy
groceries and cook I mean this is what
we have to do to be well enough to
participate thank you that was very
helpful um if there are no other cards
um I will close the public hearing on
House Bill
1350 and uh since we've already moved
into the time frame for House Bill
12:31 um sorry no we're not there yet
we've moved in the time frame for House
Bill 1581 I'm not sure if we have any
cards for that one yet but I'd love to
cards thank you and with that I will
open the hearing on house Bill 1581 and
call Prime sponsor representative
speak thank you madam chair and um thank
you to the committee for spending this
day listening to some of the bills that
we've been working on and and really
exploring the program um just as a
mentioned that I sent out to you all of
you um something that was shared with me
which was um a
presentation by and about the
therapeutic cannabus program and that
was presented to um the 611 Commission
on
legalizing um for adult recreational use
so that information about the
therapeutic canab program is really good
backdrop to what we're working on today
and just to urge your committee to
continue to protect the therapeutic
cannabis program for for the patients as
we move ahead um with our state's ideas
about what will be their therap their
non- theraputic cannabis program so
thank you for keeping us in the context
and please understand that we really
fiercely defend our program the bill
that I have before you now which is
House Bill 1581 is very simple um if you
look at the analysis on the front page
it says this bill allows a second uh
cultivation to be considered for
alternative treatment
centers um that really should say this
bill
allows additional cultivation
centers because if you flip the bill
over and you look at the other side um
the paper over and you look at the first
page of the bill it it basically tells
you that the department May authorize an
alternative treatment center to operate
additional cultivation locations which
may be a greenhouse house and which
shall be subject to the rules adopted by
the department under RSA
126x colon
6 um section three and all applicable
provisions of this chapter that are
already in there apply to having the
greenhouse so in terms of what we do now
and what this would change what we do
now is we have a grow house it is
completely enclosed there is no sunlight
interacting with the therap cannabis
planting material that's being grown
there um and in this
facility there is High Press um lighting
and um items that are used to raise the
cannabis plants but in an in an
unnatural situation with a greenhouse
you would not only curtail the carbon
footprint of the um alternative
treatment centers but you would be using
natural sunlight to grow the cannabis
plants and
um all of the things that go with doing
this the natural way also come under the
same exact applicable Provisions that
the growhouse is under right now so in
terms of security um interfacing with
the town in which the cultivation Center
is
located um the applicable the
application of the rules by the
department and by the
program should not be imp this there
should be no impact to this
um the local governing town or body of
the city or town where the additional
cultivation location would be located we
would be soliciting input from
qualifying patients designated
caregivers and residents of the town or
city just as we would if we were opening
up a new dispensary in the area but this
cultivation actually it's loosing it up
by adding a greenhouse and allowing
these the greenhouse would be just for
cultivation so before I mumble on a
little longer I just want to open it up
to questions there's people that have
more um Salient information about the
amount of utilities that the way we do
it now requires versus the way this
would be helpful to them particularly
thank you thank you are there any
questions representative Missour and
then representative mle after Missour
thank you madam chair um thank you for
taking my question actually it's
actually a point of clarity so you
mentioned that the analysis should read
this bill allows instead of that word
second
additional so to me those are two very
different words so if we're allowing a
second cultivation Center and if if
you're and correct me if I'm wrong if
you said that should say this bill
allows additional cultivation centers
those are different things so can you
clarify what you meant by
that yes I can and thanks that's a good
question um I'm just noticing that when
exactly what you're noticing this line
in the analysis doesn't match the text
in the bill and
so I made reference to it as an error
because I would hope that if we move
ahead with this that that goes over to
error do you have a followup or no so
what happens with that then what how do
we fix that before it moves on may I ask
you to send an email to OSS and let us
know what you find out because I think
it'd be a great idea for us to be able
to correct these when necessary on that
on that sorry is that me or is that
representative maor okay not
Representative no no not at all if you
want me to comment I can but if you
don't need me to that's fine I just um
this is a mistake in the drafting that's
the way I see that and and so yes
clarifying that um my understanding is
that the bill
text takes all precedence over any
analysis statement but that I could be
wrong about that and it would be
judicious to get
the um information directly from Office
of legislative Services y thank you
thank you representative mlan and then
representative
Shapiro uh thank you Madame CH chair and
and thank you for taking my question so
I remember when we first brought in an
ATC into Manchester we had the the
public hearings and one of the things
that everybody was reassured about at
the time that that Center came in is in
fact it was brought in with great
secrecy nobody nobody even we knew it
was in the district but nobody knew
where and they said it's it's it's going
to be nondescript nobody's going to know
it's there it's not going to you know
present you know any interest to the
community at all because it's boom um
and this is going to be changing all
that it's going to be a greenhouse it's
going to be much more visible um so is
there any was any of that taken into
account I mean I understand the argument
that hey it's going to be more energy
efficient and things of this nature but
the other concerns that were kind of
brought up when the atcs were first
brought in um is there any reason that
we're we're comfortable moving beyond
that at this point do you
know I think that's a really good
question um I think that we can be
comfortable moving beyond that at this
point because we're giving the um
opportunity to the ATC to lower patient
cost and to and find a better way to
make the products and that helps the
program all the way around but each and
every step of the way there's been a
public hearing before any kind of
structure has been allowed to impact a
community and
I'm the
nondescript type of location and the the
whole
discret um and health protected
information is certainly going to be
taken and considered by the atcs and if
it's not the public is going to make
them aware of any concerns and any kind
of
discretionary
um approaches they would
take thank you so um and for any new
installations it it's enabling it allows
you to put in and it will go through the
whole public hearing process kind of
thing it talks about that but for
existing
facilities um if you wanted to convert
them
um would that conversion go through the
same process they would have to come
back and go back to the community again
and engage them we want to convert it
from the state it's in now to like for
example a greenhouse state with the
existing facilities where they also have
to go through that same process is that
the
intention if they wanted to change from
having the grow house that they have
right now which I didn't hear I heard
that what what would be helpful is if
they were to because they want to be
able to increase their production and we
want to make more access to the products
for the public we want to them to be
able to get the certification but we
also want them to have the benefit of
the price points and right now um so
what we're asking you know would the
atc's move away from having a grow house
that's you know probably costing like
$20,000 a month to put these
high-intensity lights and build up theat
heat and then try to take that heat and
cool the place back down I so they have
to think about what they I you know I
wasn't under the understanding that
people would convert what they have now
but that this would be additional grow
houses um cultivation centers really and
if it were to be a greenhouse I I just
don't see how that would be really
different in terms of like it can be
discreet it can be as as secure in my
mind thank you thank you representative
Shapiro thank you madam
chair what what is the main impetus for
bringing this bill or making this change
is it Financial is it ecological is it
somehow the quality of the Cannabis that
will be
grown is it all the what is what is the
motivating factor towards making this
change
I can say as a legislator and a patient
of the therapeutic cannabis program that
I think this will be helpful for a lot
of the things that where they just want
to grow and perhaps bring some of
the what their results are just from
cultivation standpoint and not
necessarily be working on the synthesis
of products in any additional facilities
so they would still need to have a
facility where they use energy and they
convert the products from raw plant into
the different products that they have on
their menu um but at the same
time they would be able to grow more
economically they would be able to have
an additional location I think when you
think about the carbon
footprint that's another argument in
favor of this because is really the way
what we do right now is we we don't have
any natural sunlight coming in we just
have grow lights and we have the the air
circulation system and that's what we're
working with so
um I think the impetus is to help the
dispensaries to grow more product at a
better price but the other things are
very hard to tease out because there
benefits
absolutely you know to the environment
and followup
followup you know I don't really know
about this but so this is just what I've
about the odor that comes from um the
growing of cannabis and I mostly read
articles in like about California where
there were some you know those were
illegal um
growing but that in some neighborhoods
where a lot of marijuana was grown that
the neighborhoods were so affected by
the
smell in a negative way um and
so so I've never heard that brought up
in in terms of New Hampshire and the
growing the grow houses that exist here
is that an issue and if it is an issue
would it be more of an issue if it was
done in a more um you know in a
greenhouse rather than a self-contained
building and you maybe you don't know
about this or or maybe I'm off the Mark
I don't know not at all um no
representative Shapiro thank you for the
question and no I think that's that's a
really good question I'm at this point
right now
not um on the property of the grow house
that they have right now but there are
people in the room who are and who can
perhaps help all of us like have more
firsthand knowledge about the
therapeutic cannabis program including
like myself being able to go to the grow
house and find out but following my
testimony there are a couple people here
that can probably take that question and
swiftly deal with
it better than me and I'll actually
interject here as chair um in
conjunction with the adult use um Bill
there have been some um cultivators who
have offered to provide tours for people
who want to understand this more um I
don't know if those who are growing with
the atcs will be able to make a similar
offer um but that's something where so
that we could be more knowledgeable
about what we are increasing access to
anybody on this committee who's
interested in learning more about the
actual process I could help coordinate
that either through um those in Maine
who have offered up the opportunity or
if the atcs are interested in doing that
here so I think I think that would
answer a lot of the questions that you
have because I did take a tour of one
and it's not what I read on to read on
in the newspapers and see on TV so and I
can just if you don't mind Madam chair I
can just um reiterate that with that we
there's a lot of interest in finding out
more about about what we're doing and
there are more opportunities for the
house and house members and the Health
and Human Services committee to engage
and find out what exactly we're doing so
that you know where we're going with the
program and what our vision is because
come in and as representative Thomas
said we come in and we we're looking at
things peace meal a little bit at a time
and it's a big
picture thank you for that are there
other questions from the
committee okay seeing none thank you
Thomas hi again uh representative Wendy
Thomas town of marac um a few things I
wanted to clarify from the previous
statement um I think there's some
confusion because they do not grow at
the atc's at the at the ATC proper it is
a storefront where they sell the the the
flower the the products they grow in a
cultivation facility that is
offsite so they don't so in your
hypothetical situation the ATC to the
best of my knowledge anyway would not be
setting up a greenhouse like Outback or
anything like
that right right so this is this
has I was going to say it has nothing to
do with the atcs but the ATC is a
storefront the growing happens off off
property correct they work in
conjunction um and to answer the
question of why we would need a bill
like this um we've just spent the whole
day talking about adding different
different different symptoms anxiety
Eating Disorders um a bill that you just
passed 20 Z thank you very much um that
would allow Physicians to p uh to
recommend for any condition so what
we're talking about is opening up this
program making it bigger if we're going
to do that we need more
product allowing the the atcs to have a
greenhouse means they don't have to set
up a whole building it's a it's sort of
a a faster way to get this done it's not
so I mean it's just it increases the
floor space for for creating more
product for for planting
um the other thing is that I will tell
you that with the release of this HHS uh
report descheduling uh or rescheduling I
should say cannabis from 1 to three or
three to one
um so many people have already contacted
me um because they know that this isn't
my wheelhouse they know that I'm a real
Advocate there's going to be tremendous
increase in interest and people trying
this program because now our federal
government is saying hey you know what
it's been medicine all along and it's
helped a lot of people so I've had so
many people contact me and ask me
questions how do I get started what do I
use what strain you know how do you do
this so the atcs as long as we don't
have Recreation the atcs are going to
have to
bump up their production to accommodate
these
needs oh and the other thing about the
smell there was a question about smell
so here's the thing you harvest cannabis
before it
flowers so you're not going to get any
kind of a flower smell you're going well
we use the word flower you're going to
get an organic smell a very sort
of like like cut grass smell or
something to some of us it it is a
lovely lovely smell I I mean I just
adore the smell of cannabis I I know I
know it's it's a little weird but um it
it's not it's not you know a a I mean
sometimes when you smoke and especially
if you're um smoking the skunky um the
skunky strains it can be a little um
overpowering but the plant itself is no
no
more it smells no more worse than tomato
thank you are there other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much uh next I'll call Matt Simon from
you thank you again Madame chair again
for the record Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis um we support this bill I'll
begin by answering representative
Shapiro's question I the main driving
force behind this bill is cost
affordability for patients when this law
first passed in 2013 it was at the end
of a 4year ordeal we had bills passed
the House and Senate and vetoed in 2009
and
2012 there was strong opposition from
the police Chiefs Association and many
others there was a climate of fear
around this issue so as the law was
being implemented there were a number of
policy decisions that had to be made
that could roughly be described on a
spectrum from prioritizing patient care
the patient experience low costs high
quality and over here there was a
concern about security diversion some
people were very afraid that the
licensed businesses would simply be
selling cannabis at the high school and
shoving it out the side door and
everything so during that implementation
period I would describe it charitably as
an abundance of caution that led the
general court uh to adopt a law and
rules that were very restrictive and not
for the benefit of patients so patients
are aware that prices are lower in
neighboring states they wonder why that
that is and the number one complaint
about New Hampshire's therapeutic
cannabis program Far and Away has been
cost from the very beginning why is it
cheaper in Maine than in New Hampshire
and there are a number of reasons for
that but one of the basic reasons is
that neighboring states allow Greenhouse
cultivation neighboring states also
allow outdoor cultivation that doesn't
have to be in a greenhouse they do they
have regulations they have security
requirements but they have options for
cultivators so this is something that's
contributed to the high cost of cannabis
all along and this would be a way that
we could make cannabis somewhat more
affordable for p patients in New
Hampshire while reducing our carbon
footprint which our production facility
is made up of people who grow in
processed plants they tend to love the
environment and nature and would prefer
to be operating uh as environmentally
friendly as we can so representative
veil's description is correct there are
no windows in our production facility um
one clarification it's it's a little
funny the way the law is written but the
companies are
atcs as an ATC we have a licensed
production facility ours happens to be
in Peterboro you could spend hours
driving around Peterboro and you would
never find it but it is there in a very
non-descript
location I will admit that there is a
slight uh cannabis smell as you approach
that facility uh it is not a strong
smell and the key is that nobody gets
near our facility except for the people
that work there and and contractors who
come in we would love to host a tour uh
and we've very open to that um uh
touring any ATC location uh does require
approval in writing from the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services so if this committee
for example would like to tour our
production facility we would be happy to
have you we would just have to formally
request that through the appropriate
channels and we could pick a date and
walk you through it I'm sure that would
be very educational and happy to have
you
um so in discussing this bill how to
bring it in we actually considered
whether to put outdoor in there I assume
that the adult use bill will allow
outdoor cultivation we don't have a long
growing season in New Hampshire but you
can get one good season out of a New
Hampshire summer and uh that will be the
most cost-effective and Environ
environmentally friendly uh product that
you can have so
uh the committee could choose to add
outdoor to to this sentence but I we
wanted to get it passed and and speaking
for granite Leaf we would really like to
have a greenhouse that's what we would
very much like to pursue for the above
mentioned reasons and so just adding a
greenhouse would be great adding
Greenhouse or outdoor that would be
great too I'll leave that all to you
but more than happy to answer any
questions thank you questions from the
committee repres restive Nel and then
representative Missour thank you Miss
chairman Madam chairman I'm
sorry thank you for taking my question
I'm I'm just curious so I actually did I
used to be on one of the dispensary
boards and I and I actually did tour the
facility and what they they what I was
struck with was just the sophistication
of the growth process and and every
variable was controlled the humidity the
temperature and into a square foot I
mean that that amazed me and they said
to me very specifically that that was
necessary to create a reproducible
product which a pharmaceutical product
should be I'm confused when you start
going outdoors and into green houses how
do you accomplish that and and create a
reproducible product so that we make
sure people are getting something that
they think they're getting yeah so thank
you for that question it's a good
question uh there are advantages and
disadvantages to indoor cultivation
versus outdoor cultivation indoors you
can control every aspect of the
environment you can you're basically
recreating nature indoors and tricking a
plant into thinking it's summer and then
fall and you can control every variable
assuming you don't have power outages
which we've had some issues over the
years uh some complications um I I would
say
that some cannabis will always be grown
indoors we're not proposing to move all
of our cultivation Outdoors
uh
the highest and most high quality flour
will always be produced indoors under
lights uh this would
enable more cultivation of products that
most of which will be made into other
products so there there's this is where
the independent lab testing comes in
every batch of cannabis that we grow has
to be tested by an independent lab for
the canabo we also test for the tarpine
content and for a wide range of
contaminants as required by state law so
there's actually more risk of
contamination with outdoor cultivation
that's one of the reasons I'm personally
so concerned about Main's medical
cannabis program where there are
hundreds of caregivers growing outdoor
cannabis and selling it in caregiver
storefronts uh with no lab testing
requirement and the price is very
appealing to patients and patients
particularly New Hampshire patients may
not have any idea that those products
are not lab tested so in our case we'd
be testing the flour that we grew
outdoors and then we'd be making
products out of that flour and then we
would have to have those products tested
as well so it would be a controlled
product it would have to be controlled
testing so building on that is that one
of the reason reasons why there's I I
know there's a lot of reasons for cost
difference but is that one of them that
the level of um oversight that we have
here in terms of the final product
versus there does that dramatically
increase cost it significantly increased
costs that is one area of cost increase
that I have never complained about
because obvious reasons uh patients or
even adult consumers uh you know we've
heard a lot recently about cannabis
being uh adulterated with fentanyl for
example I'm I I think there have been
very few confirmed cases of that
actually happening uh but what I've been
saying for 17 years as an advocate for
responsible regulation of cannabis is
that there's a tremendous amount of
cannabis on the illicit Market that is
Tainted with mold and pesticides and
fungicides and heavy metals uh the
Cannabis that we produce within the
therapeutic cannabis program does not
have those contaminants and that would
be the only concern introduced by
outdoor or Greenhouse cultivation but we
have a testing system that would prevent
that from negatively impacting
patients um thank you and before I
recognize representative Missour um I
did want to recognize that having any
sort of field trip of the committee is
going to run into all sorts of
challenges so anybody who wants to learn
about it I suggest reach out to Mr Simon
um but this won't be any sort of uh
mileage approved sort of official
tours so representative
Missour thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question you um mentioned
law
enforcement have they come out in
support or opposition of this has there
been any discussions maybe there here is
someone here to testify today I don't
know um but I'd be curious to see what
their stance would be on it yeah thank
you for the question I have not spoken
to the chiefs of Police Association I
don't see them here today
so thank you any other questions from
the committee um and I will ask one I I
do know that the largest complaint has
been the cost and that some oncologists
in the state in the past have just
suggested that their patients seek out
their grandchildren to reached that
market but I think that was in the early
days um but the cost is is still
significant um will this allow an
increased scale that then will allow you
to bring down prices to a point where
more patients do access it and and sort
of have a have a more Market stabilizing
function by allowing more canopy
space I believe so I there are a number
of factors that that impact cost uh but
this is certainly one of them it would
enable us to cultivate more cheaply and
to pass that savings
along thank you um and with that I will
call oh sorry I representative Merchant
has a question thank you madam chair and
thank you for the quick question
I'm looking at the bill at this point in
time on line seven about compliance with
local zoning laws then it goes on and
says they Department shall in
conjunction with local governing body
and so forth consult with
them are we saying that the local zoning
law if they decide not to allow for This
Will trump the department or is it just
one of those things where it's a
courtesy from the Department to talk to
local people But ultimately they can do
wish okay thank you for the question I
think it it may be two questions uh we
would have to comply with local zoning
laws I don't think there's any ambiguity
there uh and the department separately
shall uh solicit input from patients
caregivers and residents of the town and
that goes back to what representative
mlan was saying when each of the uh
dispensaries and production facilities
open there had to be a public meeting in
that town to discuss concerns it was not
an approval process uh but they did have
to be consistent with zoning they we
laws thank you in regards to the zoning
laws help with with the
clarification what happens if the town
laws I don't
know
thank you any other
questions thank you very much thank you
Riddle I've been a little LAX on this
I'm going to make sure that I do in fact
make it Ding and let you know if you've
gone too far past so just for everybody
in general not for you specifically okay
thank you ma'am I was worried that you
were singling me out do I have a reput
not at all I just want to make sure that
I'm not letting things sort of extend
for everybody before I start how long
are you setting up for three minutes oh
okay so less than you've actually
requested which is a good reason to ask
to remind you okay thank you madam chair
members of the committee my name is Jim
Riddle and Hillsboro I mentioned before
some of you weren't in the room yet I do
have a uh New Hampshire medical card as
well as a USDA hemp grower license I
grew up on a farm and been involved in
agriculture my whole life and uh
specifically in organic production and
uh you know the way that the um current
uh cannabis medical cannabis is produced
as was described by Mr Simon as indoors
total artificial environment you know
dependent on electricity High inputs of
light and uh ventilation Etc and yeah
that's producing uh good predictable
products but I'm very excited to see
this bill before you uh to get some of
that production in at least into a
greenhouse and I I I would certainly
encourage amending uh to add the words
or Outdoors to the sentence where the
greenhouse is is uh mentioned in in line
five um because I think um that provides
a totally different product um if you
think about the tomatoes you grow in
your Garden in the summer the flavor
versus the ones you're buying right now
in the grocery store they look nice they
look like tomatoes but they just don't
have flavor but things that are grown in
Healthy Living soils I we've had a
saying in the organic world forever that
healthy soil leads to healthy plants
healthy animals healthy people and a
healthy Planet it's all about soil
health and you can extract the chemicals
and give that plant what it needs to
produce the cannaboids and good flour
Etc but there's nothing like that the
Ecology of soil the organisms that
release nutrients to the plants lead to
much more complex phytochemicals in that
plant and with cannabis medicine it's
not just the cannaboids it's not just
the THC level that everybody's focusing
on potency it's also the Turpin these
secondary plant uh phytochemicals that
when you you know really uh can be
produced under those artificial
conditions definitely um but they also
can be produced uh with Healthy Living
soil and plants that are uh exposed to
the sunlight but also to the wind to
pests they develop different chemicals
depending on the stresses that a plant
experiences during its life um so I just
um I don't want to endanger the bill by
adding or Outdoors if if that would you
know make too many red flags go up but
in reality that would allow three types
of production really the total
artificial indoors that we have now the
greenhouse which is intermediary and
then the outdoors and that will uh um be
the most environmentally sound but also
produce the broadest range of products
to serve the needs of patients thank you
thank you are there any questions from
the committee representative McAn thank
you madam chair so just for
informational purposes because I don't
know um when you go to buy a nice juicy
tomato and you get it from you know the
outside it's nice and it's juicy and
it's delicious but there's also a lot of
variety um one of the things when I go
and I buy like a a Tylenol pill I want
the Tylenol to be consistent pill to
pill to pill so um so there was some
testimony earlier that may be questioned
that maybe we would be giving up some of
that repeatability though if we went to
um outdoor growing so how significant
would that be yeah well I come back to
uh Matt Simon's response which you know
that's really the business model the
choice of the ATC here but uh and yes
they want that predictability it has to
be on the label they need to meet their
quality standards um so what I heard him
say is if they could do greenhouse or
outdoor that would be to produce plants
that then would be used for processed
products not so much for the raw flower
but if it could meet the quality
standards and the predictability in
either outdoor or Greenhouse production
um there's no reason why they should be
prohibited from doing that but if
there's any uncertainty about either the
cannaboid levels or the turpine levels
then that can be formulated by um
breaking down that product and and
putting it into an edible where it's
gone through a lab testing and it's the
controlled um representative
Merchant thank you madam
chair and also I want to follow up on
the comment about
consistency if the final product
regardless of where it starts but where
it ends up we're going through the
analysis to show and demonstrate through
the lab analysis that the product is
basically the same regardless of its
source is that not kind of the
gatekeeper is that it's the stamp of
approval saying this product is the same
as that product because we gone through
the lab
analysis yeah thank you for your
question I I I think any product that's
put on the uh Market needs to meet all
the basic minimums for you know safety
as well as predictability that if it
says it has a certain cannaboid content
it needs to have that but there are
people uh in the marketplace uh looking
for outdoor Gran and uh I mentioned that
I've been involved in the organic I was
an organic inspector for 20 years and
and served on the national organic
Standards Board and the
regulatory because cannabis is federally
prohibited and because the word organic
is federally regulated there cannot be
certified organic cannabis there can be
hemp which
is the cousin you know same same species
but uh um but yet you see that word
organic used all over the place in the
Cannabis trade but it's an unregulated
claim that's being made I I want to see
regulated claims that have meaning but
there is a market
for and now we're talking more in the
adult youth recreational side but people
are looking for outdoor grown they're
looking for specific strain specific
label um question representative
Nagel thank you madam chair thanks for
taking oh sorry thanks for taking my
question um we're about to hear another
bill that has to do with homegrown
functionally
um I mean this is cost and access are
huge issues we've already talked about
today um what I'm looking at is you're
going to be um Limited in terms of
dispensaries in terms of having to grow
indoors where they can grow It Outdoors
that doesn't seem to be fair is some of
this creating some sense of fairness um
any quality of product
because yeah thank you for your question
and yeah I have to agree with where
you're going with that is uh if uh uh
there is the uh outdoor grow option uh
for patients to grow a few plants uh
hopefully that will be allowed to be up
to their choice not be micromanaged by
the state of whether it has to be in a
closet in a grow tent or it could be uh
Outdoors so long as it's secure and
meets whatever rules accompany it um but
yeah I think the atc's who have invested
who've carried this Market made it what
it is um should be able to play on the
same level playing field that the uh
patients hopefully will be able to when
the next bill is
passed thank you any other questions um
saying none thank you very much for your
testimony um next I'd like to call Dr
Riley
Kirk thank you madam chair and the rest
of the committee uh my name is Dr Riley
Kirk I have a PhD in Pharmaceutical
Sciences specializing in the chemistry
and pharmacology of the cannabis plant I
want to highlight a fact that Jim Riddle
just made earlier about greenhouse and
outdoor cultivation practices enhancing
the flavor of the flow flavor is a
result of tpin and other smelly
molecules present in this plant in
indoor cultivation the plant has less of
a need to produce these smelly molecules
because the purpose of producing these
molecules for the plant is to protect
itself from sunlight microbes and other
environmental stressors without these
stressors there's no need for the plant
to produce them so it produces less we
have peer-reviewed scientific studies
that greenhouse and outdoor grown
cannabis produce unique therapeutically
relevant compounds compared to strictly
indoor cultivation including a
significant increase in tpin and
cannaboids and actually less degraded
molecules compared to indoor grow indoor
cultivation Greenhouse cultivation and
outdoor cultivation can all be used as
tools to provide the greatest divers
diversity and medically relevant
compounds from this bioactive plant I
understand the need for consistency in
cannabis products but the efficacy of
outdoor and Greenhouse grown cannabis is
an undeniable um effect especially for
our medical
patients Greenhouse cultivation also
makes the growing process of greenhouse
more oh sorry cultivation makes the
growing process of cannabis more green
AKA more eco-friendly as mentioned
earlier earlier meaning it limits the
amount of artificial lighting and the
associated light bills and heat costs of
those cultivation practices it is also
going to allow for faster and more
robust cultivation to AC accommodate our
potentially upcoming adult use industry
in the state which will hopefully allow
us to meet the demand and keep the cost
of the products as low as possible as
far as the smell of cannabis I will
remind everyone that manure from farms
smells pretty strongly and some old
paper smells also smells pretty strongly
but we did not stop these industries
because of smell
alone there are also some smell
remediation technologies that could be
implemented to reduce the smell of
greenh houses as Matt and as Matt Simon
mentioned earlier um these green houses
are not going to be put in the middle of
dog parks or next to the mall they're
often very far off the beaten path and
hard to find if you don't know what
you're looking for I also understand the
argument that some people don't want to
see a greenhouse but alternatively I
would say that myself and many other
people in the state would love to see
more Greenhouse uh cultivation
cultivating cannabis we should not feel
the need to hide in secretive
non-descript buildings as this portrays
our industry in the wrong light and this
is exactly what our industry has been
forced to do for decades one of the
benefits of an expanding legal industry
in New Hampshire is we can be proud of
it and showcase the amazing cultivators
in our state and the flowers that they
cultivate to heal our citizens thank you
I'll take any questions
thank you representative Nagel thank you
madam chair thanks for taking my
question you said something that really
struck me you said the undeniable
efficacy of homegrown do you have any
data to support that because I've never
heard that of outdoor gr of outdoor
grown of outdoor I would refer back to
the paper that I'm happy to send you
from the University of Colorado that was
comparing indoor vers outdoor versus
Greenhouse showing that there is
substantially higher amounts of these
bioactive compounds produced in outdoor
in Greenhouse cultivation compared to
indoor and to me that's synonymous with
efficacy because you have more of the
medicinal compounds present in those
flowers and unique compounds as
well thank you
one other questions or did you have a
follow up to that well isn't a followup
as a separate question yes another
question so one of the things I was
struck on my tour is that the um the
place smelled like grapefruit which is
what the tpin smell like um that's not
an obnoxious smell it's not till you
burn the actual product that you get the
obnoxious smell and that can be
controlled am I correct absolutely yeah
and I agree I think that grapefruit
smell is amazing and people I mean these
cultivation facilities aren't you know
burning a bunch of cannabis and that's
you know causing the whole area to smell
it's they're just cultivating plants
that are producing relatively low levels
of these organic compounds called tpin
which are also present in every single
other plant that exists in the
world representative
Merchant thank you madam chair thank you
for thanking my question when we're
talking about the clinical efficacy of
the
product out grown Outdoors versus grown
in Greenhouse so we talking about a
product that's consumed orally um in a
sense it's edible and it's going through
GI track we talking about a product
that's going through the lungs through
something that's inhaled because they're
fundamentally do different ways to get
the drug into the body that's a very
good question I'm just really referring
to what the plant is producing for those
molecules and then I think it would be
up to that uh business to decide what to
do with it after but it exists in that
plant when oftentimes it does not exist
in indoor cultivation because those
genes are never activated to actually
transcribe and produce those molecules
so thank you followup question to
representative Nagel as
well is it's nice to talk about
the plant itself and what we find from
analyzing the plant can we somehow tie
that to some sort of studies evidence
that that change in the plant per
se causes a change in the efficacy of
the product in the body I will bring up
an example of the study that I'm
referencing that there was an increase
in the amount of beta caropine which is
a turpine produced by the cannabis plant
beta caropine directly to the canab
cannaboid 2 receptor in the gut and it
has been shown to be efficacious for
people with crohn's disease ulcerative
colitis and many other gut conditions so
in this instance the plants that produce
more of this medicinal compound would be
more medicinally relevant and often
efficacious for this population compared
to a plant that was grown indoors that
molecule thank you uh representative
Nagel sorry thank you madam chair I just
have a quick if you could send me the
the paper from University of Colorado
and do you by any chance know who the
authors were of that paper not off the
top of my you get it for us I'm happy to
send it though thank you um thank you
actually if you send it to the chair
chairman we probably all want to have it
so if you send it to the chairman he can
distribute it to the committee thank you
very much for your testimony and your
study of this uh
subject um next I'll call Dr joannon and
he's the last card I have for this um
this
you thank you all you start the timer
anytime I'm
ready um thank you my name is Joe Hannah
uh I've talked to you already several
times so I won't be too wordy like I
usually am but um you know I was also on
the the uh study commission not the
recent one but the one that had a quarum
and a report years ago um and we we took
tours I also took tours uh with people
on this committee at a grow facility um
I drove past it three times before I
could find it I kept turning I'm like
where is it where is it I couldn't find
the place uh it was very and it was a
huge building but it was very easy to
miss I didn't even really smell it as I
was approaching it in fact the the place
that I uh I could say it's safe it's
safe to say that I smelled a stronger I
wouldn't say overwhelming I was welmed
uh by the smell of cannabis in the back
of the the house anti room more than I
was walking past any of these grow
facilities for some that know history
you might know what I'm talking about um
but it was in the paper look it up um so
anyway the we we've already heard
building costs the higher energy costs
that we have in New Hampshire that's one
reason why things are more anything
indoors is more expensive building costs
limitations of materials I tried to put
in a little renovation in my house I
couldn't get plywood for two years you
know what do you have if you can't you
know there's cars in the market that
were there without transistors there are
I heard Governor sen last night talking
about a housing crisis they have uh a
building several building projects have
been held up because of like a
Transformer of some kind they can't get
there are very large projects that can't
be done because of things in the market
it also from my my my uh learning
experiences with the different uh
Growers and stuff it takes many months
maybe up to 9 11 months or more once the
once you have a building to actually get
a crop and a a ready for market so they
don't just say oh we're going to grow
have a grow facility and then like you
know one sun cycle later they're they're
ready you know they can't really do it
that fast it takes many months and
millions of dollars to get these places
up and running so if we're going to have
an expanded patient population which
thank you for pushing that um you're
going to need expanded supply for the
for the patients and this is absolutely
necessary uh utility costs we talked
about meeting the needs of the patients
having by decreased costs but it was
also mentioned by someone I'd like to
reiterate it's important for the
purposes of diversity of product uh you
know you're going to see if you only can
have so much and you can only grow one
you know one area or one crop you're not
going to have as much diversity and
people really have different needs for
for for medical products not just in
cannabis but anything um you know I I I
guess we if we pulled everyone here
what's your favorite soft drink there
would be many different you know options
uh it's the same with cannabis people
have different flavors different choices
and there's different things we heard
about uh medicinal properties that
you're going to have increased benefits
from from growing
Outdoors um you know and lastly i' I'd
like to say that um you know having one
grow facility is really having a
business with all of their eggs in one
basket if something happens to that
place if a roof collapse from snow if
there's a power outage or a Transformer
gets hit that place is out of commission
it could ruin AC Copic or delay it um
that can drastically affect the
patients's um you know ability to get
their what they need it can affect costs
and all kinds of things so please pass
this this is this one just makes sense
um and i' I'd really appreciate if you
could also support this to be in line
with supporting expanding the uh medical
patient population thank you thank you
are there questions from the committee
seeing none uh thank you very much and
since I don't have any other cards I
will close the hearing on House Bill
1581 and hand uh the the role of chair
back to the chairman of the
Lon okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on host Bill 1231 at this time
and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Wendy Thomas
representative Thomas we need to give
you a seat at this table I think or at
least in this
committee it's me again um
representative Wendy Thomas town of
marac I am pleased to present this bill
once again to this committee it is the
exact same bill as amended that you
passed last year 19 to1 from this
committee and it passed on the consent
calendar it was put on the table in the
Senate so I'm here to introduce House
Bill 2170 which is permitting qualifying
patients and designated caregivers to
cultivate cannabis for therapetic use
most people call this the hom grow bill
so I'm going to walk you through this
this this argument so why do we need
this bill first reason is cost cannabis
is not covered by insurance if you are a
patient who uses a lot to keep your
symptoms under control it can be
expensive and remember this is a
vulnerable able population many of us
are unable to hold
jobs this bill helps lowincome immobile
or H homebound patients who need
medicinal cannabis to able to grow their
own medicine and get help help doing
so dispensary location there are seven
dispensaries in all of New Hampshire not
all patients have cars or an affordable
way to get to them just to put that into
perspective in my town of marac we have
five
pharmacies strains everyone reacts
differently to cannabis strains what may
work right for one person might not be
as effective for another person
sometimes the strain that works best for
you might be discontinued growing it
would be a good
option the New Hampshire therapeutic
cannabis program began in 2013 it's 10
years old since we began we have learned
about the program and patients needs
dispens have been added along with more
qualif qualifications to get into the
program and the program has been
modified to better suit patients needs
since 2009 the New Hampshire house has
consistently supported bills allowing
patients with qualifying medical
conditions and their caregivers to
cultivate cultivate a limited supply of
cannabis in 2012 and 2019 the Senate
agreed advancing homegrown legislation
went to the governor 's desk both bills
were vetoed and the override efforts
fell short in the senate in 2020 the
Senate passed a homeg grow bill in a
Voice vote but the outbreak of covid-19
prevented it from being considered in
the
house what this bill does this bill
allows New Hampshire therapeutic
cannabis patients or caregivers to grow
their own cannabis plants at their place
of residence within guard rails set
forward by this bill
patients are still Bound by the
guidelines of the program as identified
when you submit or renew your
application if grown outside the plants
cannot be viewed from another private
property it would allow New Hampshire
therapeutic cannabis patients to have
and grow Three Mature which are
flowering plants three immature or
non-flowering plants and 12 seedlings
which are identified at 6 in or
less patients can grow the plants from
seeds and some of the dispensaries have
said that they will be able to provide
seedlings the plants must be kept in a
locked and secured location that is
reported to the state the patient must
ensure that the plants are secured from
unauthorized access patients would have
access to State Labs for testing of
cannabinoids and possible contamination
which is usually mold or
mites what this bill does not do this
bill does not mean that every
therapeutic cannabis patient will start
growing plants some patients will try
and then realize it's too much work and
they'll stop some patients will be
interested and will simply gather
information on how to grow cannabis
plants and some patients will simply say
I'd rather buy the
flower it does not create dealers or
suppliers the therapeutic cannabis
program is
self-regulating to be in this program
you must sign a contract that stipulates
limitations on how much cannabis we can
have where we can keep it and how and
where we can use it we know that if we
disregard these conditions we can be
kicked out of the program or we can be
penalized at a higher rate than
others no patient is going to risk that
again this is not Recreation this is a
medical program for very sick patients
it does not create hidden stash stat St
ashes of cannabis growth locations must
be reported to the
state reasons for allowing home
cultivation secure home cultivation is
not causing any problems 14 of the 18
states that have legalized adult use
cannabis and about half of the medical
commun uh cannabis states allow for
personal uh
cultivation in the states that have
reasonable safeguards home cultivation
has not been a problem no no state has
repealed home
cultivation home cultivation is
important for patients about 6% of
Americans use cannabis for therapeutic
reason uh reasons insurance does not
cover cannabis for many people with
serious medical conditions medical
expenses and a reduced ability to work
make getting cannabis cannabis Difficult
by allowing home cultivation you are
giving the therapeutic patients
Financial relief for their non-insurance
covered medicine
home cultivation helps to displace the
illicit Market some patients need more
some patients don't have the financial
means to purchase tested and measured
cannabis from the dispensaries home
cultivation would allow those patients
access to cannabis without having to use
the illicit Market home cultivation is
consistent with our commitment to
freedom and equality in a free Society
in a state with the motto of Live Free
or Die adults should be allowed to grow
cannabis plants in their homes for
therapeutic use what's happening in the
other states Connecticut allows up to
Three Mature plants and three immature
plants Maine allows up to six FL
flowering plants six immature plants and
unlimited seedlings Massachusetts allows
up to six plants per person person or
patient no more than
12 Rhode Island up to 12 mature plants
and 12 immature plants per patient
Vermont up to two mature plants and
seven immature plants per
patient so who who supports this bill
this is a bipartisan bill that
originally came out of the committee
with a vote of 19 to1 and it passed in
the house in 2023 on the consent
calendar the dispensaries support H grow
and are ready to roll out classes on how
to grow and may even offer some
equipment that could be used to grow the
therapeutic cannabis board voted
unanimously to support this bill it is
seen as an economical way to support
therapeutic cannabis patients in summary
the New Hampshire therapeutic program
has been alive and well since 2016 and
it is only getting stronger as we listen
to patients needs House Bill 2170 is a
compassionate Humane bill that also
encourages business growth it's time to
let patients take more control of their
health and wallet by allowing for home
growth in the therapeutic
program and I'd like to point out that
there's two edits to this uh to this
7 uh page two line seven I'm sorry uh
the word with should be within and it's
really just a
uh it uh the the OS didn't catch that
there was a date change so the date
should be change from the year 2023 to
2024 so I don't know if that requires an
amendment these are really two typos so
I'm going to leave that in in your hands
but I'm happy to take any questions
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for bringing this
bill um I I actually see that it's not
bipartisan I had wanted to be a sponsor
but I'd be happy to bring forward the
amendment um to change those issues um
when I said it was bipartisan it passed
on the floor oh and it passed in this
committee so but I'd be very happy very
happy to have you on a an amendment for
this okay thank you and then the other
part is you had said that the seedlings
were up to six inches um but the
definition says up to 12 inches oh okay
just thank you this was last year's
testimony I yeah okay thank you no I I
appreciate the improvements and I I was
going to ask the question before I
looked it up so I figured I'd inform
everybody else so thank you for doing
this thank you representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I remember this
bill because it was 19 to1 last year but
you said it it died in the Senate do do
you know what their objections were and
and have you spoken to them and are they
okay with it just go around or what's
the status I guess is the question I am
never going to um take the
responsibility of speaking for the
Senate
however um this bill passed this bill
was seen as having Merit coming out of
committee um and it it was during a time
when the governor was indicating that he
would not sign any any uh cannabis bills
at all um while this bill was being
heard and put on the floor the governor
said that if you put a cannabis bill on
my desk I will sign it but it was too
late for this but because they in my
estimation because they found there was
Merit to this they didn't kill it in the
Senate they tabled it which is why you
are seeing the exact same wording as you
saw last year thank
you other uh representative Nagel thank
you Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question in full disclosure I was the
um sometimes it's a good thing to be the
19 to1 but anyways I I I've been on I
was on the board of one of the
dispensaries for I think six years um
I'm I know way more than I should know
about the business aspects of the
nonprofit thing I also sent two kids to
college in Colorado so I know how bad A
system can be my concern is this um and
I didn't really ask it very well of the
last um um witness from the previous
bill
but what I'm concerned about is this
when we created this law in this state
we went to Great Lengths to not make the
same mistakes that other states made I'm
sorry can you clarify which bill you
said when we created when we created the
statute that created the the alternative
program yeah the program exactly and I
was very proud the way that our state
did that um my concern is is this these
dispensaries as was noted have really
you know borne The Lion Share of
creating a really responsible program
but they they their their profit margins
aren't that great and little things can
make huge negative differences for them
and what I'm concerned about is you're
creating competition here that could
undermine them financially and I'm just
curious what your thoughts are about
that that's a great question um the the
atcs are behind this um
because yes it will people will grow
product at home so they're not going to
be buying it from the atc's but the atcs
will be providing some of them will be
providing seedlings they sell those they
don't just give those away they're going
to U perhaps be providing seeds again
you that's something you buy if you're
serious about growing at home you need
equipment and I talked to um a fellow
from Maine who is growing in in his home
and we went through the equipment and
for him to do a startup uh a 4 foot tent
is about ,000 worth of equipment to buy
so you know the dispensaries could could
sell the equipment I mean that's another
whole Avenue this this doesn't shut down
business this opens up another whole
Avenue of potential business for the
atcs plus there's education and we're
going to need we're going to need
private Consultants that are going to
work with people to show them how to
grow so that's going to that's going to
open up businesses for private
Consultants so so I I don't I don't see
enhancing you going to vote for it now I
said you're gonna vote for it
now no don't
Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman thank
you what is the thinking behind the
Three Mature plants the three immature
plants and 12 seedlings what happens to
the other nine seedlings when they're
ready to be immature plants uh not all
seedlings make it to adulthood just that
they're not they won't all be viable
yeah I mean it's kind of sad but not all
of them not all of them make it you know
be snuffed out or given to somebody else
they would have to be snuffed out or you
humanly other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you and this is my last one so oh
okay thank you very much we're GNA miss
pleasure also signed up to speak is
Michael Holt from the Department of
Services
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee thanks for the opportunity to
testify in this bill uh my name is
Michael Holt I'm the administrator of
the therapeutic cannabis program within
the Department of Health and Human
Services um the department doesn't have
a position doesn't take a pos position
on this bill but it unquestionably will
benefit patients uh due to increased
access increased strain availability and
lower costs the um the express concern
about home cultivation generally is
about the increased potential for
diversion um however this bill has been
circulating for years it has been
improved every year uh to try to
accommodate those concerns this is a
modest proposal especially in the terms
of the number of plants um and has many
many safeguards and guard rails um uh
representative Thomas mentioned many of
them i' just like to highlight them
again in a in a short list so that we
can here the um altogether the the the
guard rails in place with regard to this
legislation it allows a small number of
plants either the patient or their
caregiver can cultivate but not both if
the caregiver cultivates then that
caregiver can have only one patient
instead of the typical five that they
are allowed so there's no business model
here the location must be at the
person's residence it can't be in a
separate location
in a warehouse or an industrial space it
has to be at their residents the
location must be reported to and
registered with the
Department the location must be out of
public view in a locked and enclosed
space with a size limitation a landlord
can prohibit cultivation on lease
property the department is authorized to
share the registered location with local
and state law enforcement upon receipt
of a sworn affid it the atcs are allowed
in this uh Bill to provide seeds and
seedlings to patients so there is an
easy accessible source for
this independent testing labs are
allowed under this Bill to accept
samples from patients and caregivers uh
for testing for cannabinoid profile
contaminants and the department has the
authority under this bill to revoke the
cultivation privilege for any person for
violation of the law or the rules in
addition to all those safeguards in this
bill the current law establishes strict
severe penalties for any diversion by
patients or caregivers to any
unauthorized
persons up to seven years in
prison and up to
$300,000 in
fines as representative Thomas said
there's
no incentive for a patient in this
program to divert their
cannabis lastly I would say that the
department has no problems
operationalizing this bill I'm happy to
take any
questions representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh Mr Hol
for being being here um I just wanted to
kind of um understand the um ability to
uh disclose the location to law
enforcement upon a presentation of a
sworn affidavit do you can you delve
into that a little bit more for me yes
this program is a medical program uh the
information that the department has with
regard to patients and atcs is protected
by Hippa um we're not allowed to share
any information from our confidential
registry uh with external parties um
outside of a court order however there's
one provision uh that does allow the the
the state the therapeutic cannabis
program to release limited information
to local and state law enforcement not
federal law enforcement but local and
state law enforcement under certain
conditions one of those conditions is so
that local and state law enforcement can
verify that a patient is in fact a
patient um if there's a law enforcement
encounter um and the patient uh is a the
person is claims therapeutic use of
cannabis local and state law enforcement
officers are allowed to contact the
program and under those a certain
circumstances and an intake sheet we are
allowed to Prov to verify whether or not
that patient is in fact a patient or uh
whether they're on the registry or
not there's the second provision with
regard to our release of information is
that upon receipt of a sworn affidavit
uh affirming probable cause that
cannabis is possessed by a certain
person or a certain at a certain
location again the department is allowed
to confirm whether or not that personal
location is a registered patient and the
additions in this bill would extend that
allowance for us to provide information
to local and state law enforcement if
that registered location for cultivation
is in fact a registered location for
cultivation reported to the department
thank you very much other questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
just to be clear my concern always has
been reliability of product so if I
understand correctly from testimony
that's we've heard for the previous bill
that if I own um or I have a dispensary
I have to submit my product um for
reliability of product but if I have my
own homegrown thing I can but I don't
have to is that correct uh that is
correct Uh current currently patients
are not allowed under state law to go to
the single independent Testing Lab in
the state to have product tested uh
state law does not allow that lab to
accept those samples from any entity
except the three licensed atcs in the
state under this bill uh that provision
would be expanded so that the Testing
Laboratories can accept those samples
from patients who are interested to know
the cannabinoid profile how strong how
potent they're uh their products are um
and whether or not they have been grown
uh with uh you know with any
contaminants in them but you're you're
correct to say that there's not a
requirement for them to do so um and
that would be a I think that would be a
difficult provision
to
enforce follow up I I I totally
understand that but you
know we're talking about a medicinal
product not a recreational product and
in medicinal products we expect some
amount of reproducibility of what the
substance is and we are expecting that
of the dispensaries but we're not
expecting that of the people that are
going to grow it at home is that
correct so in other words they don't
have to test it if they don't want to uh
that's correct so so we don't have the
same level of expectations for them that
we do of every other pharmaceutical
country is is that a is that a a
question I mean it it I I think you're
right functionally it is so I'm I'm just
asking my wrong when I say that uh I
don't I don't think I don't think you're
wrong no okay uh the issue the issue is
is related to strain availability the
atcs can you know are only dra growing
so many strains um the cost certainly
which is a you know a huge barrier we as
we've heard all day um and the the
relative merits of those issues compared
to the reproducibility of a uh of a
specific strain you know Time After Time
After Time is one that that that is a
consideration before this committee um
you I like you too okay uh
representative Merchant and then
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman and also thank you for taking
my question Mr we've talked a couple of
times about the atcs and the profit
margins they have are relatively
thin can you speak or give me some
guidance here how this may impact the
atcs themselves are we in one way saying
that we're allowing people to homow
because it's a cost effective which I
understand can you speak to at least the
possible impact it's going to have on
the atcs themselves for the people who
decide not to Homegrown or if they don't
have atcs does that Force everybody to
become a hom
grower well that question should would
be better directed to representatives of
the atcs themselves however I will share
that historically starting last year all
three of the
atc's uh were publicly in support of
this
legislation um secondly it is assumed
that most patients don't have extraction
Laboratories in their homes and so
there's a wide variety of products that
the atc's sell cannabis infused products
uh that would not be re reproducible um
at a home at a home level and so while
it may impact the atc's somewhat um it
is not expected that every one will grow
their own it is not expected that those
who do grow their own don't go to the
atcs to purchase products that they
can't make
themselves thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this
question in terms of um individuals who
are growing their own plants then having
it tested um not knowing anything about
this modern agriculture of um cannabis
and not knowing anything about
testing
um given that these are a limited number
of plants which I assume would be
somewhat limited amount of cannabis or
product as it's called I don't really
like using that sort of product but um
that it would be a a limited amount of
product um is the amount needed for
testing would that de incentivize
testing would it be a significant amount
that you had to give to a
lab no okay it's a very small amount
that the lab requires to uh attach the
potency so that you know there' probably
be some cost but it wouldn't the amount
that you were having to not use but give
to a lab wouldn't be a a the the sample
size required by a laboratory to test
for potency and contaminants would not
serve should not serve as a a barrier if
someone was interested in um in having
their product tested thank you I say a
hand up here representative McLean did
you have your hand up earlier no okay
anyone
you also signed up to speak is former
kerk okay sorry and you do have my
testimony I distributed it before we
started this session so once again for
the record Jerry kerk chair of the theer
Cannabis medical oversight board um and
I'm here to report what TCM o feels
about this particular Bill uh TCM does
support hb1
1231 um we do that because we think it
will help our patients and caregivers
with affordability accessibility and
availability of specific
strains excuse me I would actually
expect that only a few patients will
actually do home cultivation because it
is somewhat complicated and takes space
going back two years ago TCM would be
held a listening session for feedback
from patients about the program and the
P the primary concerns were afford
affordability of product accessibility
of atcs and availability of specific
strains needed by a patient to treat
their symptoms the reason the strain
matters is because different cannabis
strains have different cannabinoid and
turpine profiles and that they therefore
have different effects upon the person's
symptoms several patients felt that
allowing home cultivation would at least
partly address these concerns at his
January 2023 meeting TCM reviewed the
prior Bill HP 431 and voted unanimously
that it agrees with the concept of Home
cultivation of of cannabis both by
therapeutic cannabis patients and by
caregivers then we Revisited it in
October of 2023 to review the bill for
this year and we agreed to continue our
support for the bill uh we did note that
there were some concerns voiced last
year that home cultivation would
somewhat diminish the knowledge of the
cannaboid content as we've just been
discussing uh compared to the products
that are available in atcs we agree that
this this is likely to some degree but
we note that the bill does allow again a
home cultivator to submit their cannabis
to a lab for
testing and uh this again is important
to know the canono profile and to make
sure there's no contaminants but again a
person growing their own can also be
very careful about contaminants by using
proper soil and so on and so forth the
bill also allows atcs to provide
seedlings with know and relative canabo
content to assist patients in growing
their specific they need for their
condition and seeds with no un Target
canono content are available and
federally legal now the the other thing
I think is that if in terms of safety if
somebody is growing their own and
they're going to start using from their
first their first part of a batch
they'll probably you know drop their
dose just a little bit just to kind of
see how they how it affects them to make
sure in case it perhaps has a little
higher THC than they expect but it's
also important to realize uh uh
representative Merchant did talk about
um testing and and I think the other one
about um Pharmaceuticals very true but
if we think about it generics have a
plusus 20% window of
acceptability uh and you know we some
people is that not
correct that was that was a few years
ago they've changed it down to plus 10%
okay but even then that means you could
get one batch here and and the next time
you refill it might be 20% more because
one was 10% % down there 10% up and I
think some of us may have noticed
occasionally a little bit of difference
in the response uh to a medication
anyway um I do have a couple of specific
points I want to express at this point
I'm now speaking for myself not for CCM
o because we voted on the uh uh concept
of Home cultivation but we did not
really go into the weeds to look at the
specific Lage of the bill this bill
really has robust protections with
respect to limitations in the number of
cannabis plants and the registration of
cultivation sites that have to be
enclosed and locked and these
protections should make home cultivation
safe controlled and should satisfy the
concerns of law
enforcement I disagree with one issue on
page five lines 13 to 18 it allows home
cultivation for potential qualifying
patients who have not yet been granted a
card this could be an enforcement
Nightmare and I really feel a patient
can wait for the very short time until
they have their card good start wrapping
up yep I'm I'm just about at the end in
fact only one thing Now to respond to
something earlier and that was the fate
of HB
431 uh I must say that it went to a
senate committee which has historically
been hostile to therapeutic cannabis and
I think that's why it was moved uh to D
in the table so we urge you to pass
12:31 and allow home cultivation the
reason being again to help patients with
affordability accessibility and
availability of specific strains thank
you thank you
questions representative chap
yes I know there's been thank you Mr
chairman I know there's been a lot of
talk about testing and
um and um analyzing whether
um the amount of therapeutic chemicals
and there's also talk about contaminants
and I'm wondering if there's something
specific about cannabis that makes the
issue of contaminants extra important
because I know
you're a serious home Gardener as Ami
and you know we might do soil testing
once in a while but we don't test every
um vegetable we um grow before we eat
some of it yeah well so is there
something specific about the way we
would ingest cannabis that would make
the contaminants a more significant
issue well first of all there's the
issue of heavy metals and so for example
when we do a soil test we usually they
they EX they automatically do a lead
test and you can also do a heavy metal
panel for cadmium and other things as
well so if somebody is using just soil
from their garden and they happen to be
in a place where there's a bunch of lead
that could be a problem but again if
you're if you use your brain a little
bit and you're a gardener you know not
to to do that um the other thing is mold
mold can be a problem because this is a
plant and that's actually something that
can occur even more if in terms of how
you well it can occur how you how you
grow it um I don't know about any of you
but have a greenhouse and I do sometimes
have problems with mold because of
humidity and so on and so forth so one
has to be cautious about that you can
often see it but sometimes that may be a
little bit difficult to see um if a
storage of course you could still get
mold if you're storing it in a moist
fashion but uh their basic issues about
primarily heavy metals and mold are the
other major things that we look at as
far as contaminants so those are nothing
unusual and as far as yeah we don't grow
we don't test every plant we sort of do
we take a bite of that tomato and go
that didn't turn out so well and with
this one because you are either inhaling
it or or taking it we do want it is
important that you have a rough idea but
again you can get a Seedling with no un
cannaboid contents or you can get seeds
which have at least a range that'll tell
you what what it's going to
grow other
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thank you honorable Dr kerk
um I I just have a quick question that I
don't know if you know the answer maybe
a dispensary person does but I mean to
visit one of these dispensaries is eye
opening I mean it was pretty amazing and
I'm just curious it would be
totally difficult for everybody here to
go visit one but I would assume somebody
must have a video or something about
cultivation the process what did they go
through in in the dispensary setting do
you know if that exists I'm sure there
probably are a lot of videos I know when
I've looked up specific issues about
uh lighting for for uh growing
Greenhouse or whatever you get lots of
hits that have to do with uh cannabis
growing for some reason but
um yeah I mean I think people would be
able to find issues and and again if
remember these plants are kind of big
too so it's going to be a little bit
tricky for a lot of people to grow them
um and they have to be enclosed and they
can't be out near just your garden so
yeah but I they could perhaps give you
more but I'm I'm sure there's some
videos I haven't done a Google search
but I bet you there's
questions okay seeing done all right
much also signed up to speak is Jo Dr
Joe
Hannon hello again thank you last time
today promise um
so I I try not to repeat things that
were already said we we heard a lot of
uh great testimony so far uh when I was
here I was on the Commerce Committee we
did a lot of the alcohol bills I sat on
a commission to study that and some
other commissions I was also like I said
a study commission for cannabis uh and
hom grow was always a topic that came up
um when and the first commission and
even this one it got mentioned but
didn't really get looked at um it we're
talking about home grow for medicine
we're not just this isn't recreational
nothing else we all know that but we
allow home brew and I'm sure most of you
are aware for beer and wine of less than
6% alcohol by volume uh a single
individual can have a 100 gallons a year
every year and stock pilot so there's no
possession limit you can have after 10
years you can have you know a thousand
gallons of it if you're have a spouse or
another adult in the house over 21 you
can grow up to 200 gallons maximum per
household that's equivalent to six beers
a day so I can have a if my wife and I
wanted to brew it and we don't but if we
did we could have a sixpack back every
night just from home brew now the
regulations are zero there is a limit on
how much alcohol you're allowed to have
and how many gallons there is no license
no one has to be notified there is no
testing requirement to make sure it's
only 6% or less I mean it could be 7%
accidentally there's never been a
reported problem uh you just can't sell
it and I haven't seen anything in the
news if if it's happened I'd love to
hear about it because I've testified
about this before it's a
non-issue um allowing a small amount and
50 100 foot canopy that is a very small
space if you ever seen some of these
grow facilities I've killed Cactus I
don't plan on doing this um it's not
easy to do for everybody but we're also
not talking about manufacturing a
complex pharmaceutical product
necessarily I mean there are
complexities in the Cannabis uh you know
field and they can they can vary but
you're getting cannabis of some form uh
you're not having to worry about you
know getting insulin from a do from a
dog and all this there's so many things
you need to do also I'm legally allowed
to grow any number of poisonous
substances in New Hampshire in my garden
legally no regulations whatsoever
there's mainly two poisonous plants in
New Hampshire poison hemlock and poke
weed uh they are indigenous in New
Hampshire they're just you go and you
can probably find them somewhere they're
here but I can grow black cherries uh
apple seeds contain cyanide too many can
kill a horse when horses eat lots of
them on the ground they can cause
problems there but you know Fox gloves
we get digitalis which is a heart
medication from Fox Glove I can grow
that if I wanted to no regulations no
license whatsoever don't have to tell
anybody at the state no offense um so
the lily of the valleys Angel's trumpets
morning glories there's any number of
plants Oleander some beautiful plants
many of you probably have had them in
your Gardens or seen them in gardens or
at flower shows they could kill
you cannabis will not kill you I mean
it's possible if a bail of it falls on
your head there may be a death related
to it when it happens I'm sure it'll be
news um but like I said there's no
requirements for testing and that and if
we're looking at we keep hearing in
other you know I don't want to talk
about other bills and committees but we
they talk about legalization like
alcohol if you're going to do it like
alcohol uh this is nothing like alcohol
alcohol will be way I mean if this was
like that You' be able to have hom grow
for any reason so I think it's
it's I just want you to legalized
gardening fully legalized gardening
that's it you know it's very simple it's
the only thing you really can't legally
grow except you can even grow other
really poisonous you know narcotic
things but um you can't do this could
place yes last thing the physical and
mental benefits of gardening we talked
about anxiety earlier being a big thing
thank you sorry uh I didn't tell you I
was ready for three minutes this time
sorry um but the benefits of uh the
medical the mental health and the
physical benefits of gardening are are
well known they're well documented in
research uh just being outside or the
act of gardening has been beneficial and
if anxiety is one of the leading
reported reasons that are people are
using this get outside enjoy yourself
you know
have it more therapeutic just by doing
that so there there are health benefits
other than environmental and cost so
please pass this bill and then we can
stop hearing about it for the next 12
years or so 15 years thank you
you also signed up to speak is Bill
Police
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
members of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony uh my name is Bill
bright I am a major with the New
Hampshire State Police I currently
oversee the Investigative Services
Bureau which includes all detectives for
state police um I I came to speak to you
today in opposition of this bill
um mostly because I just would like the
committee to consider uh the effects
that it may have on law enforcement to
enforce some of the the regulations that
are in this bill um the difficulty that
we may have uh
determining um who is legally a able to
grow um I know there's a a portion
carved out in this bill that says that
we could submit a a sworn affidavit uh
to get some of that information um as
well as who is if they are legally a
able to grow are they within the
regulations and if they're not does that
F then turn into a criminal
investigation or who is regulating that
part of um that determination in this
law um the example I would give to you
is that if we receive a complaint that
uh somebody who is opposed to growing
marijuana complains that that they
believe that somebody is illegally
growing marijuana we we're obligated to
go investigate that complaint um once we
get there we may or may not be able to
determine uh in a short period of time
whether the person is allowed to be able
to grow um which will cause some further
steps for law enforcement to take uh
eating up resources that could be better
used in other places um we would then
have to determine whether or not if they
were legally able able to grow if they
were within the the proper uh
regulations and as I mentioned um if
they are not um is that does that then
turn into a you have a
patient uh who we are now criminally
investigating for um the possession of
marijuana outside of what they are
allowed to have so I just think it it is
a difficult situation to put law
enforcement in um to allow the home grow
um in this
instance
where patients are able to get what they
need from the therapeutic grow uh
authorized therapeutic grow um
facilities now that is just much cleaner
enforcement okay thank you
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
with constructive feedback on this um I
would be interested in in trying to
figure out specifically what you would
need in order to make that determination
ahead of time because I know that
typically when you're dealing with drug
grows um those are probably the more
dynamic situations as opposed to more of
a wellness check so I don't know if
there's anything with checking with the
department or if there's anything else
that we can do to streamline this so
that we're not denying patients this
ability when it's appropriate but we're
also not putting law enforcement um in a
bad situation yeah so I think that in
order to get the information what the
bill says that we would need a sworn
affidavit uh that we have probable cause
to believe uh that that that somebody is
is growing marij Marana um just the word
that we get from from somebody that they
think their neighbor is growing is not
necessarily probable cause so there
would take it would take some leg work
to be able to get develop probable cause
uh to determine that um which is going
to present some problems and some
investigative work on law enforcement um
standpoint so as a follow sorry as a
followup um then would would that make
sense if we put into process that prior
to um pursuing a sworn off of davit um
that you would cross check with the I
believe I believe we said that we'd
already know the locations within the
whole the whole therapeutic cannabis
commission to to make sure that if you
were pursuing one of these that you
could confirm whether or not there was
an um an allowed homow operation at that
address before pursuing further well I
believe from uh previous testimony I
mean this would fall under uh hippo
regulations which my understanding was
is that we would need to supply a a
supporting affidavit with probable cause
um I I'll pursue that further with you
because uh Hippa Hippa allows a lot of
move movement of information I don't
claim to be an expert so I I probably
won't be able to answer your questions
intelligently okay thank
you other questions representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you Mr Bri for taking my
question I hear the concern about law
enforcement being sort of in a bind
you've got call to resident you don't
know whether the resident has the
authority to grow if I understand it
correctly if the department was to
provide to the resident a document
that's notorized and so forth that they
could give to law
enforcement that authorized them to do
that would that minimize some of the
concern you
have well I don't I don't know that I
can think of every situation that would
be difficult for law enforcement um
based on you know the result of this
this bill so it's hard for me to um you
know come up with a with a suggestion
for what would alleviate I think that it
just it leaves open the ability to abuse
um the the right to grow marijuana in a
hom grow situation which would I think
is going to create problems for law
enforcement um kind of no matter how it
is set up uh in the framework of this
bill follow up thank you and following
up on the Hippa concern my understanding
within Hippa law enforcement actually
has some limited authority to the
information within Hippa so therefore
you may have as law enforcement some
limited access to that database to begin
with so I don't know if that solves a
problem but something you may want to
consider well I don't know if I don't
know if um finding this information
would fall under those regulations and
the the allowances that we would
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you next up I believe it's Jim rle from
[Music]
Hillsboro thank you Mr chair members of
the committee Jim Riddle Hillsboro and I
uh mentioned earlier that do have a USDA
hemp grower license and in order to get
that license the first thing I needed to
do was go to my local police station and
be fingerprinted then I had to pay to
have an FBI background check then I had
to take online training from USDA I had
to set up h a farm number with the Farm
Service Agency and then do annual
reports and hemp and cannabis it's the
same species cannab Cannabis sativa and
before Harvest any crop has to be tested
if it's over point or
0.3% THC then it falls under cannabis
regulations under my hemp it gets
destroyed goes into the compost pile um
but uh in case you don't know the DEA
officially ruled uh that any cannabis
seeds and seedlings are technically hemp
because they contain no THC they don't
meet that 3% so DEA has officially
determined that any cannabis seed
regardless of its genetic potential uh
uh is hemp uh so just uh to be clear on
that I did um also mention earlier that
I'm on The Advisory Board of the New
Hampshire cannabis Association I just
wanted to uh let you know I let an
effort working with the New Hampshire
Farm Bureau and the Northeast organic
Farmers Association of New Hampshire to
do a survey last fall of farmers in the
granite state to see uh uh and this was
more about legalization but of the
farmers that responded
87% supported legalization and
78% of the respondents were interested
in becoming licensed Growers but as it
relates to our discussion right now the
most surprising result the question we
asked about support for homegrown that
was the strongest uh response we had got
89% of the respondant support allowing
New Hampshire residents to grow six to
eight plants uh for home use and that
wasn't you know specifically only
limited to Medical but there is
certainly an interest and support in the
agricultural Community uh for allowing
home grow um I I think uh something here
that's really an advantage of focusing
on the people with medical cards and
that's the first thing I would do if as
an officer was making an inquiry is show
my card and then if I have gotten a
permit to have a few plants I would
probably have an additional paperwork
showing that I can have these plants but
these are registered grower registered
people all the people that have medical
cards are already in the system system
you know who we are and we would have to
apply further to grow a few plants um
like it was
mentioned seeds are hemp they can be
sold through the mail right now
Interstate you anyone in New Hampshire
can have access to thousands of strains
through online companies um so they can
tailor that and yeah they may send it to
a lab for analysis but they might just
just try it and adjust their dose uh to
what they've uh grown but it will really
help both reduce cost improve access and
availability and I just closed by
echoing something that Dr Hannah said
just growing cannabis growing hemp
growing plants in and of itself is
therapeutic you develop a relationship
you're caring for something and uh that
alone uh I I think should be taken into
consider consideration thank you thank
you any
Kirk thank you to the chair and the rest
of the committee my name is Dr Riley
Kirk I have a PhD in pharmaceutical
sciences and I specialize in the
chemistry and pH phology of cannabis I
also hold the USDA hemp grower license
and I am an Advisory Board member for NH
can I'm here to express my overwhelming
support for HP 1231 to allow medical
cannabis patients to home cultivate the
plant Cannabis sativa I believe
cultivate cultivating a plant medicine
like cannabis should be a right not a
luxury especially for the safety and
efficacy of cannabis for dozens of
medical
conditions kissx IR iron triangle of
healthcare consists of three three
pillars access cost and quality this is
a well-studied phenomenon in healthcare
because no system has ever been able to
improve all three of these
simultaneously there is always a
tradeoff of at least one of these
factors the ability to homeg grow
medicinal cannabis is one of the only
examples of a tool that effectively can
provide all three of these in healthcare
simultaneously for for Access yes we
currently have a medical program in the
state but for everyone who lives in the
largest county Coos County like myself
we are over 1 hour from the nearest New
Hampshire dispensary some people as far
as 2 hours away this is not accessible
and this is not practical for residents
of New Hampshire the cost of cannabis at
a dispensary is often far outside of
what many disabled medical patients can
afford making it again inaccessible as
the medicine is not currently covered by
health insurance here in New Hampshire
and many other states with medical
programs the quality of the medicine
also matters many cannabis patients
prefer specific strains with unique
chemical profiles that can be difficult
to lock down in dispensaries as the
strains are often being rotated to fit
consumer demand and the available
options may not fill the niche of what
they're looking for for their desired
therapeutic benefits or they prefer
specific metrics like heighten moisture
content that aren't allowed to be
variable uh via dispensary Avenues some
examples of this strain preference that
we discussed earlier include people with
ADHD preferring tur pinolene dominant
strains people with crohn's disease
favoring strains dominant in the tpine
caropine and people with metabolic
conditions preferring strains high in
thcv and the list goes on patients can
have access to consistent personalized
and effective medicine when cultivating
at home and have the spiritual
connection to their medicine as well I
know this isn't important to everyone in
this room but for people like me who
prefer to use natural products and find
Value in cultivating their medicine the
spirituality component is an undeniable
and core value for our community and
greatly contributes to the healing
process and intention while medicating
in my opinion it is difficult to see
negatives to the ability to grow this
medicinal plant it does not come down to
the safety of New Hampshire residents it
comes down to control of who we get
where of where we get our medicine and
who financially benefits from us using
this medicine this contradicts
everything about the Live Free or Die
mentality that emphasizes and it does
emphasize everything wrong with the
current health care landscape and if we
continue to restrict hom grow we should
reconsider the slogan Live Free or Die
or I guess we're all supposed to
die to Dr Joe hannon's point I'm a
natural product chemist and I'm allowed
to legally wrapping up what was that
please please start wrapping up your
testimony okay I'll wrap up to Dr
johannah's point I'm a natural product
chemist and I'm allowed to legally grow
dozens of plants that are toxic and
small doses including the Opium poppy
that produces Codine and morphine the
cter plant which produces
a Tropa belladon Fox Glove and so many
more I have yet to hear a solid argument
against hom grow other than the fact
that some people just don't like
cannabis I don't think this is a just
answer and it should be a right to
cultivate the medicinal plant and to be
in control of the medicine that we're
using lastly and continuing the
conversation about the level of
expectations for consistency of products
a reminder that medical patients will
still have access to medical
dispensaries and indoor cultivated
products if they choose that or if they
want
extremely consistent products they can
also choose to cultivate cannabis
indoors in their home to have that
consistent profile thank you and I will
take any additional questions any
Bennett all right thank you for having
me I know it's been a long day for us
all but um I will Breeze through this um
so my name is Alicia Bennett I am fully
supportive of Bill uh 1231 which would
permit qualifying patients and
designated caregivers to cultivate
cannabis for therapeutic use um we've
heard a lot of great testimonies in
support of this bill today and I think
one thing that makes mine unique is that
I am a patient of the program and this
is something that I've wanted for a long
time and if this bill were to pass I do
plan on cultivating at home um currently
I work as the education supervisor for
granite Leaf cannabis however today here
speaking as a patient um just to give
you some quick background my experience
with medical cannabis began when I was a
student at Texas A&M University studying
horiculture with a focus on medicinal
plants and education while I was a
student I was battling a rare form of
cancer that led to the amputation of my
right arm and part of my chest wall
cannabis was more effecting more
effective for treating my severe pain
and the side effects of chemotherapy
than any of the other medications I had
been on um in 2018 when I was finally in
remission I moved back to New Hampshire
to have access to therapeutic cannabis
and I've been on the therapeutic
cannabis program for over 5 years and in
that time I've used it to to manage my
chronic pain Phantom limb sensation
insomnia nausea PTSD anxiety and
depression I believe that this bill will
benefit therapeutic canabas patients
like me in New Hampshire um I have
several other points that other people
had brought up already that legalizing
home cultivation will help people like
me with affordability it will give
people that do not have um easy access
to dispensaries um more opportunity to
grow from home and to not have to travel
as far to get access to products and
although the dispensaries do offer a
wide selection of products there are
certain cultivars that work well for
certain conditions I know there's a few
that work well for me than none of the
dispensaries in New Hampshire currently
offer um it's kind of like you think of
apples there's some apples that I really
like you can't always find in the store
um and I would grow them at home I'm a
very Avid Gardener I love horiculture I
love plants and I did of that the point
was already brought up that I do
actually have a couple of plants that
are in my garden and I know that they
are deadly and they can be used in
certain ways that um could be harmful or
kill someone however cannabis has never
been reported to um kill anyone and it
has so many therapeutic benefits which I
think we've all heard enough about today
um cannabis is one of my favorite
flowers and as a gardener I would really
love to grow it at home um this is
something that I think can be done
safely and responsibly and legalizing
hom grow will benefit the therapeutic
cannabis patients in New Hampshire thank
you for listening and I'm happy to any
answer any questions you have thank you
you also signed up to speak is Matt
cannabis I got it right that time right
granite Leaf very
good
okay again thank you committee for the
record Matt Simon Granite Leaf
cannabis uh we support this bill and I
will avoid repeating the many excellent
points that have been made I agree with
them I'll try to say something new um
so 10 years ago I and a lot of other
folks were in this exact committee we
were wearing stickers that said patients
not criminals support HB 648 I think it
was we had the same stickers made
several times for different bills but
the slogan patience not criminals was
the argument at the time it was a crime
to possess or cultivate cannabis and we
were arguing that the legislature should
make a narrow exception for qualified
patients which ended up happening in
2013 um I would argue that this bill is
consistent with that original sentiment
so we are sometimes talking about health
care policy when we talk about
therapeutic cannabis we're sometimes
talking about criminal justice policy
and civil liberties and the intersection
between those and Health Care policy and
I suggest representative Nagel you're
far from the first clinician who has uh
found some tension and difficulty
between those two concepts if we were
talking about approving homegrown
cannabis through the FDA or or some
process like that we wouldn't do it for
all the reasons that that have been
brought up but I would argue we are at
the intersection between healthc care
policy and uh criminal justice civil
liberties policy if patients choose to
grow their own and I will tell you that
I have known patients who choose to grow
their own in New Hampshire since 20078
when I started doing this work I know
several patients who have moved to other
states because they got tired of fearing
law enforcement and uh wanted cared so
much about this they were willing to
move elsewhere that includes my good
friend Ted Wright who was a co-sponsor
of the bill in 2013 he went on to
sponsor this bill several times failed
and then moved to Maine out of
frustration
with our not very Live Free or Die
policies um so I would say from the
perspective of the at I can't speak for
all the atcs I'll speak for our
leadership team we all view this as a
civil liberties issue we are not looking
at this at all as a bottom line issue it
is not going to help our bottom line it
may hurt it a little bit I'm not sure uh
we could sell seedlings and make a
little bit of money
uh probably the biggest benefit would
would be that it would give patients who
feel strongly about homow an incentive
to register for this program rather than
moving to another state or simply
growing uh on their own without being a
registered patient so I think it would
be healthy for the program as a whole uh
but the way we look at it you know the
way I'm looking at it uh current law is
if you manufacture more than 1 ounce of
marijuana I say marijuana because I'm
referring to 318b the criminal code if
you manufacture more than 1 ounce of
marijuana that is a felony in the state
uh if you're familiar with the New
Hampshire Constitution part one article
18 uh says all penalties ought to be
proportioned uh to the nature of the
offense in this case the offense is
gardening and uh I would argue that it
is inappropriate to have a felony
penalty associated with cultivating
cannabis based on everything we've heard
today today uh I'll answer one question
that came up somebody asked why 12
seedlings if you're only able to grow
three plants so I think that presumes
that somebody's growing from seeds if
you buy seeds Okay so you can buy seeds
that have been feminized and you have
pretty good certainty that they will
come up as female plants wrapping up my
last Point Mr chairman uh but if the
seeds are not feminized they have a 50%
chance of being male or female and male
plants are not particularly useful for
therapeutic purposes so the idea is at
least some of your plants will be female
and you'll be able to select the
seedlings that show female
characteristics and grow those as your
mature plants while destroying the
others happy to take any questions any
questions seeing n thank you very much
thank
you also signed up to speak is Tatiana
White
can you push the button on your
microphone thank you so very much good
afternoon chairman and members of the
committee my name is Tatiana white I am
an Advisory Board member of the New
Hampshire cannabis Association I hold a
USDA hemp grow license and I'm a founder
of the rich hemp wellness company based
out of lton New Hampshire I stand before
you today to voice my strong support for
the hom grow Bill introduced by the
representative Thomas the ability to
cultivate cannabis for therapeutic
purposes is more than just a matter of
convenience it's a fundamental aspect of
compassionate Health Care as a wellness
business owner and a fomy patient myself
I meet many individuals with various
chronic health issues and speaking of
myself self fibromyalgia comes with a
bouquet of symptoms such as chronic
fatigue syndrome whole body pain and
somnia anxiety depression chronic
migraines and many many
others for many patients such as myself
access to dispensaries can be
challenging due to Geographic
geographical Financial or physical
limitations there are times when my
Fibromyalgia symptoms are so severe that
driving to a dispensary 1 and a half
hours away is simply not
feasible home cultivation offers a
viable alternative ensuring that such
individuals such as myself have
uninterrupted access to this medication
cannabis cultivation at home empowers
patients and caregivers to have greater
control over their treatment it allows
for the customization of cannabis
strains to suit specific medical needs
potency and personal preferences which
is often not possible with limited
dispensary selections this tailored
approach can lead to a more effective
symptom management and an overall better
quality of life moreover home
cultivation can be a more costeffective
solutions for those who cannot afford it
the cost associated with purchasing
cannabis from dispensaries can be
prohibitive to some I met I personally
met many patients who just simply cannot
afford to purchase enough cannabis from
dispensaries for themselves um and
allowing at home can significant reduce
this financial strain for these
individuals um so as a as uh others
mentioned that it makes it affordable it
makes it easier uh to access this
medication and also I just want to add a
personal note as well that as a USDA
licensed hemp grower when I received my
license I contacted our local police
department to let them know that I have
a license to grow a hemp and I told them
where I'm going to grow it maybe
therapeutic cannabis hom Growers could
possibly do the same so that local
police knows who legally grows under
their jurisdiction in conclusion I urge
the esteemed members of this legislative
body to support Bill HP 1231 by passing
this bill you are not just legalizing an
activity you're providing relief
autonomy and dignity to countless
individuals who depend on therapeutic
cannabis for their well-being and health
thank you for your attention this
crucial M
matter do you have any questions thank
questions I'm seeing done thank you
thank
you
chair 15 seconds to to retract a
statement I made that was an error in my
testimony earlier it only Tak 15 seconds
okay I'm going to time you 15 seconds I
think those of you who know me know that
I don't like making errors and I sure
don't want it to be out there when I
made it when tcob reviewed this bill we
reviewed the LSR version um I objection
to the bill which was stated in the
second page of my testimony about page
five lines 13 to 18 that is no longer it
does not have to do with cultivation so
what I said was incorrect and I just
wanted to retract that thank you okay
thank you exactly 15 seconds wow he's
got an innate sense of timing
testifier also signed up to speak is
Heather
Stockwell
from rad New
Hampshire all right is this on this time
somebody left it on for me thank you yep
on uh thanks so much for for hearing
from me I I do think that uh most of the
people that have spoken already have
have spoken uh about a lot of the things
that I was uh thinking about saying but
I really I I've heard a lot from atc's
and um or from that sort of perspective
if you will and I um I'm really here
about the caregiver perspective my my
husband uh is a licensed caregiver in
the state he's also a USDA hemp licens
grower um in the state and
um we've testified about uh this many
times in the past I fully support this
bill um I'd like to see anyone uh be
able to grow their own not not just
caregivers um I think this is really
reasonable and one of the the things
that uh Matt Simon said before is about
the different policies in different
states and that's something that I've
been really looking at um because I also
have a Horticultural background I've
worked for organic farms and I'm
currently uh I currently grow um house
plants uh in my house and hope to
someday in maybe my retirement uh have
some sort of greenhouse business um it
is very therapeutic for me there's also
other qualities about growing indoor
plants where your air quality is better
Etc Etc um some of those differences um
for instance Massachusetts if you are a
licensed
caregiver their policy is that you can
maintain a 60-day supply for each
patient it does not mention uh seedlings
in the in the web page that I was on um
and maybe that's because those seedlings
aren't not counted on some level because
they are considered hemp um and in Maine
also another bordering state uh one that
we have considered moving to as we were
also hearing people testify about and
I've lived here for over 50 years I want
to make that clear um you can grow 30
mature plants 60 immature and there's no
limit on seedlings so we're we're asking
for a very small amount here I would I
think nationally the average is probably
around 12 uh this is super super
reasonable I um I'd like to see
something a little bit different but I I
think this is a great
start see how it goes I I really I
sympathize with what the state police
said but on some but I on another level
I I understand that there are Provisions
that allow them to
check uh so I don't I feel like that's
kind of a non-issue and another grower
just testified that they reached out to
their local law enforcement to tell them
not everybody wants to do that maybe
because they know how their law
enforcement might respond to that call
uh so or they might be targeted in other
ways so I I think that's up to
um please start wrapping up okay uh yeah
I I I I
guess that that's maybe really it I just
I think this is so reasonable that it
doesn't seem like a really big lift uh
for the committee to to support this
bill um wholeheartedly I think there's
there's plenty of structure around it
for patients uh and their caregivers I
just for me it's really about economic
freedom also um I am I I know I talk to
people about their Healthcare all the
time and uh a lot of people can't even
afford their health care let alone Be
being able to go to an ATC and afford
the prices there so this would allow
people to grow this on their own or have
their caregiver grow it for them uh for
maybe maybe a fee but it would be a very
nominal nominal fee to get the medicine
they need when it's something that is
not supported by our current health care
industry or insurance industry thank you
thank you any questions hi
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair during a
testimony you talked about the
compensation as far as with patients and
caregivers if I look at page two yes yes
I read that line 26 27
mm it says not to exceed $500 per
calendar year is that per patient or is
that now I'm trying to get to is that if
I'm I'm not I'm not sure because I
didn't write this bill so um so the way
I read it we could possibly have
somebody taking care of 10 patients no
no no no our state and actually
Massachusetts Maine and and New
Hampshire is is five five patients for a
caregiver where does it say that uh it
is where it says
page uh 11 line 11 has agrees not to
exceed five qualifying patients in the
therapeutic use of cannabis unless you
live more than 50 miles away from an ATC
or the car or the patient so if I'm in
North Country if I understand this
correctly I'm more than 50 Mi away that
doesn't
apply what what are you saying doesn't
apply if I'm more than 50 miles away
then if you're are you a caregiver yes
or a patient you can have nine patients
if you are more than 50 miles away and
your patients are thank you um you know
I I think there are some things that
could be clearer I'm I'm a little bit
unclear about um some of the wording too
so
uh I'm I'm happy to yeah go for it
representative
kosman thank you Mr chairman for
indulging me um in section nine of the
bill it's on page three um if you look
at um I on line 21 the designated
caregivers cultivation location where he
or she may cultivate cannabis on behalf
of a single qualifying patient who is
not reported a cultivation location so
they can
[Music]
only
um from what it uh from what was said in
the testimony earlier I think this is
where it's saying that only one um they
can only have one
patient so they can only grow for one
patient is that what you're saying
that's what my understanding and I just
want to try to get to is that for
clarification we heard from law
enforcement the difficulty in trying to
enforce this I want to be sure that we
don't add more
difficulty to law enforcement to try to
all other
questions great thank you okay thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on this bill representative Thomas yeah
can I just add two points sure okay
thank you very quick not as quick as
Jerry but um almost as quick um there
was there was a question about
educational material I am actually going
to be working this summer um with uh
some growers in Maine and we're going to
be videotaping and documenting exactly
how to grow from seed or how to get from
seed to use so I'm working with somebody
who is going we're going to do this for
outside growing as well as someone who
is going to do this with me for inside
growing I would never put forward a bill
that doesn't have educational material
behind it I'm a tech writer a course
developer and an instructional designer
so educ is my is Is My Jam um and lastly
the the other point that I wanted to add
in growing plants you don't just use the
bud for the flour um there's a lot of
people that will take the leaves and put
them in smoothies just like you put
spinach leaves in smoothies there's
there's a lot of nutrition in the leaves
there's there's cannabinoids in the
leaves um it's a very beneficial plant
thank you thank
you okay with that um I have no one else
signed up to testify so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
1231 and open the public hearing on
House Bill
1171 uh and recognize representative
sponsor
sorry representative Murphy we need a
it thank you chairman McDonald and um
good afternoon to honorable members of
the committee my name is Nancy Murphy I
represent the town of mar Mech which is
Hillsboro District 12 um today um I come
as Vice chair of the commission to ask
for your consideration and support for
HB
11171 which will reestablish the
currently existing Commission on
environmentally triggered chronic
illness this commission has done great
work since its Inception and as there
remains a need will hopefully be allowed
to proceed
uninterrupted so that it might continue
that work uh though representative Lyon
is a member not every uh member here may
be familiar with this commission so I've
handed out some documents for your
review uh which include a copy of the
current commission statute created by s
sp85 in 2019 the commission's most
recent annual
report a bit of an overview about the uh
the composition charge and scope of the
commission and the most recent progress
report from
DHHS as President Ronald Reagan said in
his 1984 State of the Union Address
preservation of our environment is not a
liberal or conservative challenge it's
Common Sense over the years we've
learned that when we preserve and
protect our environment we protect human
health and ecosystems we've also
discovered that when we fail to protect
our environment we compromise Public
Health far too many New Hampshire
citizens lives have been altered due to
a chronic illness diagnosis known to be
associated with environmental triggers
like past voc's mtbe arsenic lead radon
cyanobacteria pesticides and other
contaminants citizens are left to seek
health care and incur costs for illness
is linked to such things as the products
they use jobs they do air they breathe
water they drink and soil in which their
food is grown in 2019 the sb85 statement
of intent read read as follows the
general court recognizes that nearly
half of adults in the United States have
at least one chronic health condition
and chronic disease Es are responsible
for increased health care costs 70% of
health care costs in the United States
are for chronic ill chronic diseases
some chronic diseases are known or
thought to be associated with
environmental
causes according to the Centers for
Disease Control the state of New
Hampshire has the highest rates of
people with bladder breast esophageal
and pediatric cancer in the country in
addition a double pediatric cancer
cluster was identified in the Sea Coast
of New Hampshire in 14 therefore the
general court hereby establishes the
commission to study environmentally
triggered chronic
illness it's one of New Hampshire's
statutory environmental commissions and
though there's some overlap amongst the
environmental commissions each has a
different and specific Focus um you can
see that on page seven of the
environmentally triggered disease um and
chronic illness commission handout this
commission is focused upon broad issues
environmental exposure the systems
necessary to identify and address in
environmentally triggered disease and
the work of the subcommittees within
Education data and the kle super fund
the environmentally triggered chronic
illness commission is focused on
conducting environmental health
surveillance and improving coordination
and collaboration between Dees and
DHHS to allow resources efficiently to
reduce exposure to environmental
contaminant and prevent disease to that
end Dees and DHHS have entered into an
memorandum of understanding relative to
data sharing and an operating procedure
on how data layers can be shared between
the two departments to identify linkages
between environmental contaminants and
health
outcomes over time it's hoped that the
work of this commission can help lead to
widespread public health benefits
including improvements in average life
expectancy when it was looking for a
home a few years back and on the advice
of this commission this committee excuse
me as to where to put it this uh
committee to the Mission took on the
task of creating a subcommittee focused
upon providing education to clinicians
relative to the PS exposure of their
patients right now that subcommittee uh
consists of Dr patali uh the New
Hampshire Dees toxicologist uh Dr Peg
dulio she's advanced practice nurse
practitioner um geel School of Medicine
Dartmouth epidemiologist Dr Megan romano
and myself a retired nurse impacted
Community member environmental Public
Health advocate and
legislator the education subcommittee
continues to work collaboratively to
provide Education and Training relative
to PFS and other environmental toxins to
clinicians and other Health Care
Professionals with the goal to improve
patient care going forward the
commission still has work to do we' like
to further develop recommendations
related to core topics surveillance
reporting communication and capacity
building members of the health and data
subcommittees have also determined a
need to create a New Hampshire ented
centered database of environmental
threats and environmentally triggered
diseases based on the list maintained by
the National Institute of Health until
2017 that work has just begun thank you
for your time attention and
consideration of HB 1171 I urge you to
vote OTP to support and allow the
condition the commission to continue its
work thank you thank you any
questions representative Parmer I when
um last week we looked at um HB 1393
which is uh looking specifically at
pediatric cancers and asking the State
Health Improvement plan to look into
that as a bill and I'm just wondering if
this is a little redundant I mean so
that's one part of this the other part
was I'm on that commission and at our
last meeting I sort of brought up the
idea that instead of having to have a
bill for that they would just do it but
I'm just wondering if you know have two
different commissions looking at the
same thing if that makes sense or
whether there should be a little more
discussion there and and and or at least
sharing of the data so neither one has
to work as much right thank you for your
question um I the commission on
environmentally triggered chronic
illness um it when I talked about the
overlap um on the
commissions the difference between this
commission and some of the others and I
I think like the the PS commission which
is hb7 37 and HB 485 which is the SE
Coast um uh
commission this commission focuses on
Broad environmental issues um and on
systems um needed to identify and
address environmental diseases
um talking about the Pediatric cancer I
mean that's um it's interesting you
bring that up because one of the that
the uh a bill that we came before I
think it was HB 614 which was passed out
of this committee and went to finance uh
um excuse me was funded the the uh
kidney cancer study in March um those
are that recommendation came from this
commission um so it's it's widespread
it's not just about cancer it's about
natural contaminants it's about um part
particulate contaminants in the
environment um and it's looking
at um you know the whole state it's not
particular to like the PFS commission
the the the uh HB 737 is particular to
Southern New Hampshire and St gobain um
so there is some overlap and I I think
possibly the the um State Health
Improvement plan I mean I think we often
have um presentations between
commissions so that that information is
shared and we don't have to reinvent the
wheel on some things um but you know
we're we um we have presentations and
ongoing collaboration with Dees DHHS
they're part of the commission um and
when there when there is an overlap um
and there's information to to which
would benefit any of the commissions we
you know we join them or they join us
and and um I think it's a it's been a
great way to to educate a larger group
and and um you know move to to make
change where we can thank you sure other
questions representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question I just have a question because
we were talking about the State Health
Initiative assessment commission and one
of our big discussions the other day was
was well we're developing ideas but how
does this actually become real I'm
curious like in your your um in this
committee Community commission whatever
yeah how have you been able to make
things become real besides just bringing
attention to the problem exists so how
change one of thank you for that
question one of the things we do is um
and I think it's in
your handout it the charges of
commission are identified and I think
it's
on on this handout it's got a list of um
of the charges
it on part three it talks about um the
study that that which to look at but
also the things that the commission can
do um and those are numbered um
and what's listed there is the things
that we have done we've worked um with
DHHS uh around public uh health
education whether it was an issue of
pest or lead or um you know those things
Health provider Health provider
education you know we have so many um
health providers that we've seen being
in Mar
we found that citizens had had more
knowledge of the issue than health
providers because years ago you know
that wasn't environmental medicine
wasn't the largest chunk of a a medical
education and these are relatively new
contaminant so everybody's learning and
so um the commission the um subcommittee
has worked hard to um educate uh
establish networking within New
Hampshire Hospital Association um
specialty programs we do presentations
at uh be our third year in April the
Northern New England nurse practitioners
conference um and I think it's been very
well received it's been a lot of really
good feedback and it and it's alerted us
to things that that maybe we should be
looking at um so I think there's a lot
of um changes that we can make when we
know there an a problem exists and in
collaboration with Dees and
DHHS um we look to you know where we can
address them whether it's by legislation
or the work of an individual
subcommittee um and I I think there's
they might actually I don't have it with
me but we did have a list of the all of
the legislation recommendations for
legisl uh legislation that came out of
committee representative Shapero thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking
this question I know that nationally
I've read that nationally there is been
in um lung cancer among young
females female
non-smokers um and I wonder if that's
been identified as um an issue of study
in New Hampshire through your commission
um thank you for your question actually
it has not but in that same packet um
there's a page um says New Hampshire
centered index of environmental
exposures and that's part of the work
that we would like to be able to
continue to do um is to identify um
areas of Health concern public health
concerns and you know we have I just use
PS because it's an easy one and and
people are really familiar with it um
but you know we're looking at PS how how
it affects our water um cons Commerce um
which parts of the state we know that
that that Wells all over New Hampshire
are testing positive private Wells are
testing positive for pest but certain
areas are certainly more impacted
Southern New Hampshire um and the Sea
Coast um so we're looking at you know
making a list right now of what what do
we need to focus on um you know are we
saying like for example in March we hear
anecdotal stories all the time about
people say I have this cancer I I can't
tell you the number of calls I've got um
since the that HB 614 passed which funds
the the kidney cancer study people that
are living out of the state um and said
hey I'm not included in your numbers can
you please connect me with DHHS um those
kinds of things happen and we hear
anecdotal stories from people that say
you know I live there not only do I have
kidney cancer but I have thyroid
disorders that's one of the things that
I certainly think needs to be looked
into because we're hearing a lot do we
have the data no we don't but that's how
um you know I think I mentioned before
when when I came here before uh about HB
614 my goal originally was really for a
a a full epidemiological health study
for the MARC Community we have about 207
28,000 people um and we long believed
that we had a higher incidence of cancer
and I also think thyroid disorders we
have no data there's nobody collecting
the data um you know for a number of
reasons and that was one of the things
that that I IID hoped for recognizing
that we finally did see over time in
2018 we were told no you're you know the
cancer numbers are completely cons
consistent with what we would expect and
then 5 years later we have what we
thought we were saying so um it's things
like that that that rise to the top and
we're trying to create this index of
exposures and health outcomes um to see
to sort of help Drive what you know what
do what do we need to do that drives
legislation it drives
education um and so um just some of the
goals of the of the of the
commission okay other
you also signed up to speak is
rung thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rosemary rung and I represent
M the town of marac Hill Hillsboro
District 12 I'm here to speak
specifically about one aspect of the
hb85 or the the sb85 commission that
makes it a very important it's very
important to keep that commission going
some of you may be aware that over the
past few years I've been driving more
attention um on cyanobacteria blooms and
the risk that they pose to um Granite
Staters um back a few years ago uh my
bill HB 1066 was passed which mandated
that the department of of Environmental
Services compile or or um develop a
strategic plan to address the growing
trend of cyanobacteria blooms in the
state they issued that report in
November and one of the major components
of it is they have to um educate Granite
State ERS more about the health threats
posed by exposures to blooms and in fact
tomorrow at the Senate the the S sp85
commission meeting tomorrow afternoon
they're having a presentation by Dr
Elijah STL who is a neurologist at
Dartmouth Hitchcock he's also a
neurology professor at the geel school
of medicine at Dartmouth and he's been
one of the global researchers leading um
research on the connection between
cyanotoxins specifically a a chemical
called bmaa which is beta methyl Amino
alanine and its role in um uh um or it's
link to uh ALS Alzheimer and and now
Parkinson's disease so it's for my
corner of the cyano bacteria issue
education is extremely important and the
role that Senate bill
HB s sp85 commission plays in gathering
that information not only to educate
them and their membership but also to be
a conduit to how do we educate the
public on exposure risks is really
critical um it's going to be critical to
the the success of this plan to drive
that education component but we need a
group like the commission to be able to
identify experts that can put everything
in context um as far as the risk and
exposure goes and also to work with Dees
and DHHS
on delivering this information um so I
do urge you uh to pass on HB 1171 so
that this commission can continue its
work but um importantly to me to
continue the work in
cyanobacteria so I would be happy to
answer any questions you have thank you
you and guess who's next representative
Wendy Thomas and you said you weren't
today yes I apologize um I am here again
like a bad Penny uh Wendy Thomas town of
marac um as you know I live in in the
town of marac and it is completely
contaminated with past chemicals as you
likely remember following the discovery
of a 42% higher rate of kidney and renal
pelvis cancers in the town of March as
compared to other uh New Hampshire
communities DHHS determined that a phase
3 kidney cancer feasibility study was
appropriate and necessary marac is home
to St goane boo a well-known industrial
polluter a heavily p contaminated
community and has been identified by a
former Dees assistant commissioner or
has been identified as um as the site of
the largest industrial uh environmental
industrial disaster in New Hampshire's
history we know that cancer can be
environmentally triggered uh chronic
illness and that kidney cancer is linked
to pasas and that
peoa to which the marac community has
great exposure causes cancer this was
just determined recently by a
subcommittee of the
wh a contract between Dartmouth College
and NHD uh DHHS was recently approved by
the governor and Council and it allows
this important health study to move
forward the recommendation for the marac
kidney cancer investigation came from
this
commission personally my Dartmouth
Hitchcock oncologists believe so
strongly that past chemicals caused my
cancer I bre cancer that they have coded
my cancer as being environmentally
triggered by environmental
toxins um there is no code for PS
poisoning right now so that's the best
they can do uh this important commission
which will be extended by HB uh 1171
looks at the relationship between
pollutants and the health impacts that
they uh Health impacts they are known or
suspected to cause this this very
important commission should continue
doing its very good
work thank you any
questions see no questions thank
Murphy thank you for indulging me I
noticed a couple of edits that probably
should made should be
made on page
two um of the the uh
of the original bill it's are we talking
about sb85 yeah sb85 yep and just
because the 1171 just reestablished it
just extends the end date but two a
couple of things have changed um just in
our in our last session um on page two
we could should we should delete number
11 because it references a pilot study
program uh that's that is has ended so
if we could just delete number
11 the one that says reviewing result El
say yes and then on page
three um again uh a reporting
requirement has changed for DHHS so on
let's see on Roman numeral 3 where it
says on on the bottom honor before
September 1st 2019 and at a minimum
every six months it should be changed to
every 12
months page three is said yes under
Roman numeral 3
much wait one right
here yeah so the whole L the whole
section no I'll change that every 12
months okay uh no one else has signed up
to testify on HB
1171 um and that is all that we have
noticed for today so with that um I'm
going to declare adjournment and we will
meet again next week uh next um the 25th
right yeah yes we'll be reconvening on
evening